WELCOME YOU TO THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SENATE GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE COMMITTEE WE'RE GONNA
BE CALLING THE MEETING TO ORDER.
WE'RE GOING TO WELCOME THE EACH
OF YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
JOINING US ON THIS THURSDAY.
THAT WE HAVE THREE ITEMS THAT
WE LIKE TO ACCOMPLISH RIGHT NOW
FIRST AND FOREMOST WE LIKE TO
TALK ABOUT THE MEETING HELLO.
SECONDLY WE LIKE TO ESTABLISH A
QUORUM. THIRD WE LIKELY TO TALK
ABOUT HOW TO PARTICIPATE IF
YOU'RE A MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING
FROM YOU. FOR TODAY'S HEARING
ME FOURTEEN BILLS ARE ON THE
AGENDA. ELEVEN WITH AUTHORS AND
THREE PROPOSED FOR CONSENT. THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IS AS FOLLOWS.
ITEM NUMBER THREE ITEM NUMBER
THREE. FIFTY FOUR THREE FOUR
SEVEN. ITEM SIX SB THREE FOUR
SB FOUR FOUR FOUR. FIVE AM
TWELVE SB FOUR THREE ONE.
THAT'S OUR CONSENT CALENDAR FOR
TODAY. WHAT REMIND FOLKS THAT
EACH SIDE OF THE DEBATE EACH
SIDE OF THE DEBATE WILL BE
GIVEN EQUAL TIME ON EACH OF THE
BILLS. THE CHAIR MAY INSTITUTE
TIME LIMITS BUT AGAIN A
REMINDER THOSE WHO ARE IN
SUPPORT AND THOSE WHO ARE NOT.
I WILL BE GIVEN EQUAL TIME. ALL
AUTHORS WILL BE PRESENTING HERE
IN ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE
TODAY. WILL BE TAKING BILLS IN
THE AGENDA. WITH THE EXCEPTION
OF THE VICE CHAIR AND CHAIR WHO
ARE PRESENT LAST. IN LADIES AND
GENTLEMAN WE WILL BE TAKING
SENATOR Y. CAO SKI. SB TWO
SEVEN FOUR FIRST TODAY SO SB
TWO SEVEN FOUR WILL BE FIRST.
VICE CHAIR NIELSEN. AND OTHER
CHAIRS BILLS WILL BE PRESENTED
LAST FALL OTHERS WILL BE IN THE
GYM THE ORDER. MAZEN GENTLEMAN
COMMITTEE BEFORE WE HEAR
PRESENTATION ON EACH OF THE
BILLS. LET'S ESTABLISH A QUORUM
WE'RE GOING TO WELCOME OUR
CHIEF CONSULTANT CONGRESS NOW
IS A CONSULTANT CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR MCGUIRE-
REQUIRE PRESENT SENATOR NIELSEN
YEAH NIELSEN PRESIDENT SENATOR
DORADO. DORADO PRESIDENT
SENATOR HERTZBERG. SENATOR
WIENER. WIENER PRESENT YOU HAVE
A QUORUM THE QUORUM HAS BEEN
ESTABLISHED LAYS IN GERMAN WE
KNOW THAT FOLKS HAVE OTHER
COMMITTEES THAT ARE MOVING
RIGHT NOW. SO WILL BE SEEN
CENTER DRIVE SO IN JUST A BIT.
PLEASE IN GENERAL IN RESPONSE
TO THE COVERT NINETEEN
EMERGENCY AND TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC LEGISLATORS AND
EMPLOYEES. WE ARE GOING TO
LIMIT NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS
IN HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING
AND FACE COVERING GUIDELINES.
IN COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO. NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE.
PROCESS TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
PROCESS WE'VE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO HEARINGS. TO
BE EXTENDED SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW. IN WE'RE
GONNA BE USING A TELECONFERENCE
ORVIS FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO
WISH TO TESTIFY TODAY. IF YOU'D
LIKE TO BE TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY
TODAY ON THE BILLS THAT ARE IN
FRONT OF US. WE LOOK FORWARD TO
HEARING FROM YOU. HERE'S THE
NUMBER THAT YOU SHOULD BE
CALLING IN. ONE EIGHT FOUR
FOUR. TWO NINE ONE SIX THREE
SIX FOUR THAT NUMBER IS ON YOUR
SCREEN IF YOU'D LIKE TO
COMMENT. ON ANY BILLS THAT ARE
BEING ADVANCE IN THIS COMMITTEE
PLEASE CALL EIGHT FOUR FOUR.
TWO NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX
FOUR. THE ACCESS CODE IS. SIX
FIVE FOUR TWO EIGHT NINE SEVEN.
WHEN WE MOVE THE PUBLIC. YOU
WILL BE PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR
TO DIAL ONE THEN ZERO FOR
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. IN THE
UNLIKELY EVENT THAT ANY
INDIVIDUAL IS DISRUPTIVE TO THE
TODAY THAT INDIVIDUAL MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE MEETING
SERVICE OR HAD THEIR CONNECTION
MEETING. WE'RE GOING TO BE
TAKING DEAD TODAY'S HEARING
SLOW AND STEADY AND WE ASK THAT
ALL INVOLVED PLEASE HAVE A
LITTLE BIT OF PATIENCE WE'RE
GONNA GET THROUGH IT TOGETHER.
THERE MAY BE SOME LAG TIMES FOR
PARTICIPANTS WHO ARE ADJUSTING
TO THE NEW USE OF ONLINE TOOLS
AND TECHNOLOGIES AND IT'S GOING
TO BE ALL GOOD. THE LADIES IN
GERMAN WE'RE NOW GOING TO GET
STARTED. AND WE'RE GOING TO
WELCOME SENATOR MCCASKEY SONORA
CASKEY IS GOING TO BE
PRESENTING ON S. B. TWO SEVEN
FOUR. THIS BILL FOCUS ON LOCAL
GOVERNMENT MEETINGS SIDERITE
CASKEY THE FLOOR'S YOURS IN
GOOD THURSDAY MORNING TO YOU.
THANK YOU OUT MISTER ARCHER AND
THINK FOR THE ACCOMMODATION AND
SB TWO SEVENTY FOUR WHILE
SIMPLE IS A VERY IMPORTANT-
MEASURE BECAUSE IT MAKES IT
EASIER FOR OUR CONSTITUENTS. TO
BE INFORMED ABOUT THE ACTIONS
AT THEIR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE
TAKING AND ALSO ALLOW SOME TIME
TO VOICE THEIR CONCERNS. THIS
IS THE PROBLEM AND NOT SHALL
THE BROWN ACT WHICH WEALL.
HAIL IS A GREAT ACT ONLY
REQUIRES LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
SMALE AGENDA PACKETS OUT TO THE
PUBLIC. IF THEY REQUESTED IT
HAS TO BE THE SNAIL MAIL. THAT
LEADS TO SEVERAL PROBLEMS WITH
WELL DOCUMENTED TO. POSTAL
SERVICES HAVING. A LITTLE BIT
OF TIME GETTING THE MAIL
DELIVERED IN A IN A SPEEDY WAY
SOMETIMES- OF. THE MAIL THE
PACKETS ARE DELIVERED AFTER THE
MEETINGS CONCLUDED. AND ALSO
SOME JURISDICTIONS ALL REQUIRE
CERTIFIED MAIL SO THAT THE THAT
MEANS THAT THE REQUESTER HAS TO
BE PHYSICALLY PRESENT TO SIGN
FOR THE MAIL. WHEN IT'S
RECEIVED. BY THEM. WHAT WHAT'S
EFFECTIVE. SOMETIMES IT PUSHES
THE DELIVERY DATE OUT EVEN
FURTHER WHICH MEANS THAT THEY-
THEY MISTOOK PICKED OUT. THE
AGENDA AND ALSO- THE REQUESTED
MAYBE HAVE SCHOOL AND WORK AND
OTHER THINGS THIS IS NOT
CONVENIENT. AND LASTLY A LOT OF
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE ABLE TO
CHARGE THIS. A SERVICE CHARGE
FOR THIS ORIGINAL. PRINT
XEROXING AND- AND MAILING AND
THAT'S SORT OF AN UNNECESSARY
BURDEN WHEN YOU CONSIDERING
THAT THERE'S A QUICKER AND
CHEAPER WAY. TO DELIVER THESE
PACKETS AND THAT'S BY EMAIL%
SAID THE BILL BASICALLY THAT
SAYS IS THAT. ALLOWS PEOPLE OF
THE WATER REQUEST AN EMAIL
DELIVERY OF THE PACKETS. THAT
THEY CAN RECEIVE IT AND I HAVE
ADRIAN RISK IN WITH THE LOS
ANGELES SUNSHINE COALITION. TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR CAST WERE GOING TO
GO TO OUR FOR. LEAD SUPPORT WE
NEED WE ONLY. ONE LEADS. WE ARE
WRECK. WE DON'T HAVE ANY LEAD.
WHICH IS RECALL HERE TODAY.
ONCE WE HEAR FROM OUR LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESS. HOLDEN GO
TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY TO BE TO
SEE IF WE HAVE ANY TESTIMONY
THERE. THEN WE'RE GING TO GO
TO OUR TELECONFERENCE LINE.
MADAME MODERATOR LET'S OPEN UP
THE LINE TO ADRIN RISKING FROM
THE LOS ANGELES SUNSHINE
COALITION. IS RISKING YOU HAVE
THREE MINUTES THREE MINUTES
I'LL GIVE YOU THIRTY SECOND
PROMPT THE FLOOR IS YOUR
RESTORING USER IN YOUR NOW IN
COMMITTEE. OKAY THANK YOU I'M.
I'M GETTING AN ECHO ON MY OWN
IS THAT NORMAL- I APOLOGIZE.
I'M NOT SURE YOU KNOW YOU MAY
HAVE IT ON SPEAKER IF IT'S ON
SPEAKER. ARE YOU I DO YOU HAVE
A COMPUTER ON IT WE MAY BE
GETTING FEEDBACK FROM THE
COMPUTER AS WELL. IT STOPPED
NOW THAT. PLEASE PROCEED WITH
YOUR RISK IN HAVING ME. AND AT
I'M TRYING. M. DOT. RIGHT NOW
THE BROWN ACT. LOCAL
LEGISLATIVE BODY IT'S PUBLIC
WITH. I FELT. BOTH PEOPLE WE
GAVE. DR DOT YEAH TO PROVIDE.
BY THE PROP. WELL WHEN I AND
YEAH. THE FIRST PEOPLE WHO
REQUIRE SERVICE WORK TAKE UP
YOU ON MUTE YOUR CAN NOW NAY A
QUITE BADLY YOUR BREAKING UP SO
WHAT I TO BE ABLE DO WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE THE T. MODERATOR
TAX MYSTERY IN AS- MATT
MODERATOR WE CAN PLAY. MEET
WITNESS. RIGHT BERMAN ADAM
FORGET PLEASE MEET THE- YEAH
ALL I'M WITH. I WHILE I NOT.
REMEMBER I MAILED WE'RE GOING
TO ASK FOR MORE TIME IF WE
COULD PLEASE ME THE WHAT. THANK
YOU IF ANY. THANK YOU MUCH SO
WHAT WERE GONNA DO MY MODERATE
I'M GONNA YOU COULDN'T. WITH
HER WITNESS. CAN ADD RE. THAT
CAN. SO THAT CAN GET IT AT THE
CONNECT OUT FOR OUR LEAD
WOULDN'T. SO IF IT'S ALRIGHT
WITH THE COMMITTEE I'D LIKE TO
GO CHECK IN. WITH ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. THEN I'D LIKE TO BE ABLE
TO GO TOWARD TELECONFERENCE
LINE AND I'D LIKE TO GO BACK TO
MISTER RISKIN- SO THAT WE CAN
GET A BETTER. CONNECTION
ESTABLISHED BECAUSE WE DO WANT
TO HEAR FROM MR RISKING TODAY
AND THAT WE APOLOGIZE TO RISK
AND WE JUST GOT TO GET CHECK ON
A BETTER CONNECTION. ALL RIGHT
DELAYS IN GENERAL WE'RE NOW
GOING TO GO TO ROOM TWENTY
FORTY FROM TWENTY FORTY THERE
ARE NO WITNESSES WHO ARE
PREPARED TO PRESENT. WE'RE NOW
GOING TO BE GOING TOWARD
TELECONFERENCE LINE WE'RE
LOOKING FOR FOLKS WHO ARE IN
SUPPORT OF SB TWO SEVEN FOUR IF
YOU WERE IN SUPPORT OF SB TWO
SEVEN FOUR. PLEASE DIAL.
844-291-6364 WITH THE CODE. SIX
FIVE FOUR TWO EIGHT NINE SEVEN
NOT A MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE
PLEASE QUEUE UP ALL OF THOSE
WHO ARE IN SUPPORT. OF SB TWO
SEVEN FOUR. YES IT. YOU WERE IN
SUPPORT OF THE S. B. SEVENTY
FOUR. PRESS ONE AND THEN. ZERO
ONE AND THEN ZERO FOUR POINT. I
WAS LOOKING MATTER MODERATOR.
YEP THERE'S TWO IN Q. WE JUST
HAVE TO GET THEIR LINE NUMBER.
THANK YOU MA'AM. THE MODERATOR
WE NEED PULLING UP THOSE TWO
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE SUPPORTED
TWO SEVEN FOUR THEY WERE GONNA
GO BACK TO MISTER RISKING. OUT
WITH A BETTER CONNECTION. AND
MISTER CHAIR I HEAR AN ECHO ON
MONEY. AS WELL. HELLO HELLO
HELLO MADAM MODERATOR GIVE US A
MOMENT LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
COMMITTEE AT WORK IN A POSITIVE
MOMENTARILY. WE'RE GOING TO
TAKE A TWO MINUTE RECESS THE
TWO MINUTE RECESS TO BE A CHECK
THE LINES. PLEASE COME BACK
WILL BE BACK IN TWO MINUTES
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE OUT
WHAT WE'RE GOING TO DO IS WE'RE
GONNA START WHERE WE LEFT OFF.
WE WERE JUST ABOUT TO KICK OFF.
OUR PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT
OF SB TWO SEVENTY FOUR SO WE'RE
GONNA TAKE THOSE WITNESSES WHO
WERE IN SUPPORT OF TWO SEVENTY
FOUR. THEN WE'RE GOING TO GO
BACK TO MISTER RISKIN WHO IS
WITH THE LOS ANGELES SUNSHINE
COALITION HE'S GONNA BE OUR
LEAD WITNESS. DENVER GOING TO
SEE IF THERE ARE ANY LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESSES TO TWO
SEVENTY FOUR MEN WERE GOING TO
OPEN IT UP TO ANY OTHER
INDIVIDUALS WHO MAY BE IN
OPPOSITION AS WELL. SEMANA
MODERATOR LET'S START THIS OVER
AGAIN IF YOU CAN PLEASE QUEUE
UP ANY INDIVIDUAL IN SUPPORT OF
SB TWO SEVENTY FOUR AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. WE'LL GO TO OUR
FIRST LINE OF LINE FORTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS PAMELA
MILLER AND I AM REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
LOCAL AGENT THE CURRENT PATIENT
CONDITIONS ARE CALLACHAN AND
WE'RE PROUD TO THE COURT SB TWO
SEVENTY FOUR THANK YOU THANK
YOU SO MUCH MISS MILLER GOOD TO
HEAR VOICE WE APPRECIATE YOU
CALLING IN LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE MADAM MODERATOR.
THANK YOU AND THAT'LL COME FROM
LINE FORTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO CHAIR AND MEMBERS
BENEFIT CHAVEZ WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU MS CHAVEZ SAID I NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU AND AS
A REMINDER IT IS ONE AND THEN
ZERO IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF
S. B. TWO SEVEN FOUR. MISTER
CHAIR WE HAVE NO FURTHER
SUPPORTING QUEUE AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU MADAM MODERATOR
LADIES AND GENTLEMAN WE'RE NOW
GOING TO GO TO ADRIN RISKING HE
IS WITH THE LOS ANGELES
SUNSHINE COALITION HE'S OUR
LEAD SUPPORT. FOR TAKING THEM
OUT A BIT AT ORDER JUST TO ADD
THAT FUNKY ACT CONNECTION JUST
A BIT AGO WE'RE GRATEFUL THAT
MR RISKINESS HUNG WITH THIS.
SERVICE CAN THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR PATIENCE THE FLOOR IS
YOURS SIR YOU ARE THREE MINUTES
AND I'LL GIVE YOU A THIRTY
SECOND PROMPT IN SUPPORT OF SB
TWO SEVENTY FOUR. THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME TODAY-
I JUST LIKE TO TALK A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT SB TWO SEVENTY FOUR
AND ARMS- THE MAIN ISSUE IS
THAT RIGHT NOW THE BROWN ACT
REQUIRES LOCAL LEGISLATIVE
BODY. TO PROVIDE MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WITH. RESERVE MEETING
AGENDA BY MAIL IF THEY REQUEST
THAT. BUT DOT THESE DAYS LIKE
EVERYBODY IN ALL OF AGENCIES DO
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC. ABOUT
THE USE OF AN NOT REQUIRED BY
LAW AND MODERATELY THE- SB.
FOUR OLYMPIC. I SEVENTY FOUR
WITH A MEMBER BROWN. TO OUR TO
MAKE EMAIL NOTIFICATION MEMBERS
I REQUEST. OR NO THEY DON'T SEE
THAT INTRACTABLE. ON DOING IT.
ON A NUMBER. WE MONITOR
HUNDREDS OF LOCAL HAVE YOU.
BODY AND IN. ARM YOU EITHER A
EIGHT YOU KNOW DEL. THE COUNTY
ITSELF. HER SCHOOL TRIED POWER
THIRTY AND SO ON- BOTH THEY DO
SEND US AGENDA BY BY EMAIL BUT
WONDER WHY. ARMENIANS ARE
BENDING THE BY. MAIL AND. WHAT
WHAT OTHER I GET A LOT THE CAR
MOVE IT MONITORING IT BACK-
THESE ONES THAT SOUNDED EMAIL
TO ANOTHER THE BOARD. MONDAY
EVEN IF THE MALES SEVENTY TWO
HOURS IN ADVANCE- WHICH CREATES
MORE DIFFICULTIES TOP PEOPLE
WHO WHO WORK DURING THE DAY OR
WHO IN SCHOOL- OFTEN- THEY
OFTEN HAVE. GO TO THE POST
OFFICE TO PROTECT ARE FOR THE-
AND AM .COM TIME DOT QUITE
DIFFERENT FOR WORKING PEOPLE
ARE WAS FOR STUDENT. I WE ARE.
HOW MUCH MEMBERS AMERICA TO
MAKE PUBLIC RECORDS ARE TO. ARE
MONITORED MEETINGS TO ATTEND
MEETING AND IT'S VERY HARD THEM
TO RE. POSTAL MAIL- MANY OF
THEM HAVE SMART BUT OUR ABLE TO
O. YOU NOW ARE. YOU. SB TWO
FOUR WITHIN. LASTLY. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU TO SUPPORT
OUR IT'S IMPORTANT DAHLE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH M. IS RISKING
THANKS AGAIN FOR HANGING WITH
US TODAY THAT'S AS ADRIAN
RISKING FROM LOS SUNSHINE
COALITION SPEAKING IN SUPPORT
OF S. B. TWO SEVENTY FOUR
FILETS IN GERMAN NOW GOING TO
GO TO WEEKS WITNESSES WHO ARE
IN OP FOR GOING TO FIRST START
WITH THE WHO ARE LEAD WITNESSES
WE HAVE NO LEAD WITNESSES ON
RECORD- AND ARE PREPARED FOR
THAT CHECK TO SEE IF WE HAVE
ANY AND LEAD WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. OF A THREE TO
SEVENTY FOUR. WE DO NOT HAVE
ANY LEAD WITNESSES NONE WERE
RECORDED PRIOR TO THE HEARING
WE'RE NOT GOING TO GO TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY TO SEE IF WE HAVE
ANYONE IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY WE
DO NOT HAVE ANYONE. IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY WE'RE NOT GOING TO
GO TO OUR TELECONFERENCE FINE
WE'RE GONNA ASK ALL INDIVIDUALS
PLEASE QUEUE UP NOW IN
OPPOSITION AB S. B. TWO SEVENTY
FOUR MATTER MODERATOR CAN YOU
PLEASE PUT THOSE. IN OPPOSITION.
TO TWO SEVENTY FOUR. IN THE
QUEUE NOW. THANK YOU IF YOU'RE
OPPOSITE. YOU MAY PRESS AND.
ZERO ONE AND THEN ZERO FOR ANY
OPPOSITION OF S. B. TWO SEVENTY
FOUR. MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE NOT
POSITIONING QUEUE AT THIS TIME.
NO OPPOSITION IN Q. THANK YOU
SO MUCH MATTER MODERATOR WE'RE
VERY GRATEFUL FOR THAT AND WORK
AND NOW BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE FOR ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS WILL ALSO WELCOME A
MOTIONS QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR
OF MOTION ON SB. TWO SEVENTY
FOUR. SENATE LEADERS ARE
EMOTION- IN SUPPORT OF HIS
THIRTY FOURTH THANK YOU SO MUCH
SOONER WIENER A MOVES THE BILL
SB TWO SEVENTY FOUR TO DO
PASSES AMENDED TO PER. CENTER I
CAST WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH TAKE DUE TO.
AND PER. THAT'S THE ROLL OUT
NOW. MOTIONS TO PASS IS A MAN
BUT FOR A MAN AND RE REFER THE
CAN ON A PER. SENATOR MCGUIRE
HI WIRE ON IT SO NEAL. NIELSEN
HI SENATOR ALSO. SENATOR HEARD.
SENATOR WIENER. WIENER HI THREE
DOES BREEZE THREE IS WHAT WE'RE
GOING TO PUT ON CALLED ALLOW
VERIZON AND HEARD TO BE A AND
ON. THANK SO MUCH OF A THREAT
CAL. PHOTO LAYS THE GROUNDWORK
MOVE TO- I NUMBER ONE I NUMBER
SB TWO SIX EIGHT A THAT'S
SENATOR ARE TO SYNERGY LET IS
FROM TO. PURSUE MR ARCHULETA WE
WILL YOU TO COMMITTEE WANT TO
MAKE THAT YOU'RE GONNA TAKING
THE AMENDMENT MR ARE TO LET
OTHER IS YOUR- THANK YOU THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
MISTER MCCOY. COMMITTEE MEMBER
I'M HERE TO BRIDGE SENATE BILL
TWO SIX EIGHT THE LOWER LOS
ANGELES AND LOWER SIANG. THE
AUTHORIZATION WILL BE IN
ACCORDANCE WITH LOCAL AGENCY
FORMATION COMMISSION LAW AND
RECREATION AND PARK DISTRICT
LAW UNTIL JANUARY ONE TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR. SENATE BILL TWO
SIXTY EIGHT. ALSO MAKE CHANGES
IN EXISTING LAW TO AUTHORIZE
THE CITY COUNCILS OF THE CITIES
OF COMMERCE DOWNEY MONTEBELLO
AND PICO RIVERA TO EACH APPOINT
ONE MEMBER TO SERVE ON THE
INITIAL BOARD OF DIRECTORS OF
THE LOWER LOS ANGELES PARK
DISTRICT RATHER DANTE JOINTLY
APPOINT ONE MEMBER TO SERVE. A
TWO YEAR TERM. FURTHERMORE THE
BILL WILL AUTHORIZE THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS TO APPOINT THREE
MEMBERS RATHER THAN TO MEMBERS.
TO SERVE ON THE INITIAL BOARD
OF DIRECTORS OF THE LOWER LOS
ANGELES PARK DISTRICT. THE
LOWER SAYING GIVE A RIVER FLOWS
FORTY THREE MILES THROUGH BOTH
LOS ANGELES AND ORANGE COUNTY'S.
INCLUDING MANY CITIES
CATEGORIZED AS DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES. RESIDENTS OF THESE
COMMUNITIES ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED BY
POOR AIR QUALITY IN A LACK OF
ACCESS TO RECREATIONAL OUTDOOR
PARK SPACE. IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN
SENATE BILL SIX NINETY THREE
AUTHORIZED THE ESTABLISHMENT OF
THE LOWER SAYING GIVE A RIVER
RECREATION AND PARK DISTRICT
UNDER LOCAL AGENCY FORMATION
COMMISSION LAW AND THE
RECREATION AND PARKS DISTRICT
LAW HOWEVER SENATE BILL SIX
NINETY THREE SUNSET. ON JANUARY
ONE TWENTY TWENTY. WITH THE
SUNSET OF SENATE BILL SIX
NINETY THREE THIS AREA IS LEFT
WITHOUT THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ESTABLISH THE LOWER SINGAPORE
RIVER RECREATION PARK DISTRICT
AND ADDRESS THE REGION SPECIFIC
CONCERNS. THIS BILL SENATE BILL
TWO SIXTY EIGHT WILL RE
AUTHORIZED THE ESTABLISHMENT OF
THE LOWER SAYING GIVE A RIVER
RECREATION AND PARK DISTRICT
AND WILL ALSO MAKE CHANGES TO
THE BOARD OF DIRECTORS OF THE
LOWER LOS ANGELES PART DISTRICT
WHICH WILL INCREASE THE
REPRESENTATION FROM CITIES
WITHIN THE PARK DISTRICT.
TOGETHER THESE CHANGES
ESTABLISH THE LOWER LAWCENTER
STAND LOWER STANDARD RIVER PARK
DISTRICTS. THESE BODIES WILL
REPRESENT CITIES AND
STAKEHOLDERS. AND THEY ARE ALSO
RESPONSIBLE FOR IDENTIFYING
FUNDING SOURCES TO PROMOTE OPEN
SPACES. SENATE BILL TWO SIXTY
EIGHT WILL ENSURE THE THAT
RESIDENTS IN THE AREA
SURROUNDING THE LOWER LOSS AND
JUST AND LOWER STANDARD RIVER
WILL ALSO HAVE ACCESS TO THE
BENEFITS OF RECREATIONAL AREAS
THAT MANY OTHER CALIFORNIA
CITIES ENJOY. AS YOU CAN SEE
THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT
DISTRICT BILL AND I'M HONORED
TO HAVE THE SUPPORT OF EVERY
ELECTED OFFICIAL THAT
REPRESENTS THIS REGION AND THIS
CALL OFFICERS ON THIS BILL. TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT TODAY I HAVE
FULLY SORROW FOR THE RIVERS AND
MOUNTAINS CONSERVANCY- THANK
YOU. AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR BIBLE. THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR PRESENTATION ON ITS
FEET TO SIXTY EIGHT BASIN
GENTLEMAN OF THE PUBLIC AND
COMMITTEE FOR NOW GOING TO GO
TO THOSE WHO ARE IN SUPPORT.
WE'RE GOING TO START WITH A
SILLY SORROW WITH THE RIVERS
AND MOUNTAINS CONSERVANCY.
SILLY YOU'LL HAVE THREE MINUTES
THREE MINUTES TO BE ABLE TO
PRESENT THE FLOOR IS YOURS LEAD
WITNESS ON SB TWO SIXTY EIGHT
YOUR DOWN COMMITTEE. THANK YOU
GOOD MORNING CARE MCGUIRE AND
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE- HELLO AGAIN MY NAME
IS. SARAH AND I AM REPRESENTING
THE AND GABRIEL. AND LOWER L.
A. RIVER IS MOUNTAINS
CONSERVANCY. I AM- INTO COURT
AT S. B. TWO SIX EIGHT ENSURE
THAT WE OPERATE CITY COUNCIL.
OF THE CITY SOME COMMERCE
DOWNEY MONTEBELLO IN PICO
RIVERA. TO EACH APPOINT ONE
MEMBER TO SERVE- ON THE LOWER
L. A. RIVER. RECREATION PARK
DISTRICT SO THAT THEY CAN
APPOINT AND- COUNT ON THE
NATIONAL BOARD OF DIRECTORS OF
THE DISTRICT RATHER THAN BEN
JOINTLY APPOINT ONE MEMBER TO
SERVE A TWO YEAR TERM.
ADDITIONALLY AND SUPPORT AT
BABYLISS THE LOWER THANK AB
OWNERS- RECREATION AND PARK
DISTRICT. AND THE LOWER THANK
GABRIEL RIVER AND FLOWS TO MANY
OF DISADVANTAGED AND SENATOR
OUR LET SHARED. WHERE MANY OF
THE RESIDENTS ARE JUST.
IMPACTED BY POOR OUT QUALITY
CAN JUST CHAMP. CORNERS AND
SUFFER FROM SEVERE LACK ACCESS
TO THAT GREAT OP. TO OUT STAGE
FOR THIS WITH YOUR IS GOING
WITH PROMOTED THAT. OF OPEN
SPACE AND PARK FOR THE DAY. OF
REST OF AND THE LOWERS AND
PROGRAM. AND IT'S GOING TO. A
UNIQUE ON. FOR ENSURING THAT WE.
IRAN COULD PROPERTIES. AND THE
ABILITY TO OPERATE AND MAINTAIN
PARK SO WE WILL BE ABLE TO.
REACH OUT TO LOCAL STATE AND%
FEDERAL GRANTS AND PUBLIC
PRIVATE PARTNERSHIPS AND OTHER
RESOURCES. THAT CAN BE EXPLORED
FOR ADDITIONAL FUNDS TO OPERATE
AND MAINTAIN PARK WHICH WE
CURRENTLY WOULDN'T HAVE THE
ACCESS TO DO OTHERWISE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
IPHONE AND IT'L THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH RESEARCH
WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION TODAY LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN COMMITTEE WE'RE NOT
GONNA BE GOING TO SEE IF WE
HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY LOOKING
FOR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. HEARING SEEN
NINE LAYS ENDEMIC COMMITTEE
WE'RE NOT GONNA BE GOING TOWARD
TELECONFERENCE LINE WE'RE GOING
TO ASK MADAME MODERATOR TO
PLEASE QUEUE UP. ALL
INDIVIDUALS IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
TWO SIX EIGHT BETTER MODERATOR.
THANK YOU AND IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. YOUR IN SUPPORT OF
SB TWO SIXTY EIGHT. AND WE WILL
GO TELL MY NUMBER UP THIRTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GIVE ME
FAN ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
DOWNEY IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU SO
MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK
YOU AS A REMINDER IT IS ONE AND
THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT OF S. B.
TWO SIXTY EIGHT. AND WE HAVE NO
MORE AND Q. MISTER. MODERATOR
THANK YOU SO MUCH LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN COMMITTEE WE'RE NOW
GOING TO LOOK TO THOSE WHO MAY
BE IN OPPOSITION OF SB TWO
SIXTY EIGHT THE COMMITTEE DOES
NOT HAVE A LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESS- ON RECORD HERE TODAY.
BUT WILL ADD OF COURTESY WE'RE
GOING TO CHECK TO SEE IF WE
HAVE A LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESS
TO S. B. TWO SIX EIGHT IN THE
QUEUE. THIRTY NINE LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN AND AGAIN I WANT TO
REMIND FOLKS WE DID NOT HAVE A
LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESS IN THE
QUEUE- WE- ARE NOT GOING TO GO
TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY TO SEE WE
HAVE ANYONE. WISHING TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION IT IS LONELY IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY THAT WE'RE
NOW GOING TO GO TO OUR
TELECONFERENCE ON. LAZY GERMAN
WE ARE GOING TO ASK THE
MODERATOR TO PLEASE QUEUE UP.
ANY INDIVIDUALS WHO WOULD LIKE
TO BE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
TWO SIXTY EIGHT TO PLEASE GIVE
THEM UP NOW MOM MADAM MODERATOR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR IF YOU'D
LIKE- TO QUEUE UP FOR
OPPOSITION- S. B. TWO SIXTY
EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. ONE ZERO FOR ANY
OPPOSITION. MISTER CHAIR IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU AT THE
TIME. YOUR POSITION AT WORK CAN
YOU PLEASE REPEAT THAT MATTER
MODERN NO OPPOSITION IS THAT
CORRECT. YES THAT IS CORRECT
THERE IS NOBODY IN Q. THANK YOU
SO MUCH READING MODERATOR WE DO
NOT HAVE ANYONE WANTING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB TWO
SIXTY EIGHT WE'RE GOING TO
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE.
FIVE TWO CENTER WIENER THE VICE
CHAIR QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR IS
THERE A MOTION TO APPROVE WE
HAVE A QUESTION BY CENTER
WIENER THE FLOORS OR SIR-
CENTER WINNERS GONNA MOVE THE
BILL THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER.
SENATOR ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS HEARING
SEEN ON US INTERESTS A LOT OF
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSER I
THANK YOU SHARE A TOUCH LIKE
EMPHASIZES AN IMPORTANT-
DISTRICT BILL WITH NO
OPPOSITION AND I URGE YOUR
BILL. UNPAYABLE THANK YOU SO
MUCH AS AN ARCH ALETTA WE ARE
GOING TO TURN IT OVER TO MR
GOOD NOW ALL TO BE ABLE TO GIVE
US THE APPROPRIATE MOTION AND
CALL THE ROLL MISTER NOW.
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
BUT FIRST AMENDED AND RE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR MCGUIRE
BY WIRE HI SENATOR NIELSEN HI
NIELSEN HI. SENATOR DORADO.
SENATOR HEARD. SENATOR WIENER
AYE WIENER HI THREE ZERO VOTED
THREE TO ZERO SAN R. TO LETTER
TO KEEP THE ROLE OPEN AND
ALACER DRAWS ON SENATOR
HERTZBERG TO BE ABLE TO ADD ON
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR WORK
SIR AND WE WALKED ME BACK TO
COMMITTEE HERE IN THE WEEKS TO
COME ARE YOU GOOD THANK YOU
COMMITTEE MEMBERS SHARE THANK
YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH LAYS IN
GERMAN COMMITTEE WERE NOW GOING
TO BE MOVING FORWARD TO WHAT I
ITEM NUMBER TWO ON OUR AGENDA.
ITEM NUMBER TWO IS SB THREE TWO
THREE CENTER COPYRIGHT WE HAVE
A SECOND COVER YOUR WILL ON
TOAY'S DOCKET THAT'S SB THREE
FORTY SEVEN THAT BILL IS A
CURRENTLY ON OUR CONSENT
AGENDA- MADAM CENTER WE WELCOME
YOU TO COMMITTEE THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR WORK THAT THE
FLOOR IS YOURS ON SB THREE TWO
THREE THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I AM PLEASED
TO PRESENT SENATE BILL THREE
TWO THREE WHICH WOULD CREATE
EIGHT ONE HUNDRED AND TWENTY
DAYS STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS.
FOR CLAIMS AGAINST WATER AND
SEWER AGENCY RATE ADJUSTMENTS
WATER AND SEWER UTILITY BUDGETS
ARE FUNDED BY REVENUE COLLECTED
THROUGH SERVICE RATES THESE
RATES PROVIDE THE FUNDING
NECESSARY TO SUPPLY SAFE
DRINKING WATER UPGRADE AND
IMPROVE AGING INFRASTRUCTURE
AND OPERATE EFFICIENTLY AND
EFFECTIVELY EXISTING LAW ALLOWS
LAWSUITS THAT SEEK REFUNDS OR
SEEKS TO INVALIDATE EXISTING
RATE STRUCTURES YEARS AFTER
RATES HAVE BEEN ADOPTED AND
COLLECTED AND QUITE QUITE
FRANKLY DELAYED LAWSUITS CAN
THREATEN AND AGENCIES ABILITY
TO REPAY DEBT GUARANTEED BY
REVENUE FROM RATES. IT CAN ALSO
DERAIL ON GROWING ONGOING
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS AND
GENERALLY UNDERMINE AND
ABILITIES AND AGENCIES ABILITY
TO MAINTAIN STABLE BUDGETS
NECESSARY TO OPERATE
EFFECTIVELY THERE'S BEEN AN
INCREASE IN THE NUMBER OF LEGAL
CHALLENGES FILED AGAINST WATER
AND SEWER RATE AGENCY RATE
STRUCTURES AND FOR SOME OF THE
AGENCY SUED THE CHALLENGE.
RATES WERE ADOPTED FIVE YEARS
PRIOR TO THE LOS. AND NOW WITH
THE ADDITION STRAIN THE
GOVERNOR A-ORDER PROHIBITING
WATER SHUT OFFS REGARDLESS OF A
CUSTOMER'S ABILITY TO PAY WATER
AND SEWER AGENCIES ARE UNDER
CONSTANT FINANCIAL STRAIN AND
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS
ARE AT RISK. SB THREE TWENTY
THREE ADDS CONSISTENCY TO
EXISTING LAW BY AUTHORIZING A
LOCAL AGENCY OR INTERESTED
PERSON TO BRING A VALIDATION
ACTION IN SUPERIOR COURT TO
DETERMINE THE VALIDITY OF A FEE
OR CHARGE FOR WATER AND SEWER
SERVICE. IF A VALIDATION ACTION
IS NOT BROUGHT WITHIN A HUNDRED
AND TWENTY DAYS PARTIES WOULD
BE BARRED FROM CHALLENGING THE
VALIDITY OF THE FEE. FOR THE
CHARGE. THIS BILL IS CONSISTENT
WITH EXISTING PRECEDENT.
MODELED AFTER THE ONE HUNDRED
AND TWENTY DAYS STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS ENACTED IN TWO
THOUSAND FOR MUNICIPAL ELECTRIC
RATE FOR CHARGES BY ALLOWING
CUSTOMERS TO BRING CHALLENGES
WITHIN A REASONABLE BUT LIMITED
PERIOD OF TIME. THIS PROPOSAL
WOULD BALANCE THE INTERESTS OF
THE REPAIRS WITH THOSE OF
PUBLIC WATER AND SEWER AGENCIES
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS TO TEST
TRANSPORT WE ARE PAUL COOK THE
GENERAL MANNER MANAGER AT THE
IRVINE RANCH WATER DISTRICT.
AND CHRIS ANDERSON WITH AQUA.
THE THANKS FOR ALL YOUR WORK ON
THIS ONE I KNOW THIS IS BEING
YOUR THREATEN NEED ON A LOT OF
ISSUES AND SO VERY GRATEFUL FOR
ALL OF YOUR EFFORTS LAYS ENGINE
OF THE COMMITTEE WERE NOT GOING
TO GO TO OUR LEAD SUPPORT
WITNESSES. WE'RE GOING TO ASK
EACH OF OUR LEAD SUPPORT
WITNESSES TO PLEASE KEEP YOUR
COMMENTS TO THREE MINUTES.
THREE MINUTES EACH WILL GIVE
YOU A THIRTY SECOND CROP. ARE
NOW GOING TO TURN THE FLOOR
OVER TO PAUL COOK MISTER COOK
ONE THREE MINUTES HE'S THE
GENERAL MANAGER OF THE IRVINE
RANCH WATER DISTRICT. MISTER
COOK CURING COMMITTEE THE FLOOR
IS YOURS. THERMADOR MEMBERS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO DISCUSS S. B.
THREE TWO THREE WITH YOU TODAY.
I'M PAUL COOK GENERAL MANAGER
FOR THE IRVINE RANCH WATER
DISTRICT. A PUBLIC RETAIL WATER
AND SEWER AGENCIES SERVING
CENTRAL ORANGE COUNTY. TO
SYSTEM YOUR CONSIDERATION FOR
SB THREE TWO THREE OF LIKE TO
DESCRIBE THE VERY PUBLIC AND
TRANSPARENT PROCESS. OF
RESETTING THAT WE USE AT OUR W.
D. PROP TO RETURN REQUIREMENTS
OUTLINED IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS ARE EXPENSIVE BUT THEY
ARE ONLY PART OF OUR- PUBLIC
PROCESS. LIKE ALL WATER AND
WASTE WATER AGENCIES HIGHER W.
D. BEGINS ITS RATE SETTING
PROCESS WITH THE COST OF
SERVICE STUDY. THE DETAILED
STUDY EXPLAINS A METHODOLOGY
FOR HOW RATES ARE SET. AND HOW
COSTS ARE ALLOCATED. AMONG OUR
CUSTOMERS. BECAUSE OF PROP TWO
EIGHTEEN STRICT COST OF SERVICE
PRINCIPLES RATE SETTING IS TIED
DIRECTLY TO AN AGENCY BUDGET.
AND THAT IS WHERE WE PROVIDE
THE BASIS FOR THE PROPOSED
RATES. HIGHER TO BE EXPLAINS.
RIGHT POLICY DECISIONS EXPENSES
PROPOSED RATES IN IMPACTS. AT
MULTIPLE PUBLIC MEETINGS AT
SETTING PROCESS. PRIOR TO BEING
CONSIDERED FOR ADOPTION BY OUR
BOARD. WE ALSO MAILED EACH
PROPERTY OWNER AND CUSTOMER A
PROP TO EIGHTEEN NOTICE. AT
LEAST FORTY FIVE DAYS PRIOR TO
HOLD PUBLIC HEARING ON THE
PROPOSED RATES THIS WRITTEN
NOTICE. PROVIDED DETAILS ON THE
PROPOSED RATES. ALONG WITH THE
REASONS FOR ADJUSTING RATES.
THE NOTICE ALSO INCLUDES
INFORMATION ON HOW RATE PAPER
CAN COMMENT. OR PROTEST THE
RATE. I WE- RE TO PHOTO LETTER
COMMENT RECEIVE. ONLY AFTER THE
VERY PUBLIC EXTENT PROCESS
OPERATES AND CONSIDERED FOR
ADOPTION BAR ABOARD. BECAUSE OF
THIS VERY TRANSPARENT PROCESS
WE BELIEVE THAT A HUNDRED
TWENTY DAYS JACK TWO
LIMITATIONS TO NEARLY ONE THIRD
OF A YEAR. STOREKEEPER PRETTY
BALANCED BETWEEN REQUIRING
PROMPT RATE CHALLENGES.
ALLOWING SUFFICIENT TIME FOR
REPAIR TO CHALLENGE RATES. I
WAS ELECTED THANK SENATOR
CAFIERO FOR AUTHORIZING OF
SPEECH ARE OFFERING RIGHT
RATHER. SB THREE TWO THREE I
RSPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT YOU
SUPPORT THIS BILL TODAY I'M
GLAD TO ANSWERING QUESTIONS
THANK YOU. IN DECEMBER TWO WE-
TESTIMONY WE'RE NOW GOING TO
MOVE TO CHRIS ANDERSON SHE'S
WITH AQUA WE WELCOME YOU MISS
SANDERSON WITH SANDERSON YOU'RE
GOING TO HAVE. THREE MINUTES TO
BE ABLE TO PROVIDE YOUR
TESTIMONY WILL GIVE YOU A
THIRTY SECOND PROP THE FLOOR IS
YOURS AND WELCOME THE COMMITTEE.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS CHRIS ANDERSON ON
BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES WE
ARE THE PROUD SPONSOR OF CPAC
SPEECH THREE TWO THREE. I JUST
WANT TO START BY- THANKING THE
SENATOR PROP DURING THIS BILL.
WHEN I THINK THE COMMITTEE FOR
THE TIME AND ATTENTION TO THOSE
ALSO PROVIDED THE BILL SH.
THREE TWO THREE IS NOT A NEW OR
REVOLUTIONARY IDEA THIS BILL
LINES WITH LONGSTANDING
PRESIDENT IN THE- INBOX HUNDRED
TWENTY DAY STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS. UNDER MENTIONED IS
ALREADY PROVIDED FOR MUNICIPAL
ELECTRIC RATES CONNECTION FEES
CAPACITY CHARGES ASSESSED BY
WATER AND SEWER AGENCIES. AND
OTHER TYPES OF FEES AND
CHARGES. THE LEGISLATURE
CREATED THE STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS BECAUSE IT
RECOGNIZED THE NEED TO MINIMIZE
FISCAL UNCERTAINTY FOR PUBLIC
AGENCIES THAT PROVIDE ESSENTIAL
GOVERNMENT SERVICES. SB THREE
TWO THREE SIX TO PROVIDE
SIMILAR PROTECTIONS. FOR WATER
AND SEWER SERVICE RATES. PUBLIC
WATER AND A ARE LARGELY FUNDED
BY RATHER MEANING LEGAL CHAO TO
RAGE FROM. CAN HAVE A- THE
STATE BY THE FACT. FOR PUBLIC
AGING. AS A COMMITTEE ANNOUNCES
POINT PROP TO EIGHTEEN HAS BEEN
FERTILE GROUND FOR LITIGATION
THE RECENT CLASS ACTION LAWSUIT
AGAINST EIGHTY ONE WATER
SUPPLIERS. IS THE LATEST
EXAMPLE OF HOW THE BOUNDS OF
CROPS TO EIGHTEEN ARE BEING
TESTED. THESE LAWSUITS ALSO CUT
AGAINST WATER PORTABILITY AS
CUSTOMERS THAT WILL CALL ME
BEAR THE COST OF LITIGATION SH
I WANT TO BRIEFLY ADDRESS
ISSUES PREVIOUSLY RAISED TO
THIS COMMITTEE ABOUT HOW THIS
BILL WOULD IMPACT YOUR
CUSTOMERS ABILITY TO CHALLENGE
AN AGE. RANGE FACTOR PROP TO
EIGHTEEN AS YOU JUST HEARD
REQUIRES PUBLIC WATER AND SEWER
AGENCIES TO PROVIDE ROBUST
PUBLIC AND- INVOLVEMENT. PRIOR
TO ADOPTING RATES THIS INCLUDES
MAILING NOTICES TO ALL AFFECTED
PARCELS PUBLIC HEARINGS
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THE PUBLIC TO
PROTEST THE RATE CHANGE AND
MORE. HE NEEDS TO TRAIN MANDATE
DO NOT APPLY TO THE FEES AND
CHARGES THAT ALREADY RECEIVE
THE PROTECTIONOF A. HUNDRED
TWENTY DATES THAT SHOULD
LIMITATION. WE NEED A ROBUST
TRANSPARENCY REQUIRED AND THE
FACT THAT CUSTOMERS WOULD STILL
HAVE. THE CHALLENGE THE RATE
AFTER THEY GO INTO A- SB THREE
TWO THREE WITH STILL GET
CUSTOMERS AMPLE TIME AND
OPPORTUNITY TO INCLUDE THEIR
VOICE IN THE RATE SETTING
PROCESS. L. STRIKES A BALANCE
BETWEEN PROTECTING THE RIGHT TO
RATE PAYERS. ALIGN PUBLIC WATER
AND SEWER AGENCIES TO AVOID
UNNECESSARY FINANCIAL
UNCERTAINTY THIRTY SECOND
REASON YOUR PASTOR I VOTE AND
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. CHRIS THANK YOU SO
MUCH WE REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
TESTIMONY HERE TODAY THANKS FOR
HANGING WITH US THAT'S CHRIS
ANDERSON FROM AQUA. ARE SECOND
IN FINALLY WITNESS LAYS IN
GERMAN WE'RE NOW GOING TO BE
GOING TO ALTERNATIVE WAYS THAT
THE PUBLIC CAN PARTICIPATE WERE
FIRST GOING TO GO TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY TO SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE. IN SUPPORT OF SB TWO
THREE THREE EXCUSE ME SB THREE
TWO THREE. NOW AND THERE'S NO
LOVE- IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
WE'RE NOT GOING TO GO TO OUR
TELECONFERENCE LINE WE'RE GOING
TO ASK THE MODERATOR TO PLEASE
OPEN UP OUR TELECONFERENCE LINE
TO ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT. OF SB.
TWO THREE TWO THREE BETTER
MODERATOR. THANK YOU IF YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE TWO
THREE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO NOW. WE WILL GO TO
OUR FIRST LINE OF FIFTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE FIFTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YOUR
TURN MEMBERS WILL BE A POLICE
ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF SANTA
MONICA AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH RESOLUTION
ALWAYS COULD HEAR VOICES GO TO
OUR NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK
YOU THAT OF THE LINE OF FIFTY
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR ROSS BUCKLEY
ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
SACRAMENTO IN SUPPORT OF SB
THREE TWO THREE THANK YOU
MISTER BUCKLEY. NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU ARE COME FROM
LINE OF FIFTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS STORE NELSON ON BEHALF
OF THE AMERICAN WATER WORKS
ASSOCIATION MONTEREY PENINSULA
WATER MANAGEMENT DISTRICT
MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT OF
ORANGE COUNTY. SPEECH SANITARY
DISTRICT IN THE TERBUKA CANYON
WATER DISTRICT ON SUPPORT NEED
ORGANIZATIONS ARE IN ADDITION
TO THE ORGANIZATIONS ALREADY%
LISTED ON THE AWKWARD COALITION
MOTOR IN STOCK ANALYSIS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY THAT'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU BETTER
COME FROM LINE OF SIXTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER
MEMBERS DEALERS ON BEHALF OF
THE MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT OF
ORANGE COUNTY IN SUPPORT. WE
APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY LET'S
GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER. THANK
YOU LETTER FROM THE LIGHT OF
THIRTY TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THEY'RE GONNA WOOD COUNTY
SHERIFF'S ON BEHALF OF THE
STORAGE COUNTY WATER DISTRICT
AND YORBA LINDA WATER DISTRICT
AND THE SUPPORT IF AMENDED
POSITION SHOULD BE ABOUT MAKES.
SENSE OF THE OFFICE OFFICE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH
YOUR COMMENTS BRIGITTE IN NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU AND
JUST A REMINDER TO IS ONE AND
THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT OF SB
THREE TO THREE. AND WE WILL GO
TO LINE OF FIFTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CARE OFF ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF SANTA
ROSA IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH DISTRUST
PRESHEAF COLONY NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU THAT'LL COME
FROM LINE FIFTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING MISTER
TURNER STEPHANIE MORE WHILE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF MUTUAL WATER
COMPANY WE ALL PUBLIC SUPPORT
AT THE MINUTE POSITION ON THE
BILL BUT WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THE
OPERA THAT MEASURE THANK YOU
THANK YOU STEPHANIE APPRECIATE
YOU CALLING IN THAT'S GO TO OUR
NEXT CALLER. THANK YOU KNOW
COME FROM NINE FIFTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. DANIEL BLACK THAT
HEIGHTEN THE CALIFORNIA
MUNICIPAL UTILITIES ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT. HERE FOR ME
DANIELLE LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
WE HAVE NO FURTHER SUPPORTING
QUEUE THANK YOU SO MUCH READING
MODERATOR LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
WE ARE NOW GOING TO BE GOING TO
THOSE WHO. MAY BE OPPOSE OR WHO
HAVE CONCERNS THAT WE ARE GOING
TO BE LOOKING FIRST YEAR IN
ROOM FORTY TWO OF THREE. WE
HAVE AN INDIVIDUAL IN THAT ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE THAT
STUDENTS ARE WE ON THE
REPRESENTING SOME WATER
DISTRICTS MR OF YANNI I KNOW
THAT YOU HAVE SOME CONCERNS ON
THE BILL WE'RE GONNA TURN IN
THE FOR OVER. THREE MINUTES TO
MISERABLY ON A DIVORCE OR SIR.
WELL FIRST OF ALL I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL FROM SENATE
CLEAR WATER AGENCIES BUT WE
ALSO RISE IN SUPPORT IF AMENDED
OKAY A GROUP OF. FOLKS THAT WAS
MENTIONED EARLIER TODAY- MY
CLIENTS SPECIFICALLY TO YOU D.
AND MESA WATER DISTRICT OF THE
SUPPORT THE MEASURE AND TO
BELIEVE IN THE PROTECTIONS ARE
PROVIDED. IN THE FINANCIAL
CERTAINTY THAT'S GIVEN TO THE
ENTERING THE VALIDATION ACT BUT
THEY DO NOT SUPPORT WITH THE
AMENDMENTS THAT REQUIRE THE
ALREADY LEGALLY REQUIRED
MAILING THAT WAS MENTIONED BY
THE SUPPORT OTHER SUPPORT
WITNESSES. UNDER TO EIGHTEEN
THAT INCLUDED NOTICE IN A
STATEMENT TO THE RATEPAYERS THE
RIGHT TO CHALLENGE THAT THAT
WILL EXPIRE WITHIN A HUNDRED
TWENTY DAYS TO SIMPLE
TRANSPARENCY AMENDMENT THAT
SAYS. HEY IF YOU CAN GET A
NOTICE WITHIN A HUNDRED TWENTY
DAYS JUST LET HIM KNOW THAT
THAT'S THE CHALLENGE SO WE
SUPPORT THE BILL WE JUST WOULD
LIKE TO HAVE AMENDED WITH A
LITTLE MORE TRANSPARENCY THANK
YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING
WITH HIS ROUTE RUNNING PRECIADO
THAT. ADAM COURTESY WE NOW
WOULD LIKE TO BE A TO SEE IF
THERE IS ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO
WOULD LIKE TO BE TO SPEAK AS A
LEAD OPPOSITION TO SB THREE TWO
THREE THE COMMITTEE DOES NOT
HAVE ANY LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESSES ON RECORD IT'S- LEAD
OPPOSITION. WITNESS. TO SB
THREE TWO THREE. YES MORNING
THIS IS A- K. I'M THE ONLY
OPTIONS- WITH TO THREE TWO
THREE. BUT PLEASE PROCEED THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU MY NAME
IS BRIAN CAPITEC THE MORNING BY
CHEERING MEMBERS I'M A FORMER
MEMBER OF FORMER PRESIDENT OF
THE CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF
CALIFORNIA AND- CURRENTLY-
APPROACHED ME TO YEARS AGO I
WAS APPOINTED TO TAKE OVER AS
LEAD COUNSEL. FOR ALL I A
LAWSUIT INVOLVING THE LOS
ANGELES DEPARTMENT OF WATER AND
POWER AND- CERTAIN OVER CHARGES
WERE MADE TO MEMBERS OF THE
REPAIRS IN THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES PERHAPS- MEMBERS ARE
AWARE OF THAT CASE BECAUSE OF
THE ALLEGED CONSPIRACY BETWEEN
VARIOUS LAWYERS IN THE CITY. OR
INVOLVING THE RATE THEIR
VICTIMS- THE FBI AND U. S.
ATTORNEY INVESTIGATING AS WELL
AS OTHERS ARE INVESTIGATIONS ON
GOING TO COULD HIGHLIGHT OF HOW
GREAT PLAYERS TO BE TAKEN
ADVANTAGE OF BY A POWERFUL
SOMEBODY- I WANT TO FIRST POINT
OUT THAT A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
DAYS IS ON ITS FACE
INSUFFICIENT. TO CHALLENGE
RATES- IN THIS CONTEXT VERTICAL
IN THIS CONTEXT AND KEEP IN
MIND THAT A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
DAYS ALTHOUGH ONE PERSON IN IN
SUPPORT MENTION ABOUT A QUARTER
OF THE YEAR THE REALITY IS THAT
WHILE THERE'S A QUARTER OF THE
YEAR IT'S ALSO LESSEN THE TIME
BETWEEN THANKSGIVING AND TODAY.
IT'S A RELATIVELY SHORT AMOUNT
OF TIME. FOR PEOPLE TO BE ABLE
TO EXERCISE. THERE ARE CONSTANT.
RIGHTS TO. REDRESS IN THE COURT.
WE SEEN IT. IN WATER FEES OVER.
THE LAST YEAR FROM. THAT'S
REPAIRS WILL PAY THOSE. THERE'S
ABOUT ON THE WALK. FILED RATE.
ONE THE WAY. IN SABAH AS A
MATTER OF LAW. THAT AWAIT CAN
SUE BOULDER THE CHANNEL FOR A
SO. ONCE THE WINDOWS. WHATEVER
THAT. LIMITATION IN. APARTMENT
TIE FOR RAY TO CHANGE. IS
FOREVER CLOSE- THERE IS A NEED.
FOR WATCH DOGS TWO. CITIES
ABOUT AND PRIVATE WATER
AGENCIES. FROM MAKING RATES A
PROFIT CENTER. AND PARTICULARLY
CITIES MUNICIPALITIES SHOULD
HAVE BEEN TRANSFORMS. THE
GENERAL FUND. IN TWENTY DAYS IN
THIS TO PROVIDE THE SCHOOLS TO.
WHY CAN WE LOOK AT IT ALONG
PERIOD OF THIS THE SAME TO
CHEAT THIS GOAL KEEPING MY THAT
MOST ACTUALLY- CAL. ARE TO THE
TO YEAR. AND MOST AT HAVING
BEEN TOUCHED FOR THE TWENTY
YEARS ONE TIME WE THOUGHT THE
PATIENTS ARE A MAJOR ROLE THERE.
TO WE WILL TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE AUTHOR THE PAPA OF A
LONGER PERIOD OF TIME THAT CALL.
THE SAME. WE UNDERSTAND ACCEPT
THE FACT THAT AN OPEN ENDED
SECTION LOCATIONS IS NOT GONNA
WORK BUT A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
DAYS IS SIMPLY TOO SHORT IT
DEPRIVES PEOPLE OF THEIR
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS GIVE
PEOPLE PLEASE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
SEE GREEN DRESS WITH A
REASONABLE PERIOD OF TIME THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
CAPITEC WE APPRECIATE THAT
SORRY ABOUT THAT- CONFUSION
WE'RE GRATEFUL THAT YOU WERE.
AND THAT WILL NEED TO BE ABLE.
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU SO MUCH SIR. ALL RIGHT I
PLEDGE. THAT LAYS GERMAN AT DO
NOT HAVE ELSE RISK AS-
OPPOSITION AS FAR AS A LEAD
WITNESS BUT WE WANT TO CHECK
JUST IN CASE IF HOWARD JARVIS-
IS ON THE LINE. OKAY DO NOT
BELIEVE THAT THEY ARE BUT WE
WANT TO DO A DOUBLE CHECK SO
LAYS IN GERMAN WE'RE NOT GOING
TO BE GOING TO TWO DIFFERENT
WAYS TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
OPPOSITION COMING. FIRST IS
GOING TO BE IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY BUT SEE IF WE HAVE ANYONE
IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY FUNDING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION WE DO NOT
HAVE ANYONE IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. LAYS INJURED ON THE
COMMITTEE AND TO THOSE WHO ARE
LISTENING AND IN THE PUBLIC
WE'RE GOING TO BE GOING TOWARD
TELECONFERENCE LINE IF YOU'D
LIKE TO PARTICIPATE IN TODAY'S
PROCEEDINGS PLEASE DIAL EIGHT
FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE SIX
THREE SIX FOUR THE CODE IS. SIX
FIVE FOUR TWO EIGHT NINE SEVEN
WE'RE NOW GOING TO SEE IF THERE
IS ANYONE ON THE LINE WANTING
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO SB
THREE TWO THREE MADAME
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE QUEUE
UP THOSE WHO ARE IN OPPOSITION
AT THREE TWO THREE. NOW THANK
YOU FOR IN OPPOSITION OF S. B.
THREE TWO THREE MY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. AND WE WILL GO
TO OUR FIRST FINAL FORTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
CHAIRED MEMBERS BENEFIT CHAVEZ
WHAT THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF REALTORS OTHER THEORIES
BOARDED STILL CONSIDERING A
POSITION ON THE BILL AND WE ARE
NOT FORMALLY OPPOSE. WE HAVE
REACHED OUT TO THE AUTHOR
THOUGHTLESSNESS FONT THERE- AND
HAPPEN CONCERNS ON THE BILL WE
LOOK FORWARD TO FURTHER
DISCUSSION THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMONSENSE
GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU NAZARIAN MINDER WE'RE
ON OPPOSITION OF S. B. THREE
TWO THREE MY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE NO
FURTHER UP ON. WE HAVE NO
FURTHER OPPOSITION IN Q. THANK
YOU SO MUCH MATTER MODERATOR TO
MIND YOU KNOW ONE LAST CALL
FINAL CALL FOR OPPOSITION THREE
TWO THREE PLEASE. SURE FOR
OPPOSITION OF SB THREE TWO
THREE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. NO OPPOSITION IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME THANK YOU SO
MUCH A MATTER MODERATOR NOT
GONNA BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE TO SEE IF THERE'S ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS- ON SB THREE
TWO THREE IN OF COURSE. GOOD WE
HAVE A MOTION A MOTION ON THE
FLOOR BOB FROM SENATOR WIENER.
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS ON THIS P. THREE TWO
THREE. ALL RIGHT. THAT WE'RE
GONNA TURN IT BACK OVER TO
CENTER CABALLERO FOR CLOSING TO
ADDRESSING THE ISSUES OF ANY
WITNESSES THAT MAY SPOKEN
CENTER COVER YOUR FOR YOUR
CLOSING AND REBUTTAL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND MISTER CHAIR FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO AT PRESENT
TO SPELL AND ALSO. I THINK YOU
TO EVERYBODY WHO WHO MADE
COMMENTS- WE'RE MORE THAN
WILLING TO WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION WE'VE HAD SOME-
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING AND
WE'RE LOOKING AT THAT VERY
CAREFULLY BUT- IF I COULD- I
BELIEVE. THAT IT WAS STATED
THAT- THE BILL WOULD AFFECT THE
ABILITY TO- TO FILE A LAWSUIT
IN REGARDS TO OVER CHARGES THE
BILL DOES NOT PROTECT AGAINST
OVER CHARGES THAT TO SEPARATE-
ISSUE ENTIRELY AS I JUST WANT I
WANT TO MAKE THEM. THAT ONE
ISSUE CLEAR- WITH THAT I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS TODAY. THANK YOU SO MUCH
OF HER CAREER ON I THINK THE
OTHER PIECE THAT YOU MENTION IT
ALSO BRINGS US IN LINE WITH THE
ELECTRIC UTILITIES IS WELL
WHICH I THINK IS A CRITICAL IN
PARITY SO WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR
YOUR WORK ON THIS AND I KNOW
THAT YOU'RE GOING TO CONTINUE.
WORKING ON THIS ISSUE AS IT
MOVES FORWARD HERE IN THE
SENATE AND INTO THE. ASSEMBLY
AS AND WE'RE GONNA NEED TO PUT
THE BILL ON CALL THAT'S- GET
FOLKS. THE REC. MR NOW THE
FORMER MOTION IN TO BE CALL THE
ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT
FIRST RE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY. SENATOR
MCGUIRE BY. WIRE HI SENATOR
NIELSEN. SENATOR NIELSEN NO
SENATOR DORADO DORADO HI
SENATOR HERTZBERG. SENATOR
WIENER WIENER HI THREE TWO ONE.
THAT'S A CURRENTLY A THREE ONE
VOTE LAYS IN GENERAL COMMITTEE
WE'RE GONNA KEEP THE BILL OPEN
AND ALLOW CENTER HERTZBERG TO
BE ABLE TO ADD ONS AND A COPIER
THANK YOU SO MUCH WE APPRECIATE
ALL YOUR WORK. GOOD TO SEE YOU
MA'AM. JENNA COMMITTEE WE'RE
NOT GONNA BE BRINGING A-
SENATOR EGGMAN UP TO THE
PODIUM. SHE WORKS SO HARD ON
ALL ISSUES OF FOOD INSECURITY.
THAT THIS IS A GREAT BILL ON-
SP TWO FORTY. THAT FOCUSING ON
FOOD BANKS. THAT LAYS IN GERMAN
COMMITTEE. BUT WE DO HAVE.
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT FOR THIS
BILL. WHICH WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR.
TELL US YOUR EGGMAN IF YOU'D
LIKE TO BE TO GIVE A TRUNCATED
STATEMENT WE WELCOME THAT.
INCINERATE MAN AGAIN THANK YOU
FOR ALL YOUR WORK ON THIS
REALLY CRITICAL BILL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. MISTER CHAIR AND I'M
HERE TODAY JUST PERCENT SB TWO
FORTY A STRAIGHTFORWARD BILL
THAT EXTENDS THE TAX CREDIT. TO
WAR FARMERS AND FOOD PROCESSORS
CAN DELIVER TO FARMING IN FOOD
BANKS. WE KNOW FOLKS ARE OUT
THERE ARE HUNGRY I COULD TALK
FOREVER ABOUT I WON'T GET TO
SAY THIS GETS. FRESH FRUITS
VEGETABLES. INTO THE HANDS OF
PEOPLE WHO ACTUALLY NEED IT
WITH ME HERE TODAY TO TESTIFY
IS HEIDI MCCUE FROM FOOD THE
PEOPLE. THE FOOD BANK FOR
HUMBOLDT COUNTY. N. ANDREW
SHANE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF FOOD BANKS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. AGAIN SENATOR DISHONOR I
RECOGNIZE YOU FOR BRINGING
FORWARD THIS BILL THIS IS SO
CRITICAL ESPECIALLY RIGHT NOW
DURING KOBE- IN FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP IT IS TRULY
APPRECIATED. MASON JAR
COMMITTEE WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE
GOING TO. THOSE WHO ARE
ACTUALLY DO SUPPORT WITNESSES
THAT WE ALWAYS LOVE HEARING
FROM THE GOOD FOLKS AT FOOD FOR
PEOPLE THAN OVER AND TURN IT
OVER. TO ANDREW AS WELL. LET'S
START WITH OUR FIRST LEAD
WITNESS THAT'S HOW DO YOU Q.
FROM FOOD FOR PEOPLE YOU HAVE
THREE MINUTES- IT WILL GIVE YOU
THIRTY SECOND PROPER ONE
REMINDER LEE WITNESSES THOUGH.
YOU DO HAVE BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
ON THIS BILL. IS DUE. TO THE
FLOOR IS YOURS THREE MINUTES.
THANK YOU FEDERAL. A I WANNA
THANK BECOME FOR HAVING ME
ACTUALLY STAYED I READ. FOOD
FOR PEACE TO BE FOR HUMBOLDT
COUNTY. LIKE FOOD BECAUSE THE
COUNTRY WE BEEN INTO. BY THE
PANDEMIC. WITH AN INCREASING
NEED FOR OUR SERVICES.
ADDITIONALLY WE'VE EXPERIENCED
APPLY DESTRUCTION DUE TO THE
PANDEMIC PARTICULARLY OF
PRODUCE. DELIVERY FROM OTHER
PARTS OF THE STATE. I
DISRUPTING AREN'T YOU TO HOME
VOEPEL THREE LANDSLIDE CAN
COMPLETELY. THE ENTIRE COUNTY
FOR THIS REASON OUR LOCAL
PRODUCERS ARE OF CRITICAL
IMPORTANCE TO OUR COMMUNITY AND
OUR BIG BANKS- OUR- LOCAL
PRODUCERS ARE NOT THE LARGE
SCALE FARMERS THE CALIFORNIA
FAMOUS FOR. EITHER SMALL
SPECIALTY CROP FARMERS TO DO
THIS FOR THE LOVE OF GROWING
FOOD ABOUT WHAT THE COMMUNITY.
THEY DO NOT DO THAT TO MAKE
MONEY I AM ACTUALLY PERSONALLY
INSPECTED SEVERAL FARMERS
ACCOUNT FOR SUPPLICATION. I
WOULD HIGHLY THE FARMER WHO IS
VERY GENEROUS TO COOPER PEOPLE
EDDIE CANTOR OF EARTHLY EDIBLE
FARMS. NINE ACRE FARM SEATED IN
THE CITY OF ARCADIA. LAST YEAR
HE DONATED THREE THOUSAND EIGHT
HUNDRED AND SIXTY ONE POUNDS
PRODUCED OF THIRTY TWO
DIFFERENT TYPES OF ALL RIGHTY.
THE FOOD FOR PEOPLE. WELL BE
OPERATED CAN ONLY FOR TO HIRE A
COUPLE PEOPLE MORE FORM. IT
MUST BE HARVESTED PACKED
PARTICULAR FOR. I LIKE HEIRLOOM
TOMATOES. IT MUST KEPT COLD AND
COURT WELCOME TRY. ACROSS OUR
LARGE REGION. ALMOST LIKE AT
THE UTILIZED THE AT BEACH FORTY
TAX CREDIT ON AND WE WOULD.
YOUR SOME TO PREVENT IT FROM.
AND IT FOR ANOTHER FIVE YEARS.
THE COMMONSENSE POLICY NEEDED
CAMPAIGN MAKE AND IT'S A WIN
WIN FOR CALIFORNIA FARMERS AND
HUNGRY CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISS PIGGY
WE'RE APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS
TODAY FOR ALL YOUR WORK ON
BEHALF OF FOOD FOR PEOPLE. PLAY
THE GAME AND WE DO HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF FOOD
BANKS WHO ARE ON THE LINE
PREPARE TO BE ABLE TO ANSWER
ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS ON THIS
ITEM- BUT IF IT'S ALRIGHT WITH
A IS THAT A GOOD SENATOR. FROM
STOCKTON WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO IS
WE'RE GONNA GO TO. OTHERS WHO
MAY BE IN SUPPORT AT THIS TIME
BUT SAID GO TO ROOM TWENTY
FORTY ROOM TWENTY FORTY THOSE
WHO ARE IN SUPPORT IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. HEARING SEEN DOWN
WE'RE NOT GOING TO GO TOWARD
TELECONFERENCE LINE WE'RE GOING
TO ASK THE MODERATOR TO PLEASE
QUEUE UP. ALL THOSE IN SUPPORT
OF SB TWO FORTY WHICH CURRENTLY
HAS. BIPARTISAN SUPPORT META
MODERATOR IF YOU CAN PLEASE PUT
THOSE WHO ARE IN SUPPORT. OF SB
TWO FORTY IN THE QUEUE. THANK
YOU IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF S.
B. TWO FORTY YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. ONE AND THEN
ZERO FOR ANY SUPPORT OF S. B.
CHIU FORTY. AND ONE MOMENT
MISTER CHAIR WE DO HAVE A FEW
KEY OR NOT HUNDREDS. OUR FIRST
FINAL COME FROM NINE SIXTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING I AM
ALONG WITH WIDENING GROUP ON
BEHALF OF BACKING CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT. WE REALLY APPRECIATE
YOUR PHONE CALL THANK YOU SO
MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK
YOU THAT'LL COME FROM THE LINE
OF A SIXTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING CHAIR
MCGUIRE AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS-
THIS IS MORE SONNTAG NOON IN ON
A BEHALF OF THE SAN OF MARINE
BLUE BANK MORE STRONG SUPPORTER
SB TWO FORTY. I WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU TO SENATOR EGGMAN
ALSO TO THE REST OF THE
SENATORS. THE BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AS WELL. ALWAYS GOOD.
TO HEAR FROM MARCHAND THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR CALLING IN MARCHAND
GOOD TO HEAR YOUR VOICE- LET'S
GO TO- THE NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU AND AS A REMINDER IT
IS ONE AND THEN ZERO FOR
SUPPORT. AND WE WILL GO TO LINE
OF FORTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON OR GOOD MORNING-
THIS IS DEREK POCO THE LOS
ANGELES REGIONAL FOOD BANK IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU WE
APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY THANK
YOU SO MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
WE HAVE NO FURTHER SUPPORTING
QUEUE AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
MADAM MODERATOR WE'RE NOW GOING
TO BE GOING TO THOSE WHO ARE
OPPOSED TO WE DO NOT HAVE ANY
LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESSES ON
RECORD. FOR COURTESY THOUGH
WE'RE GOING TO ASK IF THERE ARE
ANY LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESSES
ON THE LINE AGAIN THE COMMITTEE
DOES NOT HAVE ONE ON RECORD.
WE'RE LOOKING FOR LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESS TO SB. TWO
FORTY. HARIAN SEEN NINE LAYS IN
GENERAL THE COMMITTEE WERE NOT
GOING TO GO TO ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. SEETHER'S OPPOSITION TO
TWO FORTY. I'M NOT GONNA
HEARING SEEN NINE WE'RE NOT
GONNA MOVE TOWARD
TELECONFERENCE LINES WE'RE
GONNA ASK THE MODERATOR TO
PLEASE QUEUE UP ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO IS OPPOSED TO SB TWO FORTY.
THANK YOU IF YOU'RE IN
OPPOSITION- SB TWO FORTY YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
ONE AND THEN ZERO FOR ANY
OPPOSITION OF S. B. TWO FORTY.
AND THERE ARE NO OPPOSITION IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU MADAM MODERATOR
APPRECIATE YOUR WORK WE'RE
GONNA BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE TO SEE IF THERE'S ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR MOTION.
JENNA COMMITTEE- VICE CHAIR
VICE CHAIR NIELSEN MEDINA SUSAN
AS YOU MOVE THE BILL- ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE.
SEVENTY NINE AGAIN CANNOT
STRESS THIS ENOUGH US IN A
MINUTE THANK YOU FOR YOUR IN
MAYES IN SUPPORT- AN INCREDIBLE
WORK ON THIS. BILL IT'S IT
REALLY GOING TO HELP FOLKS
ESPECIALLY DURING THIS CUPBOARD
IN DUES RECESSION WE'RE GOING
TO TURN THE FORMER YOU FOR
CLOTHES. YOU'RE VERY FINE
ANALYSIS POINT OUT THE FACT
DISCUSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
LITTLE BIT OVER TWO MILLION
DOLLARS RESULTING IN OVER EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS OF FOOD DONATED
INTO OUR FOOD BANKS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
IT IS AMAZING THANK YOU SO
MUCH- MADAM SENATOR WE
APPRECIATE YOUR WORK. BASINGER
COMMITTEE WERE NOW GOING TO
TURN IT OVER TO MISTER NOW
MISTER CANALES GOING TO CALL
THE ROLL IN PROVIDE A FORMAL
MOTION MR NOW. MOTION IS TO
PASS. BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SENATOR MCGUIRE HI. WIRE FIVE
SENATOR NIELSEN. NIELSEN HI
SENATOR DORADO. DRAWS HI
SENATOR HERTZBERG. SENATOR
WIENER. WIENER HI REPORTER ZERO
FOUR ZERO BIPARTISAN VOTE THANK
YOU SO MUCH CENTER EGGMAN AT
APPRECIATE THAT THANK YOU FOR
THE MOTION MISTER VICE CHAIR
WE'RE GONNA LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN
FOR THE MAJORITY LEADER. THEY
DIDN'T COMMITTEE WE'RE GOING TO
WELCOME THE PRIDE OF A RENTED
AT THE EVER COME FORWARD THAT
SENATOR GLAZERS ON SB. SEVEN
EIGHT NINE TWO. EIGHT EVER GO.
YOUR TURN RIGHT. THIS IS A NEW
THAT- GOOD SENATOR HAS BEEN
WORKING ON FOR A FEW YEARS NOW
AND WE REALLY APPRECIATE ALL OF
HIS HARD WORK SENATOR GLAZERS
THE FLOOR IS YOURS WE WELCOME
YOU TO COMMITTEE A TEACHER
THANK YOU CHAIR MCGUIRE AND- MY
HEARTY CONGRATULATIONS ON THE
NEW ADDITION TO YOUR FAMILY
THANK YOU SOME RESEARCH FUNDING
THANK YOU. THAT COULD MORE
MEMBERS- AT THIS BILL WOULD
REQUIRE RETAILERS WITH ONLINE
SALES TOTALING MORE THAN ONE
MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR TO
REPORT TO THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF TAX AND FEE
ADMINISTRATION. THE CITY OR ZIP
CODE OF THE PURCHASERS. FOR ALL
TAXABLE SALES TRANSACTIONS
ONLINE. THIS BILL IS A
TRANSPARENCY MEASURE. DESIGNED
TO SHED LIGHT ON THE BRADLEY
BURNS UNIFORM LOCAL SALES TAX
LAW. UNDER BRADLEY BURNS SALES
TAX REVENUE IS ALLOCATED TO THE
POINT OF SALE. FOR BRICK AND
MORTAR STORES THIS MEANS
ALLOCATING THE REVENUE TO THE
JURISDICTION THE STORE IS
LOCATED IN. POND LINE RETAILERS
HOWEVER HAVE THE ABILITY TO
CHOOSE WHERE THEY ALLOCATE
SALES TAX REVENUE. BE THAT A
WAREHOUSE DISTRIBUTION CENTER
OR SALES OFFICE. THIS ALLOWS
CORPORATIONS TO DIRECT REVENUES
TO A SINGLE JURISDICTION IN THE
STATE. THREAD ALLOWS
CORPORATIONS TO DIRECT THE
REVENUE FROM ONLINE SALES TO
ONE SINGLE DESTINATION IN THE
STATE. CORPORATIONS USE THIS AS
LEVERAGE WHEN NEGOTIATING WHERE
TO LOCATE WITHIN THE STATE.
WHAT RESULTS IS A RIGGED
PROCESS DRIVING CITIES TO
ACCEPT INCREASINGLY ONEROUS TAX
SHARING AGREEMENTS IN AN
EXCHANGE FOR ONLINE RETAILERS
SENDING ALL OF THE SALES TAXES
THAT THEY COLLECT IN
CALIFORNIA. TO THAT SINGLE
JURISDICTION. UNDER THESE
AGREEMENTS PRIVATE COMPANIES
PROFITABLE FROM THEIR ONLINE
SALES. AND FROM SALES TAX
KICKBACKS. OFTEN CITIES WILL
GIVE THESE COMPANIES BETWEEN
FIFTY AND 85% OF THE SALES TAX
REVENUE ALLOCATED TO THAT
JURISDICTION'S 5285% THESE
COMPANIES BENEFIT AT THE
EXPENSE OF THE PUBLIC. AT A
TIME WHEN ONLINE SHOPPING IS AT
ITS PEAK. AND CITIES ARE
STRUGGLING TO FIND PUBLIC
PROGRAMS TO COPE WITH NINETEEN.
BUT ARE SIPHONING BILLIONS
BILLIONS IN TAXPAYER DOLLARS
THROUGH THESE AGREEMENTS.
FURTHER WHEN THESE DEALS ARE
OFTEN TOUTED FOR CREATING JOBS
AND HAVING SUBSTANTIAL ECONOMIC
BENEFITS THE GAINS ARE DOUBTFUL.
SOME OF THESE AGREEMENTS DO NOT
REQUIRE THAT THE PROMISED JOBS
ARE EVER CREATED EVEN WHEN THEY
DO. THE JOBS COUNTED ARC HAS
CREATED IN ONE CITY ARE USUALLY
JUST BEING TRANSFERRED FROM ONE
CITY TO ANOTHER. ADDITIONALLY
THESE AGREEMENTS CAN ACTUALLY
FURTHER ECONOMIC INEQUALITY. AS
CITIES THAT TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THE REVENUE SHARING AGREEMENTS
OFTEN DO SO. AT THE EXPENSE OF
THEIR SIMILARLY SITUATED
NEIGHBORS. CALIFORNIA DESERVES
TO KNOW HOW MUCH REVENUE THESE
TYPES OF AGREEMENTS OR SAY
PUTTING FROM OTHER CITIES FOR
THESE REASONS SB SEVEN NINETY
TWO. WOULD REQUIRE RETAILERS
THAT PROVIDE THE DESTINATION
DATA OF ALL THEIR TAXABLE SALES
THAT'S TRANSACTED ONLINE THAT'S
ALL THIS BILL DOES IS
TRANSPARENCY SO WE CAN EXAMINE
IT ONCE MORE CLOSELY. TO SEE
HOW THESE TAX SHIFTS ARE
WORKING. FOR THE PUBLIC BENEFIT
OR AGAINST THE PUBLIC BENEFIT
AND WITH THAT RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR IPHONE. YOU SO MUCH AS
GLAZER WE'RE GOING NOW TO GO TO
THOSE WHO ARE IN SUPPORT OF SB
SEVEN NINETY TWO WE DO NOT HAVE
A LEAD SUPPORT OF WEAKNESS ON.
FILE OR RECORD HERE TODAY SO
WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO IS WE'RE
GONNA GO STRAIGHT TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY THEN WE'RE GOING
TO GO TO OUR TELECONFERENCE
LINE. SO LET'S TAKE A LOOK
BROUGH TWENTY FORTY. BROUGH
TWENTY FORTY IS AS COLD AS IT
IS HERE IN ROOM FORTY TWO OF
THREE BUT IT'S LONELIER. SO AT
LEAST WE HAVE WARM HEARTS HERE
AM I RIGHT TERRORISM. SANDRA
THIS IS ABSOLUTELY RIGHT. WE'RE
NOT GOING TO GO TO OUR
TELECONFERENCE LINE THAT WE'RE
GONNA ASK IT IS IT SEE IF THERE
ARE ANY FOLKS WHO LIKE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN NINETY
TWO NOT A MODERATOR IF WE CAN
QUEUE UP THOSE IN SUPPORT OF SB
SEVEN. NINE TWO. THANK YOU IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
SB SEVEN NINE TWO PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
I CURRENTLY HAVE ONE LINE IN Q.
FORTY ONE FORTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I AM CHAIRMAN OF THE
COMMITTEE NICK ROMANO WOULD
TELL ME TO CALIFORNIA. I'M
CALLING YOU TODAY WE DO NOT YET
HAVE A POSITION ON THIS MATTER
MEASURE- I'M TRYING IN A THIS
SECTION- TO RECOGNIZE THAT
SEVEN NINETY TWO SURELY IS IN
ALIGNMENT WITH. CITY MANAGERS
IN THE LEAGUE CALIFORNIA CITIES
RECOMMENDATION TO COLLECT MORE
INFORMATION FROM OTHER ABLE TO
HAVE INFORMED DISCUSSION AND
THE DECISION MAKING AROUND
ALLOCATION SALES TAX IN A MORE
EQUITABLE MANNER I'M
CONSIDERING BOB CITIES HAVE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AND
CITIES OF ALL OF ALL KINDS AND-
WHAT WITHOUT POSITION THE BILL
IN INSTALLMENTS THIRTY MOVING
CORD- A DISCUSSION THAT WE%
CAN'T- IS REASONABLE AND
NECESSARY. SO HOPING TO KEEP
THIS MEASURE MOVING AND WE
CONTINUE TO COME BACK AND
DISCUSS- WITH THE LEGISLATURE
ARE WHAT THE OUR CITY LEADERS
ARTICLE. THANK YOU THE REMOTE
THANK YOU SO MUCH GOOD HERE
VOICE WE'RE GONNA PUT YOU AS A
LEAD WITNESS IN THE SQUISHY
CATEGORY- IN WILL STILL BE
WORKING WITH AT THE GOOD
SENATOR ON THIS BILL THANK YOU
SO MUCH I ALSO DID LEAGUE
CITIES FOR ALL THEIR WORK. BUT
SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT OF SEVEN NINETY TWO ON.
THE LINE MADAME MODERATOR.
THANK YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER AND
YOU AT THIS. PLEASE RATHER
MODERATE NAGA BE GOING TO OUR-
WE ARE TO TURN THE FLOOR- OVER
TO LET. MR LATIMER UP FOR ME
MANY YEARS HAVE BEEN ROUGH THE-
RETAILER ASSOCIATION MISTER
LATIMER IS HERE IN PERSON IN
FORTY TWO OH THREE. MR LATIMER
YOU HAVE THREE MINUTES WE
WELCOME USER- IN OPPOSITION OF
SEVEN NINETY TWO. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN AGAIN JOHN LATIMER
ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION UNFORTUNATELY WE
ARE IN OPPOSITION TO- SB SEVEN
NINETY TWO. WE THOUGHT FRANKLY
AFTER AFTER SB FIVE THIRTY ONE
IN THE GOVERNOR'S VETO OF SB
FIVE THIRTY ONE AND IN THE SAME
YEAR THE SIGNATURE OF AB FORTY
FIVE BY MR. MEDINA WHICH
CREATED TRANSPARENCY PROCESS
AROUND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
AGREEMENTS WE REALLY THOUGHT
THIS ISSUE WAS. APPROPRIATELY
POSITIONS SO THERE WOULD BE
PLENTY OF PUBLIC DISCUSSION
ABOUT THESE ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AGREEMENTS. THAT
THE SENATOR IS CONCERNED ABOUT
AND THEN THERE FOR THE PUBLIC
TO PARTICIPATE IN THOSE IN ANY
WAY THAT THEY THEY NEEDED TO IN
THOSE LOCAL COMMUNITIES TO BE
SURE THAT THERE WERE BENEFITS
BEING GIVEN. THIS BILL
UNFORTUNATELY IS A REQUIREMENT
ON ALL RETAILERS WITH OVER A
MILLION DOLLARS IN IN ONLINE
SALES AND FRANKLY FOR OUR FOR
OUR ASSOCIATION THAT'S
VIRTUALLY EVERY SINGLE ONE OF
OUR MEMBERS WHETHER WE HAVE. A
DEVELOPMENT AGREEMENTS WERE
NOT. SO WE SEE THIS AS ANOTHER
PIZZA YOU KNOW IT'S ANOTHER
ELEMENT O REPORTING THAT WE
NEED TO DO ON TOP OF THE
REPORTING WE ALREADY DO THE
DEPARTMENT TAXES VIA FORTY. SO
WE RESPECTFULLY DISAGREE WITH
THE NEED WE APPRECIATE AND
TOTALLY SUPPORT THE
TRANSPARENCY THAT'S IN THE
MEDINA BILL BUT IN THIS CASE WE
HAVE TO DISCRETE SENATOR ON
RESPECTFULLY URGING NOT A NOBLE
TO. THE STATE THANK YOU SO MUCH
AYE MR LATIMER AND AGAIN WE
APPRECIATE YOUR IN PERSON
TESTIMONY HERE TODAY MISTER
VETERANS CAN BE HANGING OUT
WITH US- HERE DURING THIS BILL
DISCUSSION WE'RE NOW GOING TO
BE GOING TO. THAT ROOM TWENTY
FORTY TO BE A TO SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION TO
SEVEN NINETY TO. NINETEEN NINE
WE'RE NOT GOING TO GO TO OUR
TELECONFERENCE LINE WE INVITE
FOLKS TO BE TO PARTICIPATE AT
EIGHT FOUR FOUR. 1-116-364-8442
NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX FOUR IF
YOU'D LIKE TO BE TO PARTICIPATE
IN TODAY'S HEARING OR COMMENT
ON SB SEVEN NINETY TWO. WE'RE
CURRENTLY IN OPPOSITION MADAME
MODERATOR DO WE HAVE ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SEVEN
NINETY TWO IF SO. CAN. YOU
PLEASE QUEUE THEM UP NOW. THANK
YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK AND
AFTER. OF AS B. C. NINE TWO
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. MINUTEMEN AND
HELP AND WE CURRENTLY HAVE TWO
LINES IN Q. ONE THIRTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU TURN
MEMBERS MADELINE COOPER FROM
THE OPEN MARKET MORE ON BEHALF
OF THE CITY OF PARIS WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE SB SEVEN
NINETY TWO THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PHONE CALL MISS COOPER
REPRIEVE SHEET IT THAT'S GO TO
OUR NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT FORTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS THE ENGINE
LEADING HERE CALLING ON BEHALF
OF THE CITY AND PRESIDENT
RESPECTFULLY IN OPPOSITION TO
THE INTENT OF THE MEASURE-
EITHER CRIMMINS ARE INCREDIBLY
HELPFUL FOR OUR REGION AND YOU
KNOW WE NEED TO COMPLY WITH THE
TRANSPARENCY. REQUIRED FOR
ENGAGEMENT WITH THE COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT ARTICLE MOTHER WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH A
MEMBER ON THE BALLOT. THANK YOU
SO MUCH AS MAY WE PREACH YOU
CALLING IN TODAY THAT C. IF WE
ANY CALLERS IN OPPOSITION AT
SEVEN NINETY TWO MADAME
MODERATOR. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU SO MUCH
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN OF THE
COMMITTEE WERE NOT GONNA BRING
HIM BACK FOR ANY DISCUSSION.
COMMENTS QUESTIONS OR EMOTION
LOOKING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
DISEASE'S QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR
MOTION CENTER WIENER PLEASE. BY
PROGRESSIVE ERA- I SUPPORT THIS
WHAT I WANT TO COMMEND THE
AUTHOR FOR NOT LETTING GO OF
THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE IMPROVING
FINISHES ABOUT IT- THIS IS A
REAL. PROBLEM AND OUR CITIES
ARE. SO DEPENDENT ON SALES
TAXES AND NOT JUST CITIES BUT
OTHER ENTITIES AROUND THE
STATE. TO FIND BASIC SERVICES-
AND THE FACT THAT BUSINESSES
ARE ABLE TO EFFECTIVELY
MANIPULATE- THE SALES TAX
SYSTEMS AND REAP BENEFITS BY
BEING ABLE TO MANIPULATE. SALES
TAXES I THINK IT'S REAL REAL
PROBLEMS THANK YOU FOR
CONTINUING TO PUSH ON THIS AND
I'VE AND I MOVED THE BILL. WE
HAVE A MOTION A MOTION ON THE
FLOOR BY SENATOR WIENER WE'D
LIKE YOU TO SEE IF THERE'S ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE FROM COMMITTEE. ERIN
C. NINE WE'RE GONNA TURN OVER
TO CENTER GLAZER FOR THE CLOSE.
THANK YOU CHAIR YOU KNOW LET
LAST SESSION WHEN YOU PASSED IN
THE SENATE IN THE ASSEMBLY
OVERWHELMINGLY PASSED MY
LEGISLATION TO DO. THIS STUFF
BUT JUST CREATE A FREEZE FOR NO
MORE NEW DEALS NOT EVEN.
REVERSING THE OTHERS THE OLD
ONES- IT UNFORTUNATELY- THAT
BILL WAS VETOED BY THE GOVERNOR
OF WITH THE ARGUMENT THAT
THERE. WAS GONNA HURT ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT IN THE TOWNS THAT
MADE THESE DEALS. AND- YEAH IT
IS I WANT TO HAVE THAT DEBATE
AGAIN BUT I WANT TO HAVE IT ON
A PLANE THAT HAS THE FAX AND
THE FACTS IS WHO'S WINNING AND
WHO'S LOSING AND OUR
CALCULATIONS ARE ABOUT 5% OF
OUR CITIES ARE WINNING AT SOME
LEVEL AND 95% ARE LOSERS THIS
BILL IF IT PASSES IS GOING TO
REVEAL THE TRUTH ABOUT WHO ARE
THE WINNERS ANDLOSERS AND
THAT'S WHAT. MY FRIENDS ON THE
RETAILER SO I DON'T WANT THE
PUBLIC TO SEE AND FOR US TO SEE
IF POLICY MAKERS ARE THESE
AGREEMENTS WORKING OR NOT
THAT'S NOT WHAT'S ON THE TABLE
NOR IS EVEN A FREEZE WHICH WAS
ON THE TABLE LAST YEAR IN IN
THIS COMMITTEE OVERWHELMINGLY
PASSED. THE SIMPLY SAYS IT GIVE
US THE DATA ABOUT WHERE THOSE
TAX FUNDS ARE GOING AND IF WE
CONCLUDE WHERE THEY SHOULD HAVE
GONE THAT'S ALL AND THAT
COLLECTION BY THE WAY IS DONE
BUT I IN EVERY TRANSACTION- IF
THE COMPANY SELLS YOU SOMETHING
THEY KNOW WE'RE THEY'RE
DELIVERING IT THIS IS NOT
CREATING ANY NEW BUREAUCRACY
FOR THESE COMPANIES SO I
APPRECIATE THE CONCERNS THEY
HAVE ABOUT THIS BILL. BUT WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU TO MOVE
THIS BILL FORWARD TODAY THANK
YOU BIG SEMI CENTER GLAZER
SENATOR GLAZERS ASKING FOR AN
AYE VOTE ON SB SEVEN NINETY TWO
LAZY JIM COMMITTEE WERE NOT
GOING TO TURN IT OVER TO
CONGRESS MR CANAL IS GOING TO
CALL THE VOTE IN PROVIDE THE
FORMAL MOTION MR NOW. MOTION IS
TO PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR MCGUIRE
HI REQUIRED. BY SENATOR NIELSEN.
ALSO IN NO SENATOR DO. DORADO
FIVE SEVEN HERTZBERG. SENATOR
WIENER WIENER HI THREE ONE
SEVEN CURRENTLY ENJOYS A THREE
ONE VOTE TO AND WE'RE GONNA
KEEP THEIR OPEN SOONER GLAZER
AND ALLOW THE MAJORITY LEADER
TO ADD ON WHEN HE COMES BACK
THANK YOU CHAIR REQUIRE AND I
DIVE INTOCOLLECTED TO
MENTIONED OF APPRECIATION I
HAVE FOR YOUR STAFF WHO WORKED
ON THIS LEGISLATION WITH MY
OFFICE AND WROTE THAT EXCELLENT
ANALYSIS THAT YOU SAW EARLIER
SO THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH
SENATORS NOT CALLING IN THE
ENTIRE GOVERNMENT FIGHT TEAM
ARE AMONG THE BEST AND WE'RE.
SO APPRECIATE THANK YOU FOR
MAKING THAT SIR. ALL RIGHT. BUT
IN GENERAL WE'RE MOVING. WE'RE
MOVING TO ITEM NUMBER SEVEN.
THIS IS A REALLY CRITICAL BILL.
FOR SENATOR LAYERS DISTRICT AND
IN PARTICULAR FOR THE CITY OF
ATASCADERO. BUT WE SEEN SIMILAR
BILLS LIKE THIS IN FRONT OF THE
COMMITTEE. BEFORE AND I JUST
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO SENATE
EARLIER THERE ARE VERY FEW
MEMBERS OF. THE LEGISLATURE TO
GO TO BAT FOR THE DISTRICT. AS
MUCH AS AN EARLIER DOES SIMILAR
THE FLOOR IS YOURS. ON IS P.
FOUR THIRTY EIGHT. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I SHOULD PROBABLY
JUST SAY I REQUEST AN AYE VOTE
AFTER THAT YOU DO A BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT- BUT THIS IS A DISTRICT
BILL. AND IT IS FOR THE CITY OF
ATASCADERO WHICH IS THIRTY FIVE
IT HAS THIRTY THOUSAND
RESIDENTS IN THE COUNTY OF SAN
LUIS OBISPO. AND IT IS SLIGHTLY
DIFFERENT FROM. BILLS THAT YOU
MIGHT OF HEARD ON THE SUBJECT
OF LEFTOVER ISSUES FROM
REDEVELOPMENT AND THE CLOSURE
OF REDEVELOPMENT. AND
BASICALLY- THIS IS IT- SB FOUR
THIRTY EIGHT. THE CITY OF
ATASCADERO. TO LAUNCH THE
REDEVELOPMENT DISTRICT BETWEEN
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT TO. TWO
THOUSAND TWO MADE LOANS TO THE
REDEVELOPMENT DISTRICT. AND
THEN. FOURTEEN MILLION DOLLARS
WAS SWEPT FOR THE STATE. ONE
POINT THREE MILLION DOLLARS IN
LOANS WAS NEVER REPAID. THE
END. OF THE REAL ISSUE HERE IS
REPAYING THE LOAN STEP WERE
MADE FROM THE CITY IT'S A SMALL
CITY THAT IS A BIG DEAL TO. TO
ITS GENERAL. FUND AND- THE
ISSUE IS THAT THE OF FOR. DOES
WRECK. TO LONG AS HAVE BEEN FOR
IN THE RIGHT DOCUMENTS. TO BE
ABLE TO BE ENFORCEABLE
OBLIGATIONS FOR THE REPAYMENT
AND YET. ATASCADERO TO
EXPECTATION OF REPAYMENT WERE
CLEARLY DOCUMENTED IN THE
ORIGINAL LOAN PAPERS CONFIRMED
AND RESOLUTIONS CONFIRMED IN
LOAN AGREEMENTS CONFIRMED IN
ADOPTED BUDGETS CONFIRMED AN
ANNUAL AUDITS. CONFIRMED IN
STATEMENTS OF INDEBTEDNESS.
SNACK CONFIRMED IN CITY
FINANCIAL PLANNING DOCUMENTS
AND THERE WERE A HUNDRED AND
TEN CASH PAYMENTS. BACK ON
THESE LOANS SO THESE WERE
CLEARLY LOANS AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCES SAID
THAT THEY JUST DON'T RECOGNIZE
THESE AS THE CORRECT DOCUMENTS
TO BE ABLE TO ALLOW FOR THE
REPAYMENT. THIS BILL WOULD
RECOGNIZE THESE US IN FORCIBLE
OBLIGATIONS TO ALLOW THE
REPAYMENT AND- AS MUCH AS I
SUPPORTED OTHER BILLS ON
REDEVELOPMENT. THEY WERE ABOUT
USING MONEY THAT WAS LEFT THIS
IS REALLY ABOUT JUST CLEANING
UP THE LAUNCH BACK TO THE
GENERAL FUND. IT'S SPONSORED BY
THE CITY OF ATASCADERO. IT'S
WIDELY SUPPORTED IN SAN LUIS
OBISPO COUNTY BY THE COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS TO TASK
ETERNAL SCHOOL DISTRICT
ATASCADERO CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
AND OTHER STAKEHOLDERS. WITH ME
TO TESTIFY BRIEFLY IN SUPPORT
TODAY IS MAYOR HEATHER MORENO
WHAT THE CITY OF ATASCADERO.
AND ALSO. A JOSH CROSS THE
INTERIM CHAIR AND PRESIDENT OF
THE ATASCADERO CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE I APPRECIATE THE TIME
AND I ASKED FOR AN IPHONE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
SENATOR ALL RIGHT LASERJET
COMMITTEE WE'RE GONNA GO TO
RALLIED SUPPORT WITNESSES EACH
SUPPORT WITNESS WILL HAVE THREE
MINUTES TO BE A TESTIFYING FROM
COMMITTEE. WE'RE SO GRATEFUL
THAT MAYOR MARINO WAS WITH US
AS SHE IS THE MAYOR FROM THE
BEAUTIFUL CITY OF ATASCADERO ON
THIS CRITICAL ISSUE THAT'S
BEING. ADVANCED BY SENATOR
LAYERED MADAM MAYOR YOU'RE IN
COMMITTEE YOUR. THREE MINUTES
AND THE FLOOR IS YOURS. MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE
THANK YOU THE- TO SPEAK TODAY
ON SB FOUR THIRTY EIGHT AND ON
BEHALF OF THE ENTIRE ATASCADERO
CITY COUNCIL I ALSO WANT TO
ESPECIALLY THANK SENATOR LARRY
FOR INTRODUCING THIS BILL.
DOESN'T EVEN HAVE TO GET OUR-
HAS THE WORKING CONSTRUCTIVELY-
COOPERATIVELY AND SUCCESSFULLY
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IN THE CITY SINCERELY
APPRECIATE THEIR PARTNERSHIP.
UNFORTUNATELY AS THE SENATOR
STATED CURRENT LAW PRECLUDES
BOTH THE CITY AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE FROM
RESOLVING THEIR OUTSTANDING
LOAN MATTERS ABSENT OF THE
ENACTMENT OF THIS BILL. HI THE
POSITIVE EFFECTS OF THE
INVESTMENT MADE BY THE
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCY ARE STILL
FELT TODAY WOULD CONTINUE
PRIVATE INVESTMENT AND PROPERTY
TAX GROWTH IN THE REDEVELOPMENT
AREA. AND BECAUSE OF THE
POSITIVE EFFECTS OF THE RTA ON
THE COMMUNITY I AM HAPPY TO SAY
THAT THE REPAYMENT OF THESE
LOANS IS UNANIMOUSLY SUPPORTED
BY THE OTHER TAXING ENTITIES.
AGAIN THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME AND CONSIDERATION AND
PLEASE VOTE I ON SENATE BILL
FOR THIRTY EIGHT. THANKS FOR
TAKING TIME OUT OF YOUR BUSY
SCHEDULE WE'RE GRATEFUL THAT
YOU'RE PARTICIPATING FOR ALL OF
YOUR LEADERSHIP. BASINGER
COMMITTEE WERE NOW GOING TO BE
GOING TO JOSH CRISES
REPRESENTING THE ATASCADERO
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE. MISTER
CROSS YOU HAVE THREE MINUTES
WE'LL GIVE YOU THIRTY SECOND
PROMPT THE FLOOR IS YOURS IN
SUPPORT OF SB FOUR THREE EIGHT.
GOOD MORNING AND THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK TODAY ON S. B. FOR
THIRTY EIGHT. SINCE THE
INCEPTION OF THE ATASCADERO
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCY IN
NINETEEN NINETY NINE. THE
ATTACHED TO THE BUSINESS
COMMUNITY HAS BEEN HIT BY THE
RAVAGING EFFECTS. OF THE TWO
THOUSAND THREE STAND SENIOR
EARTHQUAKE. THE GREAT RECESSION
BLOSSOM REDEVELOPMENTS AND THE
COVERT PANDEMIC. THE LOAN FUNDS
WERE INVESTED IN LEGITIMATE AND
SUCCESSFUL REDEVELOPMENT
PROJECTS THAT TRANSFORM OUR
DOWNTOWN GENERATED SUBSTANTIAL
TAX INCREMENT FOR THE RTA'S
TAXING ENTITIES. AND PRESERVE
THE GROWTH POTENTIAL OF ITS TAX
BASE FOLLOWING A DEVASTATING
EARTHQUAKE IN TWO THOUSAND
THREE. NOW REPAYMENT OF THE
SORELY NEEDED LOAN FUNDS IS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT FOR THE
FISCAL HEALTH OF OUR COMMUNITY
IN ORDER TO CONTINUE TO PROVIDE
THE SERVICES AND INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENTS NECESSARY. TO SERVE
OUR STRUGGLING BUSINESSES AND
THE ENTIRE COMMUNITY. PLEASE
REASONS I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR I. BOATS ON S. B. PORT
THIRTY EIGHT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I THANK MR CROSS AGAIN
THANK YOU FOR PARTICIPATING IN
TODAY'S HEARING WE'RE NOW GOING
TO BE GOING TO THOSE WHO MAY BE
IN SUPPORT. OF SB FOUR THIRTY
EIGHT HERE IN THE CAPITAL
THAT'S FIRST START IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY ROOM TWENTY FORTY
ANYONE IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
HEARING SEEN NINE AT WE DON'T
HAVE ANYONE IN SUPPORT- IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE. WHICH MEANS
WE'RE GONNA BE GOING TOWARD
TELECONFERENCE LINE WE'RE GONNA
GO TOWARD TELECONFERENCE
FINALLY WELCOME YOUR
PARTICIPATION AT. 844-291-6364
BETTER MODERATOR FIFTY WHAT
THOSE WHO ARE IN SUPPORT OF SB
FOUR THIRTY EIGHT NOW. THANK
YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB FOUR THREE EIGHT
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE
ONE COMMENTING CUTE JUST ONE
MOMENT. REMEMBER MODERATOR WERE
CURRENTLY ON FOR THIRTY EIGHT
WE ARE ALSO GOING TO BE LOOKING
FOR OUR NEXT AUTHORS- SO WE'RE
GONNA NEED TO BE ABLE TO BRING
IN SENATORS SKINNER- HERE ON SB
EIGHT SO WE'RE ON THE HUNT
PRESIDENT'S GONNA SERGEANTS ARE
ON IT IN MOVEMENT SO THANK YOU
SO MUCH GERMAN. FOR YOUR WORK
ON THAT SIDE WILL TURN IT BACK
OVER TO YOU MADAM MODERATOR.
THANK YOU DON'T MIND SIXTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. BRIAN
SIX EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU JERRY MCGUIRE AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I AM
FAMILIES OBISPO COUNTY FIFTH
DISTRICT SUPERVISOR DEBBIE
ARNOLD. HEARTED REPAYMENT OF
THE LOAN I URGE YOU TO VOTE I
SB FOUR THIRTY EIGHT THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME AND
CONSIDERATION. BENHAM
SUPERVISOR THANK YOU FOR
CALLING IN TODAY NO HOBBIES YOU
ARE IN IT WE ARE REALLY
GRATEFUL THAT YOU TAKE TIME OUT
OF THAT SCHEDULE THAT TO BE A
TO BE WITH US AND THANKS FOR
ALL YOUR HARD WORK AND A
SUPERVISOR. I DID SEE A META
MODERATOR IF WE HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL CALLERS IN SUPPORT
OF FOUR THIRTY EIGHT. THANK YOU
I HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU MENTAL
MODERATOR LAZY GENTLEMAN THIS
IS ARE WE GOING TO OPPOSITION
WE HAVE THREE WAYS WE'RE GONNA
SEEK OPPOSITION- WE'RE GONNA
LOOK HERE IN FORTY TWO OR
THREE. THAT WE DO NOT HAVE
ANYONE IN FORTY TWO OH THREE.
THAT WE'RE GOINGTO THEN GO TO
ROOM TWENTY FORTY NOTHING IS
HAPPENING IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
WE'RE NOW GOING TO GO TO OUR
PHONE LINES AND BY THE WAY LAYS
IN GERMAN WE HAVE NO LEAD
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION ON
RECORD. SO WE'RE GONNA GO TO
OUR PHONE LINES- TELECONFERENCE
LINE WE'RE GONNA ASK THEM OUR
MODERATOR IF WE HAVE ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION. FOUR THIRTY EIGHT
ON THE LINE AND IF SO CAN YOU
PLEASE PUT THEM IN THE QUEUE
NOW. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB FOUR
THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
CURRENTLY HAVE NO LINES THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME THANK YOU SO
MUCH READING MODERATE
APPRECIATE ALL YOUR WORK WE'RE
GONNA BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE. I DO SEE IF WE HAVE
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR MOTION.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY CENTER
DRAWS- JUST- RIGHT IN FRONT OF
CENTER WIENER SO THERE WE GO.
SO I SENATOR ALSO GETS THE
MOTION ON THE FLOOR. AGAIN
WOULD LIKE TO RECEIVE ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS. PERRANCE TINA TURNER
IT'S AN EARLIER- FOR A CLOSING
COMMENT THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION I REQUEST AN
IPHONE. THANK YOU SO MUCH THIS
IS SB FOUR THIRTY EIGHT MOTION
ON THE FLOOR BY CENTER DORADO.
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO MISTER NOW
FOR A THE FORMAL MOTION- AND
THE CALLING OF THE ROLE THE
SERVER NOW. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SENATOR MCGUIRE HI. REQUIRE. HI
SENATOR NIELSEN. NIELSEN HI
SENATOR DO. DURAZO HI SENATOR
HERTZBERG. SENATOR WIENER
WIENER HI THE FOUR ZERO FOUR IS
ZERO VOTE BIPARTISAN VOTE RIGHT
THERE THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
LABOR TO KEEP THE BILL ON HOLD
ON COSTS THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO
MAKE YOU GAIN TO THE MAYOR TO
THE SUPERVISOR FOR CALLING IN
TODAY. AS IN GERMAN WE'RE NOW
MOVING ON TO S. EIGHT CENTER
SKINNER IS ONE OF THOSE HERE
IN. THE SENATE AS- WORKERS ON
ALL ISSUES- HOUSING. THIS BILL
IS PART OF THE CITY'S HOUSING.
PACKAGER MORE GRATEFUL FOR HER
LEADERSHIP ON SB EIGHT IN ALL
ISSUES OF HOUSING THE FLOOR IS
YOURS MADAM SENATOR TO BE TO
PRESENT SENATE BILL EIGHT AND I
DO WANNA LET YOU KNOW MENTAL
CENTER AT YOUR BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT ON THIS BILL. EXCELLENT
THANK YOU SO MUCH CHAIRED
MEMBERS THEN I WILL BE BRIEF
THANK YOU SB EIGHT ALLOWS. SB
THREE THIRTY A BILL THAT WE
SUCCESSFULLY PASSED WAS SIGNED
INTO LAW. IT ALLOWS YOU TO BE
EXTENDED PAST THE SUNSET THAT
IT HAD THE CURRENT LAW HOUSE
WHICH IS TWENTY TWENTY FIVE AND
THE REASON WHY WE WANT TO
EXTEND THAT SUNSET IS BECAUSE
SB THREE THIRTY IS WORKING WHAT
IT DID IS GREEN LIGHTS HOUSING
THAT MEETS OUR EXISTING ZONING
PLANNING AND LAND USE RULES. SO
IT DOES NOT REQUIRE THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT TO CHANGE ANY OF
THEIR EXISTING RULES IT JUST
GREEN LIGHTS THAT HOUSING THAT
MEETS THOSE RULES AND IT JUST
PUT SOME BOUNDARIES AROUND. THE
NUMBER OF HEARINGS THE PROCESS
AND ALL SO THAT WE CAN GET
HOUSING THAT IS THAT MEETS THE
RULES DON'T FASTER SO WITHOUT I
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT AND I
WOULD HAVE MY WITNESSES PEDRO
GALV PHùFROM THE NONPROFIT
HOUSING ASSOCIATION OR THE
CALIFORNIA AND JONATHAN FOR WHO
IS A CITY OF OAKLAND PLANNING
COMMISSIONER. COMMISSIONER TO
SPEAK ALL RIGHT THANK YOU SO
MUCH SENATE SKINNER SO I LAYS
IN GERMAN LET'S GO TO OUR TO
THE WITNESSES WERE GOING TO
FIRST START WITH PEDRO FROM THE
NONPROFIT HOUSING ASSOCIATION
THEN WE'RE GONNA GO TO JONATHAN.
WITH CONSIDER COALITION. TO OUR
LEAD WITNESSES WE JUST WANT LET
YOU KNOW THE YOU ARE BY.
SUPPORT FOR THESE BILLS WE'RE
GONNA ADD OUR WOULDN'T. IF YOU
DON'T MIND BUT TO BE ABLE TO
KEEP YOU. ATTENTION NO MORE
THAN THREE MINUTES IF YOU WANT
TO GO SHORTER BECAUSE YOU DO
HAVE BIPARTISAN SUPPORT WE
WELCOME THAT IS WELL. SO LET'S
GO FIRST TO PEDRO- WELCOME TO
COMMITTEE THE FLOOR IS YOURS
AND THANK YOU FOR ALL YOUR WORK
SIR FROM THE NONPROFIT HOUSING
ASSOCIATION ROBIN CALIFORNIA
PEDRO. WELCOME THANK YOU SO
MUCH CHARM MCGUIRE- BY SHARE
NIELSEN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I REALLY APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK THIS
AFTERNOON- I'M CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF STA BY
SENATOR SKINNER. BECAUSE OF THE
FROM THE PERSPECTIVE WILL
CONTINUE THE SUCCESS OF SB
THREE THIRTY BY MAINTAINING THE
PREDICTABILITY. AND LOCAL
HOUSING APPROVAL PROCESS. AS A
YOU NOTED MICHAEL INPUT HAS.
SUPPORT ON KEEP MY COMMENTS
BRIEF- BASICALLY I WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THAT PORTABLE HAWKING.
BY ALL OTHER DEVELOPMENTS. TO
ABIDE BY LOCAL YET IN THE PAST.
TO HELP THE PARTS BUT THAT THE
THREE THIRTY PROJECTS OF.
SOMETIME FOR YOU DUE TO
ARBITRARY CHANGE THAN LOCAL
REQUIREMENTS EVEN THE PROJECT
HAS BEEN APPROVED- ONE EXAMPLE-
I WANT TO KNOW OF THE SUCCESSOR
THE THREE THIRTY- IN CREATING
PREDICTABILITY IN THE HOUSING
GOOGLE PROCESS HAVE BEEN BACK
NGH MEMBERS HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
CHAT. AFFORDABLE HOUSING
THROUGH. AND INCLUDING ONE
PROJECTS TO BAT HOUSING WILL BE
ABLE TO GET THROUGH IN HAYWARD
WHERE THEY GOT SEVENTY OF
PORTABLE HOMES APPROVED. DUE TO
SB THREE THIRTY LIMITATION ON
THE NUMBER OF HEARINGS AT A
LOCAL GOVERNMENT CAN HAVE
BEFORE CREEPING OR DENYING.
DEVELOPMENT ANOTHER INSTANCE
WHERE- AFFORDABLE HOUSING UP TO
FASTER IN IS ENCAMPMENTS CISCO
WITH. THE CHILDREN'S- WHICH
WILL PROVIDE A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY FOUR NEW HOMES AND SB
THREE THIRTY WAS RESPONSIBLE
FOR SHOOTING OFF SIX MONTHS OF
NOT APPROVAL PROCESS. SO AS THE
STATE CONTINUES ON THE PATH TO
RECOVERY IT IS CRITICAL THAT
YOU CONTINUE TO SUPPORT HOUSING
AND- I AM VERY GLAD FOR YOUR
SUPPORT THANKS EIGHT- TO
MAINTAIN PREDICTABILITY IN
CALIFORNIA TALKING A COUPLE
CONCEPTS. SO WITHOUT I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
IPHONE I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR APPRECIATE YOU CALLING IN
TODAY LAYS IN GERMAN COMMITTEE
WE'RE GONNA GO TO OUR SECOND
LEAD WITNESS IN SUPPORT OF- SB
EIGHT. THAT'S JONATHAN FROM THE
CONSIDER COALITION JONATHAN WE
DO HAVE BIPARTISAN SUPPORT ON
THIS. BILL THE FLOOR IS YOURS
SIR. THANK YOU SO- CHAIRMAN.
AND OF THE COMMITTEE- MY NAME
JONATHAN ABOUT TWENTY
COMMISSIONER THE CITY OF. CA AT-
A BOARD MEMBER FOR THE CRITICAL.
AND ALSO DIRECTOR DAHLE A GREAT
OUR- WHICH IS A LEADING TO.
BUDGET HOUSING- AS OF SKINNER
MENTION IN OUR OPENING THEM ST-
IS- AND- DOES OR MUCH OF CRISIS.
WELL BECAUSE WE STILL THE
BUILDING HOLLISTER DECADE- THE
PLAN COMMISSIONER AND HOW THAT
ALL I DO KNOW HOW FIRSTHAND HOW
JOHN. ENOUGH THE COUNTRY TO THE-
TO PRODUCE HIGH WHICH IS DO
CHANGE THE RULES. THROUGH
DEVELOPER- PROBABLY EASILY
PARAMOUNT CONVERSE UNSERVED
DOES- KILL OR MAKE A PROJECT
MUCH MORE. EXPENSIVE INTO THIS
IS OWNING- YOU KNOW WE CAN.
THAT ABOUT FEDERAL PER AND- A
LOCAL USED GOING ON DO COULD ON
IT FASHION. ON THAT CREDIT TO
MAXIMIZE ARGUABLY NUMBER
FUNDING SOURCE AVAILABLE HOW TO
GO. TYPICALLY APART HOUSING.
AND INCREASE THE FLAG OF THESE
ACTUALLY GET PAID- JUST IS A.
SKINNER I'M- WAS IN BY IN A
CRASH. THAT WAS- COULD FORM HIS
OWN WAS CAN- THE TOOK OUT
NEARLY SO YEARS TO ANTI. A
LOAN- AND ALWAYS A- AFTER
CUTTING THEM OF UNITS BY HALF-
BUT WE ARE YOUR ACTUAL
CURRENTLY WERE A GREAT- ON
THREE FIVE. THIRTY AS CITY OF
NOT VIEW ACCUSING ITS OF METAL
PARK- WHICH ARE. VERY WELL- AND
ALSO- ARE ARE YOU GOING TO
SCHOOL. I'M IN THE PARK STAFF.
TO MOVE TROOPS. SO IT IS WHAT
IT IS MAX- S. EIGHT DOES TO
PRAGUE OF THREE THIRTY PROVIDES
REDUCE IS NOT ONLY TO THE BUT
THE LOCAL ON. BY SERVING THE
SENSE OF AND USED TERMS TO
GREEN LIGHT FOR THE HOUSING FOR
SO- THAT- COURAGE THIS
SUBCOMMITTEE TO- WITH- I'VE-
AND TO DENNIS THE TRUTH- BY
TAKING PRUDENT NEEDS AND STAY
ONGOING HOUSING. I AM PLEASED
TO SB EIGHT THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION HEY THANKS SO
MUCH JOHN WITH SHE CALLING IN.
GERMAN FOR NOW GOING TO BE
GOING TO ROOM TWENTY WE'RE
GONNA CONTINUE WITH OUR A
TESTIMONY SUPPORT THE SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE ROOM TWENTY
FORTY AGAIN AT SAID THIS A GOOD
THERE'S NO WONDER MENTAL FORTY
ARE. THAT'S ARGUED IS GOING TO
SURGERY OUT WHAT WE'RE THERE
NOW WE'RE GOING TO GO TO OUR
PHONE LINE ARE GONNA GO OUR
CALVET LAW- IN CHECK TO SEE IF
WE HAVE A- OUT SO OF S. B.
EIGHT. MADAME MODERATOR IN YOU
COULD PLEASE PUT THEM IN Q.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH SPEAKIN
SUPPORT OF S. EIGHT PLEASE PRAY
ONE AND THEN. AT TIME. I HAVE
ABOUT EIGHT IN THE QUEUE OVER
TO A THIRTY. PLEASE GOING. SURE
MEMBERS JENNIFER SECOND HAVE A
CO SO OF REALTORS HERE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
LET'S GO TURN CALLER. THANK YOU
RYAN SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS SILVIO FERRARI
ON BEHALF OF FACEBOOK IN
SUPPORT. WE APPRECIATE IT NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU I'M
SIXTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AFTERNOON HEARING MEMBERS OF
THE MATTER NOT LIKE HOW PUBLIC
AFFAIRS CALLING ON BEHALF AT
CALIFORNIAN BE HABITAT FOR
HUMANITY CALIFORNIA ENERGY
PARTNERS ACCOUNTABLE OF INTEL
BUILDERS- FEELS BAD AND HOW HER
AND EDA AND OF THE MEASURE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH WE
APPRECIATE IT LET'S GO TO OUR
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU
LINE FORTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I THINK CHAIR MEMBERS
ADAMANTLY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
ADAM. BONTA MODERATOR LET'S GO
TO OUR NEXT CALLER. THANK YOU
RIGHT EIGHTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BAN ON BEHALF OF BRIDGE HOUSING
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR YOUR PHONE CALL
TODAY NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK
YOU LINE SEVENTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU ADAM CHEN
CLICK ON MAP THE HOUSING ACTION
COALITION IN SUPPORT OF SB
EIGHT. THANK YOU SO MUCH WE'RE
VERY GRATEFUL NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU LINE SEVENTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUT
RESEARCHER THIS IS BOB NAYLOR
CONGRATULATIONS ON THE ADDITION
TO YOUR FAMILY- I AM ALSO FOR
DEALS THAT IN COMPANY
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT. MARCH
ROB VERY GRATEFUL FOR THAT IT'S
GOT OUR NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU VERY SEVENTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
KELLY CALLING CALLING ON BEHALF
OF THE BAY AREA COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PHONE CALL
TODAY. NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU ARE YOU CURRENTLY
HAVE ONE MORE COMING Q. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME.
IT'LL BE JUST ONE MOMENT FOR
NEXT COMMENT. SURVEYS IN GERMAN
I AS WE START WRAPPING UP
TESTIMONY HERE IN SB EIGHT
WE'RE GONNA BE GOING TO THE
VICE CHAIR NEXT AT CENTER
NIELSEN ON FOUR NINETY ONE. AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE WE
STILL HAVE TO ADOPT OUR CONSENT
CALENDAR IS WELL. LET'S GO TO
OUR NEXT CALLER MADAME
MODERATOR. THANK YOU OUR LAST
COMMENT IS FROM WHITE EIGHTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE EIGHT
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. ALL RIGHT
I HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR THE MODERATOR
WE APPRECIATE THAT WE'RE NOT
GOING TO BE GOING TO OPPOSITION
WITH ACTIVITY PUT ANY
OPPOSITION HERE ROOM FORTY TWO
OR THREE THERE IS NO OPPOSITION
ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE. DAYS
IN JAVA COMMITTEE WE'RE NOT
GONNA BE GOING TO ROOM TWENTY
FORTY THERE IS NO OPPOSITION IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY WE'RE NOT
GONNA BE MOVING BACK TOWARD
TELECONFERENCE LINE WE'RE GOING
TO BE SEEN IF THERE IS ANY
OPPOSITION ANY OPPOSITION TO SB
EIGHT FOLKS WHO HAVE CALLED IN.
844-291-6364 IS OUR NUMBER
TODAY IF YOU'D LIKE TO BE A TO
PARTICIPATE. IN PUBLIC COMMENT
ON ANY BILLS THAT ARE IN FRONT
OF US NOT A MODERATOR WE CAN
PLEASE KEEP UP ANY INDIVIDUAL
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF. SB EIGHT PLEASE
DO THAT NOW. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY
HAVE ABOUT FIVE IN THE QUEUE
WILL GO OVER TO LINE SEVENTY
SIX PLEASE CALL AT. MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS DESIGN WE
CALIFORNIA CITIES.
UNFORTUNATELY WE ARE OPPOSED TO
THE EXTENSION OF SB THREE
THIRTY. EIGHT WE OPPOSED SB
THREE THIRTY WHEN I WAS IN THE
LEGISLATURE FOR TWO PRIMARY
REASONS ONE. ARBITRARILY CLOSER
SEATS FOR TWO AND A HALF YEARS
IN THE DEVELOPERS. NOT BUILDING
JEFF YEARS AND STILL BE SUBJECT
TO THE SAME PIECE. AND THEN
EVENTUALLY OF COURSE
ESSENTIALLY PROHIBITED PROJECTS-
WHILE THIS WAS BEING NEGOTIATED
THE LEGISLATURE IT WAS IMPAIR
DOWN TO A FIVE YEAR SUNSET
WHICH WE THINK IS APPROPRIATE.
LAWS ON THE BOOKS FOR LITTLE
MORE THAN ONE YEAR IT SEEMS A
LITTLE TOO SOON FOR US TO
EVALUATE HOW SUCCESSFUL THIS
PROGRAMS BEN. I'M SIXTEEN ABOUT
EDUCATIONAL FIVE YEARS SEEMS A
LITTLE INAPPROPRIATE THIS TIME
AND FOR THAT WE ARE CLOSE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH AS A
BRIAN THANK YOU FOR YOUR PHONE
CALL TODAY. TO GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER IN. OPPOSITION OF S. B.
PLEASE. THANK YOU I'M SEVEN
FIVE PLEASE CALL. HELLO THIS IS
PLUGGED INTO BY MAYOR TO TOUGH.
ON BEHALF OF THE OF. WE THE
LEAGUE OF CITIES IN OPPOSING SB
EIGHT THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH COUNTY WOMAN AND THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PHONE CALL TODAY.
WE'RE NOT GOING TO GO TO OUR
NEXT CALLER. THANK YOU RIGHT
EIGHTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
AND YOUR EMPLOYEE WHICH I ENTER
INTO RESTRUCTURING LYING HERE
TODAY TO CLASSIFY IN OPPOSITION
TO SPH GUNNER ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY BURKE WILL. THANK YOU SO
MUCH ANDREW GOING TO GO TO OUR
NEXT CALLER MATAMATA WRITER.
THANK YOU I'M SEVENTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. RECALL WITH
MOVABLE CALIFORNIA AND- MISSION
THE- YOU KNOW OPPOSITION TO THE
SP A. IT IS WAY TOO EARLY TO
EXTEND- THIS BILL AND LOCAL
COMMUNITIES. NEED THAN THREE
NINE FIVE HEARINGS TO GET THE
COMMUNITY BENEFITS NEEDED FOR
PROJECTS FROM PROJECTS AND
DEVELOPERS ARE. NOW CIRCUMVENT
A- BY X. BY HAVING- USE THE
EXTENSIONS AND SO THEY ARE YOU
A THE FIVE YEAR. WITH ANY SUBS-
JUST LIKE OUT THE COMMUNITY
THIS BILL IS GOING THE
UNDERLYING BILL NOT WORKING.
AND SHOULD NOT BE EXTENDED YEAH
UNTIL WE SEE- HOW THE MAY IT
BETTER THANK YOU WE APPRECIATE
YOUR COMMENT THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR CALLING IN TODAY. FOR NOW
GOING TO NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU RYAN SEVENTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
FINALLY GABEL LUDDY NEAR
BURBANK. PART OF THE MOBILE
CALIFORNIA SALLY SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA IT SHOULD BE A TWO
YEAR BELCHER CHIEF MORE DATA.
WHEN I GAVE FOUR EXAMPLES OF
SUCCESSFUL PROJECTS ACTUALLY
FIVE THREE AND THEN THE PART.
IN ORDER TO THE REAL SUCCESS OF
THIS. THE THIRTY PART TIME
SHOULD BE GIVEN SO THAT LOCAL
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC AND LOCAL
ELECTED OFFICIALS CAN CAREFULLY
ASSESS. HOW SUCCESSFUL IT HAS
BEEN. I WOULD EVEN CURTAIL THE
PEOPLE'S VOICE EVEN MORE IT'S A
RIDICULOUS PART OF THE BILL AND
FINALLY DEVELOPERS CAN FILE
ASKING FOR CLEARING CAMPUS THAT
WILL. I AM STRONGLY OPPOSED.
RETURNING HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AS PART OF
A GLOBAL CALIFORNIA. REMEMBER
MAYOR WE YOU TAKING TIME
INTEREST SCHEDULE CALLING.
WE'RE NOT GOING TO GO TO OUR
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU I
CURRENTLY HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT THANKYOU AT THIS TIME
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU SO MUCH
I'M REALLY GRATEFUL MATTER
MODERATED FOR ALL YOUR WORK
TODAY. THANK THE GENTLEMAN
pCOMMITTEE WE'RE GONNA BRING IT
BACK FOR DISCUSSION OF PLEASE
CENTER WIENER AND I JUST WANT
TO SAY THANK YOU SIR WHEN YOUR
FOR YOUR WORK AS CHAIR OF
HOUSING AS WELL FORGERIES. GIVE
US A GERMAN- I SUPPORT THIS
BILL SB THREE THIRTY. FIVE ONE
OF THE MOST EFFECTIVE AND
IMPACTFUL. ON HOUSING BILLS
LAWS THAT WE HAVE PASSED IN
RECENT YEARS- CALIFORNIA HAD
IMMEDIATE BENEFICIAL IMPACT. ON
THE RADIO THIS IS ONE OF THOSE.
LAWS THAT I MEAN IT'S A BASIC
GOOD GOVERNMENT LAW. IT'S
BASICALLY SEVEN WHEN YOU SET UP
RULES. IN A FOR HOUSING AS A
CITY. YOUR HONOR YOUR OWN RULES
LIKE DON'T. YOU KNOW IT AND WE
HAVEN'T HAD IT THIS BAD HISTORY
CALIFORNIA RESEARCH HERE THE
RULES. I BELIEVE THOUGH YOU
COME WITH EVER SINGLE ONE OF
OUR RULES WE'RE STILL GOING TO
DRAG IT OUT AND MAKE IT
IMPOSSIBLE FOR THIS TO HAPPEN
EARNERS TIMELY MANNER SO THIS
IS A REALLY IMPORTANT LAW- I
THINK HAVING A LONGER. SUNSET
MAKES A LOT OF SENSE AWAY-
UNFORTUNATELY THE WAY HOUSING
WORKS IS IT'S NEVER AS FAST AS
WE WANTED TO BE. AN ANYONE
WHO'S PLANNING WHETHER YOU'RE A
NONPROFIT AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPER OR A- PRIVATE
DEVELOPER. YOU KNOW OR OR EVEN
A CITY FRANKLY YOU NEED TO
HAVE. A RUNWAY SO I MOVED THE
BILL. WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE
FLOOR BY CENTER WIENER THANK
YOU SO MUCH AND MISTER RICHARD
DID YOU WANT TO PROVIDE SOME
COMIC NO. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
BYE HEARING SEEING NO
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS WE DO HAVE
A MOTION FOR CENTER SKINNER
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE PLEASE
YES THANK YOU- THAT ONE OF THE-
SUPPORTERS DID MENTION THERE
ARE SOME. TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS
IN THE BILL SO I WANTED TO BE
CLEAR ON THE RECORD THAT IT IS.
IT IS AN EXTENSION OF THREE
THIRTY HOWEVER WITH A FEW
TECHNICAL CLARIFICATIONS THAT
WERE BROUGHT TO OUR ATTENTION
BY PLANNING DEPARTMENTS OF
CITIES THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
AND SO WE GLADLY TOOK THOSE
BECAUSE WE WANT THIS THIS BILL
TO WORK. SO WITH THAT I ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE THANK YOU SO MUCH
CENTER SKINNER VESTING FOR AN
AYE VOTE ON SB EIGHT SB EIGHT
WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE FLOOR
BY CENTER WIENER. MISTER NOW
WILL NOW BE PROVIDING THE
PROMOTION- IN CALLING THE ROLE
MR NOW. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON HOUSING. SENATOR
MCGUIRE HIGH WIRE. HI SENATOR
NIELSEN. SENATE DRAW. DORADO HI
SENATOR HERTZBERG. SENATOR
WIENER WIENER HI THREE ZERO
BASINGER COMMITTEE THAT'S A
THREE ZERO THREE ZERO VOTE
WE'RE GONNA KEEP THE ROAD OPEN
ALLOW THE MAJORITY LEADER BE IT
AT A FITNESS TRAINER ALWAYS ONE
OF THE FEW AND ALSO I WANT TO
SAY THANK YOU AGAIN FOR ALL
YOUR WORK ON ALL THIS IS A
HOUSING. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU. BUT IN GENERAL CAN.
AS WE SEVENTY. OF THIS- THIS.
COMMITTEE MEETING WE'RE GOING
TO BE TAKING THE VICE CHAIR OF
THE CHEERS BILLS LAST WE'RE
GOING TO NOW TURN THE FLOOR
OVER TO SB FOUR NINETY ONE AND
THAT CENTER NIELSEN I WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE CENTER NIELSEN THIS
IS NOT HIS FIRST BILL ON THE
SUBJECT. BUT HE HAS BEEN A
CHAMPION FOR THAT TO BE A TO
KEEP KIDS SAFE ACROSS
CALIFORNIA WILL ON THIS ISSUE
CENTER NIELSEN THE FLOOR IS
YOURS ON A FIFTY FOUR NINETY
ONE. AND ON CIGARETTE AND
TOBACCO PRODUCTS THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND. THANK YOU
FOR ALLOWING ME 2% FROM HERE.
THIS FOUR NINE ONE. WILL
PROHIBIT THE DEPARTMENT OF TAX
AND FEE ADMINISTRATION FROM
ISSUING A TOBACCO LICENSE TO
ONE. WHO HAS BEEN CONVICTED OF
SELLING NITROUS OXIDE TO A
MINOR DISTRIBUTING NITROUS
OXIDE. FOR DRUG USE OR WHO HAD
FAILED TO COMPLY WITH THE
STATE'S RECORD KEEPING
REQUIREMENTS FOR THE SALE OF
NITROUS OXIDE. IT WOULD ALSO
ALLOW THE REVOCATION OR
SUSPENSION OF EXISTING TOBACCO
LICENSE IF THE LICENSE SHE HAS
DISTRIBUTED NITROUS OXIDE FOR
DRUG USE FAILED TO COMPLY WITH
THE STATE'S RECORD KEEPING
REQUIREMENTS FOR THE SALE. OF
NITROUS OXIDE THIS IS A- AN
EMOTIONAL BILL HOW THE
MEMBERSHIP THE- MAYBE THE ISSUE
IS NOT AS KNOWN TO THE BROAD
PUBLIC. BUT TO THE AFFECTED
FAMILIES IT'S VERY WELL KNOWN
AS TO OUR WITNESSES WILL
ATTACHED. THIS NITROUS OXIDE.
IT IS A DRUG THAT GIVES A BIG
BOPPER FOR SURE. BUT IT IS VERY
ADDICTIVE AND VERY DANGEROUS.
NOTWITHSTANDING IT WHATEVER
EXISTING LAWS WE HAVE IN PLACE.
THE CANISTERS WHAT'S YOUR
CALLED WEAPONS I THINK IT'S A
VERY APPROPRIATE SOUNDING NAME
IF YOU WILL THIS THESE WEAPONS.
THEY ARE CONTINUING TO BE SOLD
FOR RECREATIONAL DRUG USE
MOSTLY AND TOBACCO SHOPS. BUT
THE INHALING IT CAN BE EVEN
FATAL AND WE HAVE WITNESSES WHO
TESTIFY TO THAT IMPACT. IT ALSO
THAT CAN BACK LIVE DEVELOP A
FOR INDIVIDUALS. THE DANGERS
THAT ARE WELL KNOWN. TO SOME
BUT NOT TO ALL AND THAT'S WHY I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT. I DO NOT
ACCUSE ANY OF THE- PURVEYORS OF
THIS A TOBACCO STORES OF ANY.
INSIDIOUS CONSPIRACY. NOT AT
ALL BUT I DO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT I
DON'T THINK IT'S WELL ENOUGH
KNOWN THE DISASTROUS IMPACTS.
OF THIS. ONE OF OUR WITNESSES
HERE HAD TO DATE. SUN BECAME
ADDICTED. THE TORSIONAL E.
SURVIVE BUT IT CERTAINLY SET
THE YOUNG MAN'S LIFE BACK
CONSIDERABLY. ANOTHER ONE WHO
WILL TESTIFY HERE TODAY.
SEPARATE EVEN MORE GREATLY
DINESH. TO WHICH IS THE
EMOTIONAL. IMPACT OF THIS. AND
I WOULD ARGUE THAT JUST A SLAP
ON THE WEST RESTORE A WARNING
IS NOT SUFFICIENT TO CURTAIL
THE DISTRIBUTION OF THE NITROUS
OXIDE. SOME. AB USERS CONSUME
BOXES OF THESE CANISTERS. FOR
THE TEMPORARY HIGH. THE GIVES
THEM. BUT THE CUMULATIVE IMPACT
IT'S VERY SERIOUS. AND EVEN
FATAL. SO THIS WILL HAVE. PLACE
SOME RESTRAINT. ON THE
WHOLESALE MARKETING. OF THESE
NITROUSOXIDE WEAPONS SHORT
CANISTERS. I WOULD THE EXCEPT
AS AUTHORS AMENDMENTS AND THEY
SUGGESTED THE AMENDMENTS BY THE
COMMITTEE. THEY WILL BE ABLE TO
BE HAPPY TO HAVE THOSE ADOPTED
MISTER CHAIRMAN. THE PRIMARY TO
THE- SUMMARIZE WHERE WE'RE
HEADED WE'RE HEADED TOWARDS
PROTECTING THE UNKNOWING. OF
THE IMPACTS. AND EVEN BY VIRTUE
OF THE CONSEQUENCES HERE FOR
THE SALE OF. IT'S GOING TO
EDUCATE A LOT MORE. OF STORES
WHO SELL THESE WEAPONS. TO
REALIZE THE CONSEQUENCES AND TO
RESTRAIN THEM FOR MARKETING A
PRODUCT IS DANGEROUS BUSINESS
NITROUS OXIDE IS. TO THE HUMAN
BEING. THE WITNESSES WILL BE
VICARIOUSLY COMING IN ON OUR
LINE AND IF I MAY THEN THIS TO
CHAIRMAN WE DO HAVE TO TWO
WITNESSES BARBARA LARGE WHOSE
SON BECAME ADDICTED AND
SUFFERED SEVERE DAMAGE. AND THE
MILEAGE- THE LIFE PARTNER.
AMANDA CROSBY. SHE SUFFERED
MUCH MORE GREATLY. THE LIFE
COMPANION AMANDA CROSBY AND
WE'RE GOOD KNOWLEDGE IN HER
TODAY IF I MAY THEN WHO'S
CHAIRMAN OF WE COULD HAVE THESE
FOR ME WITNESSES. THANK YOU SO
MUCH I CENTER NIELSEN SOLUTION
GERMAN WE ARE GOING TO HEAR
FROM TWO OF OUR LEAD WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT OF THIS CRITICAL
BILL AND THANK YOU. CENTER
NIELSEN OR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON
THIS BUT LET'S FIRST REQUEST
BARBARA LARGE RUBBER LODGE I
WILL BE PROVIDING THERE ARE-
TESTIMONY FOR THE FIRST LEAD
WITNESS MISS LRGE YOU HAVE
THREE MINUTES THE FLOOR IS
YOURS AND WE WELCOME YOU TO
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU THANK YOU
EVERYONE FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
YOU SPEAK TODAY. MY NAME IS
BARBARA LODGE AND I AM A NATIVE
OF LOS ANGELES I'M AN ATTORNEY
A WRITER AND A MOTHER OF TWO
ADULT CHILDREN. MY FAMILY AND I
LIVE EVERYDAY WITH THE
DEVASTATING EFFECTS OF NITROUS
OXIDE ABUSE. SCAMMING FROM AT
THE EASY ACCESSIBILITY
CALIFORNIA SMOKE AND TOBACCO
SHOP. MY TWENTY SIX YEAR OLD
SON PURCHASE SCORES OF WICKETS
FROM SMOKE SHOP DAILY FOR
MONTHS. AND ELATION OF THOSE
WITH THAT LED TO NITROUS OXIDE
INDUCED PSYCHOSIS. MORE THAN A
MONTH IN A PSYCHIATRIC WARD AT
UCLA AND RESIDUAL BRAIN DAMAGE
THAT AFFECTS HIS MEMORY AND
COMPREHENSION TODAY. HE WAS
INTRODUCED TO BE ADDICTIVE
PLEASURE OF INHALING NITROUS
WHILE RESIDING IN A LOCAL
SHELTER LIVING. ON 1100%
UNDETECTABLE ON DRUG TESTS AND
A WELL KNOWN OPTION FOR THOSE
WHO WANT TO GET HIGH WITHOUT
GETTING CAUGHT. PEOPLE DESCRIBE
THE HIGH FROM HUFFING NITROUS
AS THIRTY SECONDS OF ABSOLUTE
BLISS. WHAT THAT EUPHORIA
REALLY IS THOUGH. IT'S BRAIN
CELLS STARVING FOR OXYGEN.
OAKESHOTT SELL THESE CANISTERS
WHICH ARE 1100% PURE GAS RATHER
THAN THE DILUTED 30% USED BY
DENTIST ANESTHESIOLOGISTS. WHEN
INHALED TEAR GAS FILLS UP THE
LONG SO NO OXYGEN CAN BREATHE
INTO THE BRAIN. LEADING TO
BRAIN DAMAGE STROKES PARALYSIS
HEART FAILURE AND DEATH FROM
THE CREATION. ON ONE OCCASION
MY SON TURNED BLUE FROM LACK OF
OXYGEN AND YOUR ROOMMATE HAD TO
SLAP HIM BACK INTO
CONSCIOUSNESS. RIGHT HIS
CURRENT TO BRADY'S MY SON CAN
ANY DAY OR NIGHT WALKING TO ITS
MOST COURT TOBACCO SHOP FOR.
FIND HIMSELF FACE TO WITH HIS
DRUG CHOICE IN ALL THE WAY. AND
YOU HAPPEN TO HAVE A REAL TH
EMPLOYEE WILL WE AND NOT INTO
HIS MONEY WITH EACH. KNOWING
FULL WELL HE'S NOT GOING HOME
TO WITH CONCRETE. WHY IS IT
BUSINESS DEVOTED TO SELLING
INHALANTS EVEN ALLOWED TO SELL
A PRODUCT THAT IS ILLEGAL TO
INHALE AND DEADLY. THESE DAYS
NITROUS OXIDE ABUSE IS NOT ONLY
RAMPANT BUT REGARDED AS A QUICK
AND EASY FIX FOR COLD RELATED
STRESSORS EVEN TURNING ON
TICTOC VIDEO THE WITH THE TO
HAVE MORE THAN TWENTY SEVEN
MILLION FOLLOWERS. BY
CONTINUING TO TURN A BLIND EYE
WE'RE SENDING THE MESSAGE I'M
HEARING THAT. DRUG IS IN AND BY
AND THIS LEVEL MAPS AND
MCKNIGHT NINE BILL. FOR NINETY.
IT'S LIKE THANK YOU SO MUCH.
ALL WORK IN ASKING TEAM THINK
WE MAY A COUPLE LINES SAME TIME
BETTER MODERATOR HE CAN ME TO
LINE. THANK YOU. I WOULD WANT
TO SAY THANK YOU TO OPT ARE FOR
HER ALEX TEST HERE TO IN MEANS
A LOT TO US PLEASE ENGINE THE
SECOND LEADS WE CENTER IS FOUR
NINE ONE AND THAT'S- GOING TO
BE COMING FROM HER AND A BLUE
COLOR- HUH ABU COLOR I LOVE SO
WE WORK YOU BACK TO COMMITTEE
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO STEP UP TO
PROVIDE TESTIMONY TODAY YOU
HAVE THREE MINUTES. THE FLOOR
IS YOURS YOUR NOUN COMMITTEE.
HI THANK YOU SO MUCH CHAIR AND
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
FOR HAVING ME ON TODAY I JUST
WANTED TO SHARE A STORY WITH
YOU ON THE CALL FOR HELP JUST
GIVE YOU AN IDEA OF WHY WE NEED
TO DO THIS- MY NAME IS
MOHAMMED. EVAN WEAVER I'M
MEDICAL. AND THE CURRENT PHD
CANDIDATE UNIVERSITY.
CALIFORNIA IN THE MOVIE CARE
YOU'RE ABOUT. I BELIEVE CAL.
BETWEEN THE SANTA VALLEY AND
THE BAY SINCE TWENTY TWELVE.
TODAY JUST YOU YOU AS OF HOW
KNOCKED OXIDE AT NEW AND ACTION.
CON JUST OVERNIGHT- SO MY WIFE
PARTNER BEST FRIEND MCCARTY.
ACTUALLY EVER MET IN MY LIFE.
AND THEN THE CAR. SHE HAD BEEN
BACK WITH WHOLE BY DISORDER.
ARE YOU SEE MICHAEL SORRY WAY
TO DEAL WITH THE MORE THAN
EIGHT LOANS BUT IT CRAFTED THE
SAME ASSOCIATED WITH ELEMENTS.
CHOICE OF MARGIN OXIDE MOVES WE
SIMPLE FOR HER. ACCERN
RELATIVELY SHORT LIVED IT ISN'T
SPEAKING TO THE PERSON OF THEM
MEDICAL DRUG AND IT'S WHETHER
WE AND EASILY ACCEPT IN EVERY
CITY BLOCK. THAT FINE BECAME
ALL THAT AMANDA WAS BECOMING
AND MORE AND ON MY- BUT MAKE NO
MISTAKE NOT JUST LOOKS IS
POLITICS. YOU CAN CALL SOME
INTERNET COMPLICATIONS. THE
STAFF A FEW MINUTES RESEARCHING.
AND OFFLINE HUNDREDS OF
ARTICLES- THANK. YOU FOR THE
WEEK OF THE DEPRESSION. CORRECT
WALK DOWN MULTI SMOKE SHOPS
LOCATED ONLY BLOCKS AWAY FROM
HER HOME WHY DID EVERYTHING
THAT SHE NEEDED TO FUEL OVER
NOT JUST INSIDE ME. AS HER
ADDICTION SPIRALLED OUT OF
CONTROL SHE WROTE IN HER CAR
THE. JOURNAL THIS. HARDER TO.
EXACTLY A HUNDRED SIX DAYS AGO
ON DECEMBER NINTH. YES FOUR
DAYS AFTER HER THIRTIETH
BIRTHDAY. TWO DAYS BEFORE MY
ARRIVAL BACK HOME. SHE DID NOT
REQUIRED MARK BACK IN COURT FOR
A COUPLE OF HOURS I DID ASK
YOUR CURRENT TO GO CHECK ON HER
AND WHILE BEING LONG RESPONDED
TO- WE FOUND THE MAN'S BODY
NEAR HUNDREDS OF ANY TEAMED
WITH ITS CHARACTERS. OUT OF
CANCERS RANDOMLY SCATTERED
ACROSS THE FLOOR STOOD BETWEEN
A SINCERELY CRYING HEARING CAN.
HER ABILITY TO ACHIEVE HER BIG
DREAMS AND HOPES. AND THAT'S
WHAT. YES YOUR HOUSE. EASY IT.
ACTRESS IN I THINK YOU CAN SEE
THE TO FACT. WHILE WE WALKED
OUT AMANDA WAS ABLE TO ACQUIRE
BROWN'S OF MARCHERS CANISTERS.
BY COME ONLY PLAN COMPLETED.
AND TO SMOKE SHOPS TO NEVER
BOUGHT OF THEM OUR DOOR. AFTER
HER PASSING AND AS AN EXPERT.
ON MY IS ABLE DELIVER TO HOMES
FIVE HUNDRED POUNDS OF THE BILL
WITH BY VISITING TO SMOKE
WITHIN THIS BLOCK SAN FRANCISCO.
IT WAS A YEARS AGO TO THE
TABLES TO BUY THAT DOLLARS.
BECAUSE. YEAH PURCHASING OUT
COMO TO THIRTY NOT EVEN AFTER
MY DRIVER LICENSE CHECK MY AGE.
FOR ME- AS THE CORNER ONE.
ACRES ONCE THE IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION OF HELPING THOSE OF.
ARE SUPPORT. NITROUS OXIDE MAX.
IN THE DARK OOPS MANY LIVES
HELLO MORE COMP. APPROACH AND
IMPLEMENTED. NOTHING ABOUT THE
DISREGARD SMALL SHOP. THE MAJOR
NOT JUST CO. THANK YOU FOR
SHARING YOUR THE PERSONAL STORY
AND WHY YOU ARE HERE WITH US
TODAY THANK YOU SO MUCH WE'RE
VERY GRATEFUL. PLEASE IN GERMAN
WE'RE NOW GOING TO PROCEED ON
THOSE WHO MAY BE IN SUPPORT OF
SB FOUR NINETY ONE PROTECTED
WITH A CHECK ROOM TWENTY FOUR
C. IF THERE'S ANYONE. IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY NOTHING NOTHING'S
HAPPENING ROOM TWENTY FORTY
WE'RE NOW GOING TO BE GOING TO
OUR PHONE LINES WE'RE GONNA
INVITE YOU TO. PARTICIPATE IN
TODAY'S HEARING BY CALLING
EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE
SIX THREE SIX FOUR WORK WITH
THE MODERATOR IN FOLLOW THE
PROMPTS- AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
HEARING FROM YOU ON ANY BILLS
THAT THIS COMMITTEE IS HEARING
TODAY. SEMANA MODERATOR THAT'S
CHECKING TO SEE IF WE HAVE
ANYONE IN SUPPORT OF SB FOUR
NINETY ONE IF WE DO CAN YOU
PLEASE KIM QUEUE THEM UP NOW.
THANK YOU IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT
pMAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
AND WE WILL GO TO LINE OF
SEVENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO THIS IS JULIE TESTA
PRESIDENT OF. IN SUPPORT. FOUR
NINETY ONE. THANK YOU SO MUCH
PROCESS THAT WE APPRECIATE YOUR
TESTIMONY. LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE ABOUT A MOTOR.
THANK YOU OF A LINE OF TWENTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS BRANDON UP ON
BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT IN
PROUD SUPPORT AND SPONSORSHIP
THANK YOU. APPRECIATE THAT
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR CALLING
IN TODAY. NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU AND THERE IS A MINOR
IT IS ONE AND THEN ZERO IF YOU
ARE IN SUPPORT OF S. B. FOUR
NINETY ONE. SUPPORT IT'S ONE
AND THEN ZERO. MISTER CHAIR WE
HAVE NO FURTHER SUPPORTING
QUEUE AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
VERY MCH MADAM MODERATOR WE'RE
GRATEFUL FOR THAT WE'RE NOW
GOING TO GO TO THOSE WHO MAY BE
OPPOSE FOR LOOKING FOR
OPPOSITION FOR ITS BEFORE
NINETY ONE STARTING HERE ROOM
FORTY TWO- THREE WE DO NOT
HAVE. ANY LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESSES LET'S CHECK IN IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. NOTHING
GOING ON AROUND TWENTY FORTY NO
WITNESSES THERE IN OPPOSITION.
WE'RE NOT GOING TO GO TO OUR
PHONE LINES LET'S GO TO OUR
TELECONFERENCE LINE TO CHECK IN
WITH MANTA MODERATOR. BETTER
MODERATOR IF WE HAVE ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION OF FOUR NINETY ONE.
CAN YOU PLEASE PUT THEM IN THE
QUEUE NOW MADAM MODERATOR.
THANK YOU IF YOU'RE AN
OPPOSITION OF S. B. FOUR NINETY
ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN.
ZERO ONE AND THEN ZERO FOR ANY
OPPOSITION. MISTER CHAIR WE
HAVE NO OPPOSITION THANK YOU
APPRECIATE THAT MINOR
MODERATOR- WE'RE NOW GOING TO
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE
DAVID TO SEE IF WE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR MOTION.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR
WIENER MOTIONS ON THE FLOOR BY
CENTER WIENER. VICE CHAIR
NIELSEN WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSELY. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND FELLOW MEMBERS.
ASIDE CLOSE OUR- CONVERSION
BARBARA AND MOHAMMED. IN A CAR
OR A BEDROOM FULL OF THESE
CANISTERS. THERE ARE SO.
DEVASTATING ONE OF MY STAFF
WENT INTO ONE OF A TOBACCO
STORE. TO PICK UP ONE OF THE
SILICON TO LEAVE WHAT THEY LOOK
LIKE I DIDN'T. EVEN KNOW I'VE
EVER SEEN ONE. SHE WILL THAT
FOR ONE. AND WHOEVER WAS
CHECKING OUT HE SAID WELL YOU
ONLY WANT ONE FIVE BOXES YOU
COULD BUY A BOX. NO I DON'T
WANT TO SAY THAT THAT LANGUAGE
PROMOTING BUT HE CERTAINLY WAS
ACKNOWLEDGING THE NORM THAT
PEOPLE DON'T JUST GET ONE OR
TWO THEY BY A LOT. AND THE
CONSUME A LOT AND THE
CUMULATIVE EFFECT IS
DISASTROUS. I WOULD ASK AN AYE
VOTE. TWENTY THANK YOU SO MUCH
RESERVATIONS HERE DO YOU WANT
TO SAY THANK YOU AGAIN MR VICE
CHAIR FOR YOUR WORK ON THIS
THIS IS NOT YOUR FIRST BILL ON
THE SUBJECT AND JUST WANT TO
SAY HOW GRATEFUL WE ARE TO WORK
WITH YOU ON IT IN FOR SHOWING
LEADERSHIP SIR THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT NOW WITH THE MOTION ON
THE FLOOR RIGHT CENTER WIENER
THIS IS A MOTION TO BE APPROVED
IF YOU FOR NINETY ONE WHAT
WE'RE GONNA DO IS WE'RE GOING
TO TURN IT OVER TO MISTER NOW
MISTER NOW WILL BE GIVEN A SIR
FOR MOTION AND THEN ALSO
CALLING THE ROLE MR CONNEL THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
BUT FIRST AMEND AND RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC SAFETY
SENATOR MCGUIRE HI WIRE BY
SENATOR NIELSEN. NIELSEN HI
SENATOR DORADO DORADO. HI
SENATOR HERTZBERG. SENATOR
WIENER. WIENER HI THE FORRESTER
OF THE BIPARTISAN FOUR ZERO
VOTE- THANK YOU SO MUCH
INTEREST YEAR VERY GRATEFUL FOR
THAT- IN BEFORE WE GO TO OUR
FINAL THREE BILLS WE'D LIKE TO
GET A TAKE UP QUICKLY DO SO
THAT FOLKS CAN SCOOT OUT-
TOWARDS. IN WITH IT COULD TAKE
UP OUR CONSENT CALENDAR LAYS IN
GERMAN. ARE CONSENT CALENDAR
GIVE ME A MOMENT PLEASE.
GERMAN
COMMITTEE WE HAVE THREE ITEMS
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR SB
THREE FOUR SEVEN ITEM NUMBER
THREE. SB FOUR FOUR FOR ITEM
NUMBER SIX IN. FOR THREE ONE
ITEM NUMBER TWELVE THIS IS OUR
CONSENT CALENDAR. ESERVER
MEMBER WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR ALSO ON OUR CONSENT
CALENDAR. MR NOW CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. BUSH IS TO PASS
RECOMMEND CONCERNED SENATOR
MCGUIRE BY WIRE HI A SENATOR
NIELSEN ALL RIGHT NIELSEN HI
SENATOR DORADO. DORADO BY
SENATOR HERTZBERG. SENATOR
WINNER. WIENER HI FOUR ZERO
HERTZBERG IS GONNA NEED TO ADD
ON TURKEY SANTANDER- WE'LL GET
TO HIM AS SOON AS HE GETS INTO
COMMITTEE HERE TODAY FOR LAYS
IN GERMAN ARE I'M GOING TO BE
PRESENTING THREE BILLS. ITEM
EIGHTY NINE IN TEN EIGHT AM
EIGHT. EIGHT NINE AND TEN I'M
GOING TO PASS THE GAVEL OVER TO
THE VICE CHAIR WHO PROCEED WITH
THE HEARING IN ARE WE
PRESENTING FROM MY DESK. BY
INTERESTING. MISTER CHAIR YOU
WANT TO DO IT FROM UP THERE.
GERMAN YOUR FIRST BILL WOULD BE
S. B. E. TWELFTH. THANK YOU SO
MUCH RESERVOIRS SUGAR AND
MISTER RIGHT HERE I WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO WORK WITH YOU EACH AND EVERY
YEAR AND GRATEFUL THAT YOU'RE
IN THE ROLE THAT YOU ARE THIS
YEAR WITH GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE COMMITTEE- BURKE.
MISTER CHAIRMAN RESERVE NEED TO
TELL YOU THAT WE'RE LIVING IN A
PRESIDENT TIMES WITH WILDFIRES
HERE IN CALIFORNIA. THE SIZE
AND SCOPE OF WILDFIRES IN THE
STATE THEY'VE CHANGED. FOR
LARGER MORE DESTRUCTIVE AND
DEADLIER THAN. THEY'VE EVER
BEEN IN MODERN HISTORY. THE
TWENTY TWENTY WILDFIRE SEASON
BURN MORE THAN TWO FOUR POINT
TWO MILLION ACRES MAKING IT BY
FAR. THE LARGEST IN CALIFORNIA
HISTORY. EIGHT OUT OF TEN OF
THE LARGEST WILDFIRES IN
CALIFORNIA HISTORY HAVE ALL
OCCURRED IN THE PAST DECADE.
THIS INCLUDES AUGUST COMPLEX
FIRE. THAT BURNED ONE MILLION
ACRES IN SEPTEMBER OF TWENTY
TWENTY INTERNING CALIFORNIA.
MAKING IT THE STATE'S FIRST
SIGNIFIERS THE TERM FOR A FIRE
THAT IS BURNED. AT LEAST A
MILLION ACRES OF LAND. AND WE
ALL REMEMBER THE CAMPFIRE
NOVEMBER TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN.
THAT FIRE TRAGICALLY CAUSED THE
DEATHS OF EIGHTY SIX PEOPLE.
DESTROYED IT NEARLY NINETEEN
THOUSAND STRUCTURES. OR WHAT
ABOUT THE NORTH BAY FIRE HOUSE
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN WHERE
WE LOST. DOZENS OF LIVES. IN
EACH OF THE- DEVASTATING FIRES.
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS RAN FOR THEIR
LIVES. AND SOMETIMES IN THE
DARK AT NIGHT WITH JUST THE
CLOTHES ON THEIR BACK. THEY RAN
FOR THEIR LIVES SCRAMBLING TO
FIND ANY WAY TO ESCAPE THE
ROARING FLAMES. THE WAY WE
THREE TO STRATEGICALLY GROW OUR
COMMUNITY SAYS NOW COME INTO
QUESTION IS THE REALITY OF MY
MEGA FIRES HAVE SAID IN HERE IN
THE GOLDEN STATE. WE KNOW THAT
THE SAME DEVELOPMENT PRACTICES
THAT CONTINUE TO TAKE PLACE IN
HIGH RISK FIRE AREAS MUST
CHANGE. AND IF THEY DON'T JUST
BEING CANDID ABOUT IT. MORE
DEATH AND DESTRUCTION WILL
FOLLOW. THE CALIFORNIA ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE IS ALREADY
INTERVENE WITH LAWSUITS ON
THREE DEVELOPMENT PROJECTS IN
THE WILD IN URBAN INTERFACE
BECAUSE OF THEIR WILDFIRE
IMPACTS. THE NEW NORMAL
CALIFORNIANS HERE AND THAT'S
WHY WE NEED SB TWELVE. FIFTY
TWELVE CENTS A MINIMUM FLOOR
FOR DEVELOPMENTS IN THE
WILDLAND URBAN INTERFACE.
CURRENT STATE STANDARDS ARE
LIMITED TO THE BUILDING CODE
REQUIREMENTS FOR LIKE ROADS AND
SIGNS IN FUEL BREAKS. NOW WHAT
THIS BILL WOULD DO IS TO SET UP
A TRANSFORMATIONAL PROCESS FOR
THE STATE FIRE MARSHAL TO
ESTABLISH A BOLD. NEW STANDARDS
THAT ENSURE DEVELOPMENTS AS A
WHOLE ARE DESIGNED TO WITHSTAND
FIRE NOT JUST THE BUILDINGS
WITH IN THOSE DEVELOPMENTS.
SOME OF THESE NEW STANDARDS
WOULD INCLUDE A WILDLAND FIRE
HAZARD ASSESSMENT IN WILDFIRE
HAZARD MITIGATION PLAN THAT
STANDARDS FOR THE ORGANIZATION
AND DEPLOYMENT OF. FIRE
SUPPRESSION OPERATIONS AT THE
DEVELOPMENT LOCATION AND
CONSTRUCTION OF INFRASTRUCTURE
TO REDUCE IGNITION POTENTIAL
AND ENSURE AVAILABILITY WATER
SUPPLIES ESSENTIAL FOR FIRE
SUPPRESSION DURING A WILDFIRE.
HE COULDN'T YOU CAN NO LONGER
HAVE. ONE WAY ENDING ONE YEAH
YOU'D HAVE TO. MULTIPLE IN AND
DEFENSIBLE SPACE WOULD BE
REQUIRED. MANAGEMENT AND FUEL
MODIFICATION REQUIREMENTS AND
THEN THERE WOULD BE AN
ENFORCEMENT PROGRAM ESTABLISHED
AND IT WOULD ALL BE FUNDED IN
AND OUT AND IMPLEMENTED TO
VERIFY ON GOING COMPLIANCE.
BACK BY FINANCING MECHANISMS
LIKE ASSESSMENTS ON H. AWAY
FUNDS THAT ARE A CONDITION ON
THE DEVELOPMENT. WE WOULD LOOK
TO SITE SPECIFIC SAFETY
MEASURES TO ENSURE THAT THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE WHOLE IS
PLANNING CONSTRUCTED TO REDUCE
THEIR ENCROACHMENT OF
UNCONTROLLED FIRE IN. A
DEVELOPMENT LAY OUT THAT
REDUCES WILDFIRE RISK TO THE
GREATEST EXTENT PART PRACTICAL.
BUT BLUNTLY PUT THIS
LEGISLATION SAYS THAT IF
DEVELOPMENTS CAN'T MEET THE
STANDARDS. THE LOCALS CANNOT
APPROVE THEM. NOW THE STANDARD
ARE KEY SAID THE STANDARDS GET
INCREASE IN STRONG. AS
DEVELOPMENTS GET LARGER THE
REASON IS THIS. LARGER
DEVELOPMENTS PUT MORE PEOPLE IN
THE MOVIE WHILE THE URBAN
INTERFACE. ASSEMBLY MUST MEET
HIGHER STANDARDS IN SMALLER
DEVELOPMENTS. THIS MEANS THAT
THE REQUIREMENTS ARE STRINGENT.
BUT ARE NOT TOO COSTLY AS THE
TOTALLY PREVENT DEVELOPMENT.
EITHER COMMONSENSE AND BY THE
WAY WE SHOULD PROBABLY BEEN
DONG THIS DECADES AGO LET'S
JUST BE BLUNT. AND WE KNOW THAT
HALF OF THE BUILDINGS LOST HALF
OF THE BUILDINGS LOST IN THE
LAST DECADE WERE BUILT IN THE
WILL WE- BILL UNDER CURRENT
CODE. THAT SUPPOSED TO
WITHSTAND. THESE FIRES THIS
WILL ALSO ENHANCES THE PLANNING
BUT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS MUST DO
INCLUDING TO COME UP WITH A%
STRATEGY TO RETROFIT EXISTING
BUILDINGS. YEAH YOU MAY HEAR
FROM OPPONENTS TODAY BUT THIS
BILL WOULD MAYBE LOOK LABELED
AS A HOUSING KILLER. WILL HEAR
THE FACTS OF THIS THIS BILL IS
ALMOST IDENTICAL ALMOST
IDENTICAL TO A BILL THAT WAS
APPROVED BY BIPARTISAN
MAJORITIES IN BOTH HOUSES AND
SENT TO THE GOVERNOR'S DESK
LAST YEAR. WE MADE AMENDMENTS
TO ADDRESS THE GOVERNOR'S
CONCERNS. EVERYONE OF THE
PROPONENTS ON THIS BILL THIS
YEAR. EVERY ONE OF THEM WERE
NEUTRAL ON THE LEGISLATION LAST
YEAR. AND THEIR CONCERNS THIS
YEAR OUR WITH PROVISIONS OF
THIS BILL BETTER THE SAME
PROVISIONS CONTAINED IN THE
BILL LAST YEAR. I WANT TO
REPEAT THAT. THE CONCERNS WITH
THE BILL THIS YEAR ARE THE SAME
ONES THAT WERE IN LAST YEAR'S
BILL WITH SENATOR JACKSON.
PLEASE GO BACK INTO THIRTY.
OPPONENTS WILL SAY THAT THE
OFFICE OF PLANNING RESEARCH OPR
HAS CHANGED ITS GUIDANCE SO
THAT LARGE DEVELOPMENTS UNDER
SB TWELVE WILL NOW HAVE TO
PROVE THAT IT'S IN FEASIBLE TO
BE LOCATED OUTSIDE THE WILL BE.
BUT LET'S TALK ABOUT WHAT THE
BILL ACTUALLY SAYS SB TWELVE
SAYS THAT THE WILDFIRE RISK
REDUCTION STANDARDS MUST AND I
QUOTE BE REASONABLE. FEASIBLE
AND ACHIEVABLE FOR THE MAJORITY
OF THE DEVELOPMENTS IN EACH
CATEGORY. THIS ISN'T SOME
QUESTION OF INTERPRETATION IT'S
IN BLACK AND WHITE IN THE BILL
THE STANDARDS HAVE TO BE
FEASIBLE. IN THE STATE FARM ARE
FOR MUST GO THROUGH THE FULL
FORMAL RULEMAKING PROCESS TO
DEVELOP STANDARDS. IN HERE'S
WHY WHAT THE OPPOSITION WANTS
ISN'T WORKABLE THE VERY PREMISE
OF S. B. TWELVE IS THAT LARGER
DEVELOPMENTS THAT PUT MORE
PEOPLE IN THE WILL YOU. MUST
MEET HIGHER STANDARDS IN
SMALLER DEVELOPMENTS.
OPPOSITION AMENDMENT TO REMOVE
THAT HIGHER THRESHOLD NONE THE
LESS AND YOU HAVE MY WORD.
WE'RE WILLING TO NEGOTIATE IN
GOOD FAITH ON THIS BILL. TO
ADDRESS THE OPPOSITION CONCERNS
ARE MORE THAN WILLING TO HAVE
THE FIRE MARSHAL CONSIDER THE
RECOMMENDATIONS IN OPR DEVICE
THREE. AS LONG AS IS BALANCED
BY OTHER STANDARDS TO ENSURE
THAT LARGE DEVELOPMENTS AREN'T
GETTING A PASSED IN CONTINUE TO
PUT. FOLKS IN HARM'S WAY THIS
IS THE THIRD YEAR OF THIS BILL
THAT THE LEGISLATURE- AND S. B.
TWELVE. AS THIS IS THE THIRD
YEAR THAT THIS BILL IN FRONT OF
THE LEGISLATURE IN SB TWELVE IS
THE ONLY BILL THAT BALANCES THE
NEED FOR YOU HOUSING. EVEN IN
THE WILL YOU WITH FIRE SAFETY.
LET'S JUST BE CANDID NOT SINGLE
SAY WE CAN'T AFFORD. ANOTHER
YEAR WE JUST CAN'T. THESE ARE
REASONABLE THEY'RE PRACTICAL
AND IT WILL LITERALLY SAVE
LIVES THAT IS SUPPORTED BY THE
AMERICAN PLANNING ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA FIRE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION. MISTER VICE CHAIR
I'M GRATEFUL THAT WE HAVE
LAUREN ON THE LINE FOR AMERICAN
PLANNING ASSOCIATION FOR THE
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER THREE TO
PROVIDE OUR LEAD. WITNESS
TESTIMONY TODAY. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN. RICHARD THIS
IMPORTANT. NOW DO WE HAVE TO
THE- CAN YOU ASK THE FOR PEOPLE
IN SUPPORT WHO WISH TO
COMMUNICATE- THE END SUPPORT
COMMITTEE WILL AT FIRST OF ALL
CHECK HERE I DON'T SEE ANYONE
IN THIS ROOM AND A TWENTY FORTY
ANY BODY THERE WANTING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. TWENTY
FORTY SEEING NINE I BELIEVE
THERE WAS CERTAINLY WILL BE
SOME CALLING IN A MODERATOR CAN
YOU ASK THE FOLKS TO QUEUE UP
TO BE SUPPORTIVE OF THIS BILL
S. B. TWELVE- YES. IF YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT OF- S. B. TWELVE YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
MISTER CHAIR MISTER BY HERE IS
THAT OKAY THAT THE WARREN COURT
EIGHTY EIGHT OKAY TO TESTIFY.
WE HAVE TO LEAD SUPPORT AND I
FORGOT TO LET US GET TO LEAD
SUPPORT LAUREN AND
DIFFERENTIATE YOU SAVAGES.
LAUREN DIFFERENTIATE SATCHER'S.
YES DURING SENSORS ARE PLEASE.
BRAIN WELL AFTERNOON MR PROVIDE
YOUR AND MEMBERS HELLO A YEAH
TODAY ARE THE AMERICAN PLANNING
ASSOCIATION AND WE'RE VERY
PLEASED TO BE HERE IN PART
ABOUT THE TWELVE WHICH WOULD
MAKE A NUMBER OF VERY IMPORTANT
CHANGES REGARDING PLANNING FOR
INCRIMINATING DEVELOPMENT IN
HIGH FIRE RISK AREAS- WE REALLY
APPRECIATE SENATOR MCGUIRE'S
EFFORTS ON THE TRACKING ISSUE-
OF COURSE THE SENATOR MCGUIRE
RT THE ELOQUENTLY HIGHLIGHTED-
UNFORTUNATELY WE CONTINUE TO
FACE RECORD BREAKING
DESTRUCTIVE AND DEADLY FIRES
YEAR AFTER YEAR THAT. ARE NOW
ARE ST NEW NORMAL. WE DO
BELIEVE THAT YOU'RE CAN ANY TO
DO MORE TO BETTER FOR. AND SO
DOES THIS MEAN IT MEANS
RECASTING HOW LAND USE PLANNING
HAS BEEN DONE OVER THE YEARS
AND FIRED HIGH FIRE RISK AREAS.
AND ENSURING THAT LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS ARE SUPPORTED
WITH GUIDANCE. AND FUNDING TO
MAKE THESE CRITICAL CHANGES AND
WE CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND THAT
THIS IS A VERY TOUGH ISSUE TO
TACKLE AND UNDERSTANDING OF ALL
THE CONVERSATION LAST YEAR
WE'RE VERY PLEASED TO SEE. SB
ONE EIGHTY TO PASS- WITH
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT LAST YEAR
AND WE'RE VERY APPRECIATIVE
THAT THE BILL BACK AGAIN TO BE
CONSIDERED. WE KNOW THAT
ANOTHER FIRE SEASON WILL BE
UPON US AND SO CHINA VERY
CRITICAL. EIGHTY EIGHT THE
COURTS THAT ARE REASONABLE AND
FEASIBLE WILDFIRE REDUCTION
STANDARDS AND PLANNING
REQUIREMENTS THE BILL TO ENSURE
THAT EXISTING HOME FOR HARDENED
AND NEW DEVELOPMENTS ARE
THOUGHTFULLY CONSIDERED. AND WE
BELIEVE THAT THE BILL SURELY
SUPPORT CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING
PRIORITIES BYENCOURAGING MORE
SUSTAINABLE HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
PRACTICES APPROPRIATELY
DESIGNING COMMUNITIES AND HIGH
FIRE RISK AREAS. AND WHEN
POSSIBLE DIRECTING DENSITY
COLLECT HAZARDOUS AREAS WITHIN
A JURISDICTION ALL OF THIS
WHILE STILL MAINTAINING THE
STATE'S HOUSING PRODUCTION
TARGETS FOR EACH REGION TO
ENSURE THAT THE NEED TO DEVELOP
STAY CLEAN- DOES NOT KEEP
HOUSING FROM BEING DEVELOPED IN
COMMUNITIES ALL THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. FINALLY APA
BELIEVES THAT THE PLANNING
REQUIREMENTS COUPLED WITH
EFFECTIVE LOCAL ENFORCEMENT
STANDARDS AND ADEQUATE FUNDING
ARE ALL IMPORTANT PIECES OF
THE- PUZZLE THAT THE BILLS SEEK
TO PUT TOGETHER. PLANNING MUST
BE DONE NOW TO PROTECT HOMES
AND LIVES BY PROVIDING FOR MORE
RESILIENT COMMUNITIES AND AGAIN
WE REALLY APPRECIATE SENATOR
MCGUIRE'S AFRICANIST ISSUE AND
A VIRGIN. I ABOUT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. DO WE HAVE ANY MORE
IN Q. MODERATE INTERNSHIP. WE
HAVE NOT ON THE PHONE LINE.
AMERICAN AT JUST A REMINDER FOR
SB TWELVE IF YOU WANNA- CUBA
PERSIPURA DID. ONE NINE ZERO.
AND WE HAVE NO SUPPORT IN THE
QUEUE. NUMBER. THESE ARE MORE
SUPPORT. I'VE THOSE ARE
OPPOSITION. FIVE YEP THAT'S ALL
WE HAD GOT. WE DO HAVE SOME
RECORDED OPPOSITION IZZARD BUT
THERE'S NO MORE SUPPORT IN Q.
MODERATOR. OKAY WE WOULD GO
THEN TO THE OPPOSITION AND
THERE IS A SILVIO FERRARI
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION. HELLO GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER SHERMAN CAN
YOU HEAR ME. YEAH PLEASE
PROCEED. OKAY WELL THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ASSEMBLY-
FERRARI HERE TODAY ON BEHALF
THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION- WE'RE
HEARING VERY RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION SB TWELVE TODAY- IS
YOU ALREADY HEARD FROM FROM THE
AUTHOR- CBI HAS LOOKED AT THIS
BILL AGAIN AND HAS IDENTIFIED
IN THIS YEAR AS A HOUSING
KILLER YOU KNOW THE PURPOSE OF
FEEDBACK HOUSING CATALYST IS TO
IDENTIFY LEGISLATION. THAT WILL
FURTHER EXACERBATE THE HOUSING
CRISIS- AGAIN IN THE AUTHOR'S
TESTIMONY YEAH HE EVEN YOU KNOW
FROM A FIFTY PAGE BILL- HE DID
IDENTIFY A LOT OF THE
ADDITIONAL REQUIREMENTS AND
PROVISIONS THAT ARE IN THE BILL
I'M HOPEFUL THAT FROM OUR
OPPOSITION LETTER- YOU ABLE TO.
DISCERN THAT OUR OBJECTIONS TO
S. TWELVE ARE LASER FOCUSED ON
THE OPR PROVISIONS ABOUT THE
AUTHOR ALSO MENTIONED- AND YES-
WILLIAM SHORT PROVISIONS WORK
IN THIS BILL LAST YEAR A LOT
HAS CHANGED IN THE WORLD SO
LAST YEAR AFTER TWO YEARS OF
NEGOTIATIONS ON ONE EIGHTY
FIVE- WE PONDER NOSES AND TOOK
A NEUTRAL POSITION. IN NOVEMBER
OF TWENTY TWENTY- PR RELEASED A
NEW DRAFT TECHNICAL GUIDANCE
THAT IS REFERENCED BY NAME IN
THIS LEGISLATION AND IT IS
ELEVATE IT IS BROUGHT UP TO A
LEVEL WHERE IT IS GOING TO BE
COOPERATED AND LOOK. TO AS
STANDARD. WE ARE OPR
ESSENTIALLY J. JURY
EXECUTIONERS. CLOSE TO EFFORT
ON HOW AND PLANNING AND WE ARE
AS CREATING A NEW ONE SAYS
WHERE THEY CAN WHAT THEY THE
INTO THEIR TECH AND- THAT WILL
BE ROLLED IN. THE STATE FIRE
MARSHAL'S CONSIDER. AND THAT IS
NOT ABLE. NOW THAT WE UNDER
MORE SO THAN WE DID LAST YEAR
THE PREVIOUS YEAR WHERE- PR
PLANS TO GO AND WHERE WE THINK
THEY WILL GO IN FUTURE TACTICAL
ADVICE UPDATES THAT IS NOT
SOMETHING THAT WE CAN ALLOWED
TO DICTATE WHERE FUTURES
HOUSING IS GOING TO GO.
ADDITIONALLY WE ARE A LOT OF
COMMENTARY ABOUT. THE SIZE OF
THE PROJECT. DATA AND THE STOCK
IT'S ALMOST. OF THE WELL PLAY-
PLAN COMMUNITIES. ONE IS TEST
MAKES YOU SANTA FE VALLEY NORSE
DIEGO. PROJECT THAT WILL STOOD
THE WHICH FOR. LEAVES WERE
STILL BY DRIVEN BY HIGHWAY ALL
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTY. ROGER
WHERE YOU SAW THE BLUE BURNED
MORE UP TO THE EX EX THE PRICE.
IT RIGHT INTO THE DEVICE
DEFECTS SPACE AND IT WAS
STOPPED MEMBERS EVERY PART OF
THE- BOUNCE STOCKPILE ONE HELD
BY THE BAR DIDN'T USE TO
PENETRATE STOCKHAM. AND THE DOT
WITHOUT ANY STRUCTURAL DAMAGE
IT IS IN THE LARGEST PROJECT
WERE MEANINGFUL IS BEING BUILT
THANK YOU CAN DO THOSE TYPES OF
THINGS IT'S ACTUALLY THE SMALL
PROJECTS THE ONE OFF THE TEN
AUSTIN FIFTY ALL. YOU REALLY
HAVE THAT CONCERN 85% OF THE
HOUSE IN CALIFORNIA THAT IS
BUILT BY CBI MEMBERS IS NOT
THAT KIND OF HOUSE. IT IS THE
WELL DESIGNED AND WELL PLANNED
BUT THE SAFEST STANDARDS IN THE
COUNTRY. IF NOT THE WORLD.
OPERATED TO TODAY'S GROUP
PROJECTS. AND MEMBERS I WOULD I
WOULD SAY. THERE HAVE BEEN MANY
ATTEMPT BY THIS PLEDGES OVER
THE MASS LAST NAME OF YEARS. I
TRY NOT UNLOCK HOUSE FOR. AN
INFILL URBAN AREAS THE PLACE IS
WEREN'T HOW US YOU. TO FOR TEN
AFTER. ATTEMPT SHARE O. AND DIE
IN THE OF. THE SAME TIME WE NOT
IN. YOUR BILL. TO BUILD IN
INSULARITY. WE ARE NOT BRINGING
THE COST TO BUILD AND SELLING.
WE HAVE NOT BE TAKEN STEPS HOLD
ON WHAT REALLY THE ONLY
AFFORDABLE PLACES FOR THE
AVERAGE CALIFORNIANS WHICH IS.
MIXED USE COMMUNITIES. TO
MEMBERS I WOULD YESTERDAY- WE
HAVE BEEN AT THE TABLE THE
REGULATIONS LEGISLATIVE EFFORTS-
FROM THE START WE AGREE THAT
THERE ARE ABSOLUTELY THINGS
THAT CAN AND SHOULD. BE DONE TO
KEEP COMMUNITIES. ESPECIALLY
THOSE THAT GOING TO BE. IN
GROUP THEIR- ABSOLUE BECAUSE
POSSIBLE. MEAT SCIENCE THE DATA
SHOWS AND SUPPORTS THAT CAN BE
DONE THEY CAN BE DONE SAFELY.
AREAS WHERE WE NEED TO MORE OUR
INSULAR AREAS LIKE THE CAMPFIRE
AND OTHERS THAT ARE OLDER THAN
ARE OUTDATED THAT ARE IN DIRE
NEED OF RETROFIT. SO FOR THESE
REASONS WE VERY MUCH LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING ON THIS I
WILL BE OFF IN THE OTHER
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE AND
OTHER COMMITTEES- BUT AT THIS
POINT WE ARE CLOSED AND THIS IS
A HOUSING KILLER THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER FERRARI AND
THEN I WANTED TO BE A LITTLE
BIT GENEROUS WITH YOU THERE ARE.
PLEASE DO UNDERSTAND THE IMPACT
TO YOU AND YOU WANTED TO RECITE
SOME HISTORY. ABOUT WE RESIDE
REMIND WE TRY TO KEEP OURSELVES
TO THREE MINUTES IN THE OF
PROPONENT ANY OTHER OF.
OPPOSITION IN Q. MODERATOR.
THANK YOU IF YOU'RE IN
OPPOSITION OF S. B. TWELVE YOU
MAY PRESS. ONE NINE ZERO. WE'LL
GO TO THE FIRST LINE OF LINE
FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS I YELEY
GALLAGHER THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS ECHOING
THE CONCERNS OF G. B. I. A. BUT
ALSO IN ADDITION TO THAT- WE'VE
ASKED FOR SOME AMENDMENT
LANGUAGE THAT WOULD HELP ENSURE
THAT COMPLIANCE WITH THE
COMPREHENSIVE RECTO SAID- HOME
HARDENING PROGRAM WOULD NOT
BURDEN HOME SALE TRANSACTIONS.
AND WE'VE ALREADY PREPARED A
HOME HARDENING DISCLOSURE
STATEMENT AND THE DEFENSIBLE
SPACE COMPLIANCE DISCLOSURE FOR
TRANSACTION SO WE ARE CURRENTLY
PREPARED TO DISCLOSE WHETHER OR
NOT A HOME IS IN COMPLIANCE
WITH CURRENT- DEPARTMENT OF
FORESTRY AND FIRE PROTECTION
STANDARDS FOR HOME PARKING
UNTIL YOU JUST HAVE TO GET A
LOT MORE INSURANCE THAT. DOES
NOT COMPLAINTS ABOUT BECOME. A
TIME OF SALE DEMAND THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THE MODERATOR WILL
CHECKING FOR ANY OTHER.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. YES
THAT NEXON WILL GOAL LINE OF
NINETY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE AUTOMATICALLY
WITH THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE ONE EYELINER. WEIGHT
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION WE DO STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS CURRENTLY
DRAFTED LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE AUTHOR TO ADDRESS-
STRICTLY LINKED ISSUES SEVERE
HOUSING SHORTAGE AND
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES WE THINK
WE CAN HAVE COMPLIMENTARY
QUALITIES BUT CURRENTLY S. B.
TWELVE TO BROAD WITH THE ONES
THAT THE BALLPARK. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. WOULD YOU CHECK
AGAIN BUT- YES NEXT OF A LINE
OF NINETY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
I DIDN'T COMPLIMENTS CALIFORNIA
BUILDERS ALLIANCE- WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED- WE- ECHO THE COMMENTS
MADE- BEFORE- IN A LINER FILLED
WITH A CALIFORNIA BUILDERS-
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION AND LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR. STAFF AS WE- DEVELOPER.
POLICY TO ADDRESS THESE ISSUES
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ANYMORE
UNTIL MODERATE MODEL I. WELL
GOAL LINE OF NINETY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MISTER CHAIRMAN
OF THE COMMITTEE DAVE BUTLER ON
BEHALF OF THE UNITED CHAMBER
ADVOCACY NETWORK A COALITION OF
SEVEN LOCAL CHAMBERS ACROSS
FOUR COUNTIES IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA ALSO- OPPOSED-
RESPECTFULLY. CONSISTENT WITH
THE COMMENTS OF THE CPA THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ANYMORE IN Q. THREE AS A
REMINDER IT IS ONE AND THEN
ZERO FOR ANY OPPOSITION OF S.
B. TWELVE. AND THERE ARE NO
FURTHER OPPOSITION THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. WELCOME BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE AND IT LOOKS LIKE THE
CENTER WINNER HAS A QUESTION OR
COMMENT. THIS THANK YOU-
MISTER- BASED HERE ON ALL THE
SUPPORTING MOVING TO CELTIC
COMMITTEE BUT OF COMMITTEE
TODAY- UNDERSTANDING THAT THIS
WILL BE COMING TO THE HOUSING
COMMITTEE. MAX AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH CENTER
MCGUIRE. ON A- I FIVE SIX OF
THE A COUPLE THINGS FIRST OF
ALL- THE CHAIR AND I HAVE
WORKED FOR YEARS TOGETHER. TO
TRY TO ACCOMPLISH TWO THINGS IN
CALIFORNIA AROUND HOUSING. ONE
TO INCREASE PRODUCTION OF
HOUSING AND WE'VE BEEN TALKING
STRONG PARTNERS IN THAT UPPER.
AND TO TRY TO MOVE A REDUCE
PRESSURE. AND OUR HIGHEST RISK
WILD FIRE AREAS AND FOCUS MORE
HOUSING AND SUSTAINABLE AREAS
SPECIFICALLY AND FILL. BY
HOUSING AND THAT IT'S BEEN IT'S
BEEN A LONG AND HARD. JOURNEY I
WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR FOR THE
COLLABORATION I KNOW THE
CORPORATION IS GOING TO
CONTINUE. THIS BILL IN ITS
PREVIOUS FORM ALSO WAS A LONG.
JOURNEY MAY RECALL- WE PASS IT
OUT OF BOTH THE HOUSING
COMMITTEE AND- GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE- UNFORTUNATELY I HAVE
TO CALL IT BACK INTO COMMITTEE
ON CONCURRENCE BECAUSE- THERE
WERE SOME AMENDMENTS THAT WERE
SUPPOSED TO HAVE BEEN TAKEN
THAT WERE AND IT WAS A WHOLE.
MESSY SITUATION THAT'S WHY I
BECAME A TO YOUR BILL- WE
ALTERNATELY THAT THE CHAIR AND
I WORKED INTENSIVELY WITH. OUR
FORMER COLLEAGUE AND WERE ABLE
TO. GET SOMETHING TOGETHER YEAH
WE GOT TO THE GOVERNOR AND THE
GOVERNOR VETOED- THE BILL- AND
SO I'M GLAD THAT THE BILL IS
BACK I THINK OVERWHELMINGLY-
IT'S A GOOD BILL- THAT I'M
SUPPORTIVE OF. TOM I DO WANT TO
AND I DON'T WANT TO SORT OF BE
PICTURE. BECAUSE THERE'S A
OTHER BILL. BERMAN FIFTY
EMPLOYEE US. AT I THINK EVERY
HOUSING BILL I'VE ALL. HAS HAD
AN- AND EFFORT HIGH RISK WILD
FIRE AREAS. TAMAYO AND BILLS
IT'S GOING TO ON THE- AND
LESSEN THE ONE FIRE. AREAS
BECAUSE WE TO VIEW THIS CON.
AND SO THERE IS A NO PROTECT
BILL THAT FOCUSES ONLY ON
ENDING NEW HOUSING IN HIGH RISK
WILD FIRE AREAS WITHOUT DOING
ANYTHING. TO PROMOTE. HOUSING
AND NON WILD FIRE AREAS AND WE
AND WE NEED TO BE VERY CLEAR.
IT IS NOT RANDOM THAT WE HAVE
SO MUCH HOUSING BEING BUILT. IN
OUR HIGH RISK WILD FIRE AREAS.
IT'S BECAUSE WE MAKE IT
DIFFICULT TO IMPOSSIBLE TO
BUILD MUCH HOUSING. IN OTHER
AREAS LIKE IN THE BULK OF THE
BAY AREA OR PARTS OF L. LIKE WE
HAVE THROUGH ZONING AND
OTHERWISE WE MADE IT SO
DIFFICULT. TO BUILD INFILL
HOUSING ROOM POWERED NIMBYS TO
SHUT DOWN THE LAY EMPTY HOUSING
AND SO IT SPRAWLS OUT. ABOUT
TWICE SO MUCH GETS BUILT. IN
THE WE SO WE HAVE TO DO. WE
HAVE TO DO BOTH. TIMES I DO
WANT TO SPECIFICALLY THE V. THE
OPR PRINT WAS THE PREVIOUS
VERSION THAT I SUPPORTED THAT
WE ALL SUPPORTED IRAQ MOST OF
US SUPPORTED. I BELIEVE BUT I
THINK IT IS IMPORTANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT WERE SORT OF
GIVING A PROXY OPR BY
REFERENCING AND THEY'RE AN OPR.
HAS ISSUED NEW GUIDANCE SINCE
THE VETO OF SB ONE EIGHTY TWO.
THAT IS AYE UNDERSTAND THAT-
GOES BEYOND- VERY HIGH WILDFIRE
RISK AREAS THAT INCLUDE HIGH
RISK WHICH IS A HUGE SWATH OF
CALIFORNIA- AND SO THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT I THINK WE NEED
TO TAKE A LOOK AT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE NOT. ON SWEEPING IN
SUCH A HUGE AREA WERE THE SKIRT
DISCOURAGING DEVELOPMENT AND
GIVING TOOLS TO PEOPLE WHO
DON'T WANT TO SEE ANY HOUSING
ANYWHERE SO I'M CONFIDENT WE'RE
GOING TO RESOLVE THIS- AND I
KNOW THAT MY COMMITTEE- WILL
AND WE'RE WORKING COSELY WITH-
WITH WITH THE AUTHOR OF A
CHAIR. ON THIS AND I'M
CONFIDENT WE'LL GET IT DONE AND
THEN MOVE OUT STRONG BILL
WITHOUT SAID I'M HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THIS TODAY. THANK YOU
SENATOR WINNER AT THE SENATOR
ALSO DID YOU HAVE SOMETHING TO
POLLUTION YES- THANK YOU MR
VICE CHAIR I ALSO- PLAN TO
SUPPORT AND- THE REASON I FEEL
COMPELLED TO JUST SAY SOMETHING
IS IT BECOMES PRETTY OBVIOUS I
MEAN NOT. NOT MANY OF US ARE
HAVE THE SAME HISTORY OF
UNDERSTANDING THE DETAILS OF.
OF ON OF HOUSING BILLS BUT IT
JUST HITS CALIFORNIANS ACROSS
THE STATE WHY ARE WE BUILDING
IN THESE HIGH RISK FIRE AREAS
WE SEE THE LIVES THAT ARE LOST
OR HURT WE SEE- DAMAGE TO
PROPERTY WE SEE HOW IT IMPACTS
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND I JUST- I
JUST THINK I HAVE I JUST WANT
TO SAY THAT THAT I APPRECIATE
ALL THE WORK THAT YOU ALL ARE
DOING. ON THE AUTHORS DOING- TO
MAKE SOME SENSE OF THIS- AND-
THAT'S IT. THANK HELLO LET ME
TYPE IN YOUR BROUGH- HAVING
REPRESENTED DIFFERENT COUNTIES
OVER THE DECADES SHOWN MUCH
DETACHED THAT- AND I'VE HAD
SOME URBAN AS WELL AS MOST NEW
GIRL TO. I CAN'T TELL YOU HOW
MANY FIRES THE- THE AREAS THAT
I REPRESENT OF HAD TO SUFFER.
AND WE ARE WELCOMING. WE IN THE
MORE RURAL AREAS. THE
ACKNOWLEDGEMENT OF THE HALF
DOLLAR ABILITY THAT WE HAVE AND
THE SUPPORT THAT'S BEEN
FORTHCOMING FROM SUBURBAN AND
MORE URBAN AREAS FOR CLEANING
UP THE FORCED IN THE WILDLANDS
FROM THESE CATACLYSMIC FIRES DO
NOT GET IGNITED AND KEEP
BURNING- OKAY. YOU SEE THESE.
THREE SEVEN AND I THINK
PARTICULARLY IF PARADISE HOLDEN
CITY HOTEL CALLED AROUND AND
GONE HI MATT EIGHTY SIX PEOPLE.
NOW THAT'S PRETTY DRAMATIC AND
BEING RIGHT IN THE MIDDLE OF
THAT DURING THE BURNING. AND
WATCHING THE CARS JAMMED UP
WITH THE WATER OF THE
PROVISIONS AT THE THIS BILL
DOES CONTAIN IS A SECOND EGRESS
INGRESS AND EGRESS ROUTES. THAT
WAS ONE OF THE IMPAIRMENTS WE
COULDN'T GET ANYTHING DONE
ABOUT IT FOR DECADES BUT NOW
THINGS ARE MOVING IN A BETTER
STEP. THE OPPOSITION HAS
DIMINISHED TO. MANAGING OUR
FORCE THE NORMAL WILDLANDS.
THAT'S MOST HELPFUL. IN ALL
REMIND FOLKS THAT THERE'S AN
IMPACT ON WILDLIFE YES I TOOK A-
BUS TOUR OF POKES ABOUT A YEAR
AND A HALF AGO UP TO PARADISE.
LOOKING UP ON A LARGE BORE.
DISTASTE. HE WAS BARBECUED BUT
NOT ON A SPIT. BUT THAT TO RIP
TO RIFIC FIRE. THEN YOU CAN
JUST ENVISIONED THEN THE
THOUSANDS. BUT WILDLIFE. THERE
ARE GONE- HABITAT DESTROYED AND
THEN IN THE AFTERMATH ZEROCHAN.
THE POLLTES THE WATERS AND
COMPLICATED FURTHER. I KNOW THE
HATCHER VERY VERY WELL
PERSONALLY AND HE'S THE MOST
TRUSTWORTHY PERSON OF KNOWN.
AND AS A LEGISLATORS ONE WHO
WORKS WITH HE'S VERY EASY TO
WORK WITH SOME OF THE OPPONENTS
FROM OF WHICH YOU'RE CONCERNED
I PROBABLY SHARE. BUT I'LL TELL
YOU THAT THE CHURCH IS EASY HAD
AN AMENABLE TO MAKING
AMENDMENTS IN MAKING CHANGES AS
HE HAD DEMONSTRATED. SO I WOULD
LIKE TO SEE THE BILL MOVE
ALONG. AND THAT KIND OF
NEGOTIATION CONTINUE. AND I
INTEND TO BE A FORCE WORKING
WITH ARCHER GIORGETTI. PICTURE
MODE YOU LIKE TO GIVE US OPPOSE
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR SURVEYS
CHERRY AND- THE- THE VICE CHAIR
AND I. UNFORTUNATELY HAVE GONE
BACK ON AND- THE REALLY
DIFFICULT. FIRES IN BEEN ABLE
TO WORK TOGETHER AND I ST
FORTUNATELY- WE- HAVE BEEN ABLE
TO GROW CLOSE WHICH I WILL FOR
EVER VALUE- AND IT'S
UNFORTUNATE BECAUSE OUR
COMMUNITIES HAVE BEEN SO HARD
HIT. WE HAVE THAT IN COMMON.
THE PUTTING ALL POLITICAL
DIFFERENCES ASIDE. THAT WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO BE ATTACHED AT THE
HIP AS WE MOVE FORWARD ON SO
MANY ISSUES THAT IS ONCE A
THANK YOU AND WHAT THAT HAS
MEANT FOR ME. IN GRATEFUL FOR
YOUR PARTNERSHIP OFFICER-
INFAMOUS WIENER CENTER WIENER
NINE OVER THE LAST MANY YEARS I
HAVE GONE THROUGH- INCREDIBLE
ISSUES AND CHALLENGES WHEN IT
COMES TO HOUSING AND WE'VE
ALWAYS BEEN ABLE TO WORK IT OUT
AND I JUST WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU TO SEND WINNER BECAUSE IT'S
NOT ALWAYS EASY AND WE ALL COME
FROM DIFFERENT SPOTS AND FACES
IN LIFE- AND I JUST I VALUE
ABOVE THE RELATIONSHIP AND
FRIENDSHIP THAT I HAVE. WITH
CHAIR OF HOUSING ALONG WITH THE
VICE CHAIR OF GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE. AND I JUST WANNA JUST
ON SOME. WERE LIVING IN A
BUBBLE HERE IN SACRAMENTO.
EVERYTHING TODAY'S INCOMING
WHERE WE'RE GOING TO START.
LOOKING AT NOT BUILDING IN HIGH
FIRE RISK AREAS WITH THEM IN A
BUBBLE. EDITORIAL BOARDS ARE
ALREADY OPINIE ACROSS THE STATE
THAT WE NEED TO START TEARS A
CONSIDERING. AT THIS BILL WOULD
HAVE GOTTEN REALLY CLOSE LAST
YEAR TO BE ABLE TO BAN- THROUGH
POLICY. NEW HOUSING IN HIGH
FIRE RISK ZONES. I UNDERSTAND
THE MINISTRATION DID NOT WANT
TO MESS UP THE NEXT RINA CYCLE-
AND THAT IS A CONCERN BY THE
WAY THAT THE CHAIR OF HOUSING%
BROUGHT FORWARD AS WELL I WANT
TO BE VERY TRANSPARENT ABOU
THAT. IN THIS BILL ZITO. THAT
LANGUAGE IS NOW OUT. SO WHAT WE
NEED TO DO IS WE NEED TO CHANGE
WITH THE TIMES THAT WE'RE
LIVING IN. REGARDLESS OF THE
BUILDING CODE THAT WE HAVE NOW.
LET'S GO BACK TO THE FACTS.
HALF OF THE HOMES THAT WE'VE
LOST IN THE LAST DECADE DELYLAH
FIRE IN THE WORLD. FIVE THE
REALITY IS THAT STATE LAW OR
ORDER REQUIRES. CITY
GOVERNMENTS TO CONSIDER THE OPI
OPR TECHNICAL ADVISORY- ITEMS
WHEN THEY UPDATE THEIR JOURNAL
PLANS FOR FIRE HAZARDS. IN ITS
NOT NEW BY THE WAY. THE OTHER
ISSUE IS THIS BILL IS NOT ABOUT
BANNING DEVELOPMENT IN THE
WORLD IT'S NOT IT CREATES A
PATH TO DEVELOP FAITHFULLY IN
EVERY JURISDICTION IN THE
STANDARDS ARE CRITICAL FOR
THAT- THE OTHER PIECE I THINK
IT'S WORTH REPEATING THESE-
PIERCE TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
TECHNICAL ADVISORY WHICH WAS
THE ADVISORY IN PLACE LAST
YEAR. SAID THIS I WANT TO
QUOTE. THE FOLLOWING NUMBER ARE
EXAMPLES OF POLICIES AT A LOCAL
GOVERNMENT MY DOC TO MITIGATE
DAMAGE TO VALUES AND ASSETS
RELATED WILDFIRE AVOID WERE
FEASIBLE APPROVING NEW
DEVELOPMENT IN AREAS SUBJECT TO
OFFER RISK IF OF WOULDN'T IT IS
NOT FEASIBLE CONDITION SUCH AS
NEW DEVELOPMENT ON OR
IMPLEMENTATION. OF MEASURES TO
REDUCE RISKS WITH THAT
DEVELOPMENT SHOULD BE
IMPLEMENTED YEAH. WE CAN DEBATE
THE NEW LANGUAGE BUT THE BOTTOM
LINE IS THAT THIS BILL SAYS THE
STANDARDS MUST BE FEASIBLE AND
THAT'S WHAT REALLY THIS IS ALL
ABOUT. THERE'S NO WAY TO BE
ABLE TO GET AROUND THAT. AND
AGAIN THIS BILL IS STRICTLY
LIMITED IT'S STRICTLY LIMITED
TO VERY HIGH FIRE HAZARD
SEVERITY ZONES IT DOES NOT
TOUCH FIVE FIRE HAZARDS ON SITE
IS GOING TO MAKE SURE. THAT ALL
OF YOU ARE. CLEAR ON THAT
BECAUSE I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE.
THAT IS CLEAR THE LAST THING ON
PHASES. IT'S AT THE MINIMUM FOR
DEVELOPMENTS IN THE WEEKS. AND
AS WE NOW ENGAGE. HALF OF THE
BUILDINGS AFTER LAST DECADE
WERE IN THE WEEDS ALL OF THOSE
WERE BUILT UNDER CURRENT FIRE
CODE. THIS BILL IS ALMOST
IDENTICAL TO A BILL THAT WAS
APPROVED WITH BIPARTISAN
MAJORITIES IN BOTH HOUSES SENT
TO THE GOVERNOR'S DESK LAST
YEAR. IN EVERY ONE OF THE
PROPONENTS. EVERYONE OF THE
OPPONENTS ON THIS BILL WERE
NEUTRAL ON THE LEGISLATION LAST
YEAR. I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
IN YOUR MY COMMITMENT THAT
WE'RE GONNA CONTINUE TO WORK
FOR THOSE. WHO MAY BE OPPOSED
TO THIS- AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
THOSE A COLLABORATIVE
CONVERSATIONS AND I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE IN AFFORDABLE COMPETITIVE
HOUSING. HERE IN THE COMING
WEEKS. AND THIS IS S. B. TWELVE
CENTER MCGUIRE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT
FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON HOUSING SENATOR
MCGUIRE ASKED REQUIRE HI
SENATOR NIELSEN HI ILSAN HI
SENATOR DORADO DORADO HI
SENATOR HERTZBERG. SENATOR
WIENER WIENER HI. FOUR ZERO.
FOR NOW PLACE THE CALL IF YOU
WOULD PLEASE. SENATE MCGUIRE
YOU NOW ALSO HAVE S. B. ONE OH
FOUR. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
SECURE ALL RIGHT UNLESS YOU
EVER THINK WE MAY HAVE A BILL
THAT WE CAN ALL AGREE UPON
FIRST AND FOREMOST- THIS BILL
IS FOCUSED ON MAKING SURE. THAT
CALIFORNIANS ARE KEPT WHOLE
AND- IT IS FOCUSED ON ALL
ISSUES OF TAXES- IN PERSON FOR
pSUGGESTED COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
THAT IS DETAILED IN THE
ANALYSIS SOME BACK STORY TO
THIS IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
CONGRESS AND THEN PRESIDENT
TRUMP SIGNED A BILL THAT TRULY
PUNISH CALIFORNIA'S.
INDIVIDUALS AND SMALL
BUSINESSES ON THE SO CALLED TAX
REFORM BILL CALIFORNIA VOTERS
HAVE PREVIOUSLY PROVED PROP
SIXTY THREE THE MILLIONAIRES
TAX TO SUPPORT MENTAL HEALTH AS
WELL AS PROP THIRTY IN FIFTY
FIVE IN A FIVE HIGHER INCOME
TAX RATES TO DOES A GREATER
MEANS TO FIND EDUCATION
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REALIGNMENT.
ALL FOR THAT BUT CONGRESS AND
PRESIDENT TRUMP DECIDED TO
LIMIT THE DEDUCTION OF STATE
AND LOCAL INCOME TAXES NOT NOW
KNOWN AS THE SOLE CAP IT'S A
FUNDAMENTAL PART OF THE FEDERAL
TAX SYSTEM IT'S BEEN IN PLACE
SINCE EIGHTEEN SIXTY TWO AND IT
PREVENTED BOTH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND STATE TAXES.
FROM BOTH THE FEDERAL ID THAT
PREVENTED BOTH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND STATE TAXES FROM
TAXING THE SAME INCOME. AS A
RESULT OF THIS CHANGE. MANY CAL
PAY HIGH FEDERAL TO. INCLUDING
SOME BUSINESSES HAVE BEEN
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED. BY
THE ECONOMIC IMPACTS OF KOBE
NINETEEN SB ONE OH FOUR SIMPLY
REVERSES THE STATE AND LOCAL
TAXES LIMITS. ADVANCED BY THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION BY HELPING
THE SMALL BUSINESSES DR STATE
AND LOCAL TAXES ABOVE THE SOFT
CAP HERE'S WHAT IT DOES NUMBER
ONE. IT CREATES AN ELECTIVE TAX
A PASS THROUGH. THE ATVS CAN
CHOOSE TO PAY BUT ONLY IF THEY
WANT TO SECOND PROVIDES OWNERS%
OF THOSE PASS THROUGH ENTITIES.
OKAY THE OPTIONAL TAX A TAX
CREDIT TO PREVENT DOUBLE
TAXATION. NOW I KNOW THIS IS
CONFUSING FOR THE ME JUST SAY
THIS. WE KNOW THAT THIS
APPROACH WORKS BECAUSE THE IRS
HAS ISSUED A NOTICE LAST YEAR
ALLOWING THE SAME DEDUCTIONS IT
THAT THIS BILL WOULD DO. IN
OKLAHOMA. CONNECTICUT LOUISIANA
THE NEW JERSEY IN RED AND BLUE
STATES. THAT WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING WITH THE FRANCHISE TAX
BOARD TO ENSURE THAT THIS BILL
IS NEARLY REVENUE NEUTRAL OVER
THE NEXT FIVE YEARS. THE BILL.
ALSO CONTAINS A SUNSET CLAUSE.
AFFECTED CHEN FIRST TWENTY. THE
SAME YEAR THAT THE- SALT CAP.
THE SAME TAX YEAR AS A CELL CAP
IN FEDERAL LAW. BY THE GOVERNOR
NOW IS INCLUDED A SIMILAR
PROPOSAL AS PART OF HIS
PROPOSED BUDGET. NOW SB ONE OF
FOUR DIFFERS FROM HIS PROPOSAL
IN TWO WAYS NUMBER ONE. THIS
BILLS AS A MORE STRATEGIC RATE
FOR THE ENTITY LEVEL TAX AT
NINE POINT 3% WHICH PROVIDES A
BIGGER INCENTIVE FOR SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS IN LOWER INCOME
TAX RATES BRACKETS. DIPPERS
PARTICIPATE COMPARED TO THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED THIRTEEN
POINT 3% RATE. SECOND IN THE
REASON WHY WE DID THAT IS
TRYING TO KEEP THIS IS REVENUE
NEUTRAL AS POSSIBLE JUST BEING
CANDID ABOUT IT. SECONDLY THE
GOVERNOR PROPOSAL APPLIES TO S.
CORPORATIONS BECAUSE ONLY
INDIVIDUAL TAXPAYERS CAN BE
OWNERS OF RECORD S. COVERAGE
EZCORP CALVARY CORPORATIONS. SO
TRACKING THE PAYMENT ELECTED
TAX AND THE CLEANING OF THE
CREDIT CAN BE TRACKED BY
TAXPAYERS AN FTP. THIS BILL
THOUGH. APPLIES MORE KINDS
ENTITIES SUCH AS PARTNERSHIPS
AND LLCS BUT KEEPS A LIMIT ON
ENTITIES WHOLLY OWNED BY
INDIVIDUALS AND ALSO ALLOWS
FAMILY BUSINESSES. ARE OWNED BY
STATE ESTATES INSURANCE TO
QUALIFY AS WELL. SO AGAIN THIS
IS A WIN WIN. FOR CALIFORNIANS
AND WE HAVE WITH US TODAY
PRESTIN YANG WITH THE
CONFERENCE CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IN KEVIN PROPRIETY WITH THE
NATIONAL FEDERATION OF
INDEPENDENT BUSINESSES AND THE
NATIONAL. EZCORP ASSOCIATION. I
TO BE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN. SB
TWELVE DO YOU HAVE SOME
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. YES
MISTER MEMBER OF MR A VICE
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE KEVIN MCCARTY I'M
REPRESENTING ENOUGH I'D BE AND
THEIR FIFTEEN THOUSAND
CALIFORNIA SMALL BUSINESS
MEMBERS AND WE WISH TO CONVEY
OUR STRONG SUPPORT FOR S. B.
ONE OH FOUR. THE CHAIRMAN
NOTED- THE- TWENTY SEVENTEEN
TAX CUTS AND JOBS ACT IMPOSED A
TEN THOUSAND DOLLAR CAP ON THE
AMOUNT OF CALORIES I'M STATE
LOCAL TAXES CALIFORNIA
TAXPAYERS CAN DEDUCT ON THEIR
FEDERAL RETURNS IN ADDITION TO
INDIVIDUALS CAP ALSO APPLIES TO
INCOME EARNED BY CALIFORNIA
PASS THROUGH BUSINESSES
ORGANIZED AS S. CORPORATIONS
PARTNERSHIPS AND LLCS. AS A
RESULT CALIFORNIA'S ONE
MILLION- PARTNERSHIPS AND S.
CORPORATIONS ARE SUBJECT TO TAX
RATES TWO POINT EIGHT THREE
POINT FOUR PERCENTAGE POINTS
HIGHER THAN IF THEY WERE
ALLOWED TO FULLY DEDUCT THESE
TAXES. THE HIGHER TAXES BUT
MANY CALIFORNIA MAIN STREET
BUSINESSES AT A DISADVANTAGE TO
PASS THROUGH BUSINESSES
OPERATING IN STATES WITH NO
INCOME TAX FOR THOSE OPERATING
IN STATES THAT HAVE ALREADY
ADOPTED ASSAULT REFORM. TO
ADDRESS THIS SB ONE OF FOUR
WOULD RESTORE THE FULL SALT
DEDUCTION TO CALIFORNIA AFTER
BUSINESSES SB ONE OF FOUR IS
REVENUE NEUTRAL TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT'S RESTORE
DEDUCTION REDUCES FEDERAL NOT
STATE TAXES OWNED AS A CHAIR
POINTED OUT NINE STATES OF ALL
PASSED SIMILAR STE- STOP
REFORMS WON'T TEN OTHER STATES
ARE ACTIVELY CONSIDERING THAT-
THIS YEAR. IN NOVEMBER OF
TWENTY TWENTY THE IRS ANNOUNCED
OF THE STATE AND LOCAL TAXES
IMPOSED AT THE ENTRY LEVEL ON
PASS THROUGH ENTITIES ARE
PERMITTED AS A DEDUCTION AND
THAT THIS TREATMENT IS
CONSISTENT WITH A LONGSTANDING.
POSITION OF THE AGENCY. SB OH
FOUR IS A WIN FOR. AND ITS
BUSINESS OWNERS. IT REDUCES.
FOR OUR THROUGH BUSINESS DURING
VERY DIFFICULT TIMES ALL AT NO
COST TO THE STATE. FOR THESE
REASONS. NFIB ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT SB ONE OH FOUR. AND
MISTER CARE I'D LIKE TO SAY
CONGRATULATIONS TO YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU SO MUCH
SIR THANK YOU GOOD TO HEAR FROM
NFIB DO WE HAVE OTHER
SUPPORTERS. ONLINE. YES THANK
YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
VICE CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS CRAFTING YANKING THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
HAPPY TO BE HERE TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF SB ONE UP FOR. YOU
MY BROTHER COMMENT BRIEFLY MR
MEGRAHI WAS TO SAME AND- WE
AGREE WITH HIS SENTIMENTS AS
YOU KNOW BUSINESSES OF ALL
SIZES HAVE. STRUGGLED
TREMENDOUSLY OVER THE PAST YEAR
DUE TO THE PANDEMIC THIS IS
INCLUDED- NEARLY A YEAR OF
LOCKDOWN ORDERS CUSTOMER
CAPACITY LIMITATIONS EXTEND THE
REGULATORY BURDEN. IN ADDITION
THE TAXI OBLIGATIONS HOWEVER-
AS MENTIONED EARLIER BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC EVER EXISTED. AND
THROUGH NO FAULT OF THE
LEGISLATURE VARIETY OF
TAXPAYERS WERE STRUGGLING WITH
THE FEDERAL TAX CUTS IN JOBS
ACT- HAVE YOU STATED. IT PLACE
A TEN THOUSAND DOLLAR CAP ON
THE AMOUNT OF STATE AND LOCAL
TAXES CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS
COULD DEDUCT ON THEIR FEDERAL
RETURNS. WE'RE HERE TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF SB ONE OF FOR IT
BECAUSE- RESTORED THE
DEDUCTIBILITY TO CALIFORNIA'S
PASS THROUGH ENTITIES WHICH ARE
VAST MAJORITY OF THE STATE'S
BUSINESSES. ADDITIONAL PROVIDE
AN AVENUE OF THE FINANCIAL
RELIEF TO STRUGGLING BUSINESSES
AND THEIR OWNERS ALL REMAINING
REVENUE NEUTRAL CALIFORNIA
ADDITIONALLY IT SHOULD BE NOTED
THAT THE IRS IS INDICATED THE
PROVISIONS CONTAINED WITHIN SB
ONE OF CORVALLIS. IN NINE OTHER
STATES ARE ALREADY IMPLEMENTING
THIS REFORM SO IN CLOSING
CALIFORNIA SMALL BUSINESSES ARE
STRUGGLING ENOUGH TO BE ONE OF
FOUR OFFERS THEM A FINANCIAL
BRIDGE ALONG WITH SMALL
BUSINESS GRANTS THAT WERE A
PART OF THE BUDGET PROCESS AND
FEDERAL RELIEF FUNDS SO FOR
THIS REASON WE'RE HERE TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF SB ONE OH FOUR. AND
APPRECIATE THE PLATFORM THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU FOR
THE TEST. CHAMBER OF. DO WE
FURTHER PEOPLE. READY TO. IF
YOU NEED TESTIFIED IN SUPPORT
OF SB OH FOUR. THANK YOU AND
OVER THE PHONE LINE. YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO FOR S. B.
ONE OH FOUR YOU'RE IN THE PARK.
WE'LL GO TO LINE OF ONE OH
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THE
CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR ALLOWING THE
TESTIMONY THIS IS CINDY
HILLARY'S FROM THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION AND WE'D
LIKE TO CLASSIFY IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE CONTRACT. WE
WOULD LIKE TO WORK WITH
COMMITTEE AND- AUTHOR STAFF TO
ENSURE THAT PHYSICIAN
PRACTICES. AND WHOLLY OWNED
BUSINESSES BY FOR THE SENATE
ARE COVERED BY THE- TALKED
CAPPADOCIAN. THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR TAKING ON THIS ISSUE. THANK
YOU DO WE HAVE FURTHER SUPPORT
TESTIMONY. THERE IS NO FURTHER
SUPPORT TESTIMONY IN Q. THANK
YOU MODERATOR THEN LET'S GO TO
THE OPPOSITION IF YOU ANNOUNCE
TO THE OPPOSITION THAT THEY MAY
CONTACT US IF THEY WISH TO.
OFFER OPPOSITION. SHIFFRIN
OPPOSITION OF S. B. ONE OH FOR
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
ONE AND ZERO FOR ANY OPPOSITION.
AND WE HAVE NOT OPPOSITION
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME. NO
OPPOSITION THERE AND I'VE SEEN
NO FURTHER FROM THE- HEARING
ROOM OR THE- CARD TWENTY FORTY.
WHICH CHAIRMAN WOULD YOU CARE
TO CLOSE. I WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE HAND- YEAH
IF IT WOULD BE POSSIBLE FOR YOU
SO MUCH AND LEVINE ALTHOUGH THE
MOVES IN SOME WE WILL THEY
PROCEED TO THE ROLL CALL. FOR
WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON S. B. ONE OH FOR THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED BUT FIRST
AMEND AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SENATOR MCGUIRE HI MCGUIRE HI
SENATOR NIELSEN AYE NIELSEN HI
SENATOR DORADO. ZERO ZERO HI.
SENATOR HERTZBERG. SENATOR WE-
OKAY WE WILL MOVE A CALL THANK
YOU SENATE MCGUIRE YOUR LAST
BILL IS SB FIVE FIVE FIVE ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU SO MUCH AS VICE
CHAIR OF THE GENTLEMAN HERE WE
GO TODAY EVERYTHING SB FIVE
FIVE FIVE LONG STORY SHORT IN-
SHORTEN MY TESTIMONY HERE
MISTER VICE CHAIR I KNOW THAT
REGIONALLY IT WILL CREATE A NEW
INNOVATIVE SYSTEM FOR
COLLECTING AND DISPENSING
REVENUES FROM TRANSIT OCCUPANCY
TAX IS ALSO KNOWN AS T. T. YOUR
BED TAXES FROM SHORT TERM
VACATION RENTALS. LONG STORY
SHORT ALMOST EVERY CITY IN
CALIFORNIA THE LEVY THEIR OWN
BED TAX REVENUE COLLECTED FROM
THAT THEIR TAX IS TYPICALLY USE
FOR THE VITAL SERVICES POLICE
FIRE PARKS KEEPING POTHOLES
FILLED- MIKE HOTELS AND MOTELS
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS HAVE
HISTORICALLY HAD A REALLY
CHALLENGING TIME COLLECTING
THESE BED TAXES FOR SHORT TERM
VACATION RENTALS BECAUSE HOUSE
THOSE FOLKS WHO OWN THE HOME
THEY'RE NOT ALWAYS AWARE OF THE
REQUIREMENT TO COLLECT A REMAKE
TAXES. MAYBE THEY DON'T WANNA
COLLECTOR REMIT TAXES AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS DO NOT ALWAYS KNOW
WHAT PROPERTIES ARE BEING USED
FOR SHORT TERM VACATION RENTALS
THERE FOR HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS ACROSS THE STATE
THEY SHOULD BE GOING TO CITIES
AND COUNTIES TO GO UNCOLLECTED
EVERY YEAR SO WHAT SB FIFTY
FIVE FIVE FIVE WOULD DO. IT
WILL HELP CITIES AND COUNTIES
COLLECT THIS UNTAPPED REVENUE
BY CREATING A STATE WIDE BED
TAX COLLECTION PROGRAM THAT
WOULD BE ADMINISTERED BY OUR
GOOD FRIENDS AT THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT. OF TAX AND FEE
ADMINISTRATION. NOW THIS WOULD
BE IN IN. IT WOULD NOT BE MAN.
LOCAL DO. COULD STILL PASS OWN
ORDINANCE IN COLLECT THEIR OWN
BED TAXES. THIS PROGRAM WOULD
JUST BE FOR CITIES AND COUNTIES
THAT MAY NOT WANT TO BE ABLE TO
DO THAT HAVE THE MEANS TO DO
THAT- OR DATE MAY NOT HAVE BEEN
CONTACTED BY FOR EXAMPLE A
SHORT TERM VACATION RENTAL
FACILITATOR LIKE. AIRBNB OR VR
BO. DATA HAVE THEIR OWN
AGREEMENTS WITH EACH INDIVIDUAL
COMPANY. THE WAY THIS WOULD
WORK. IS THAT CD TFA WOULD
COLLECT TAXES. IN JURISDICTIONS
THAT OPT INTO THE PROGRAM. THE
PLATFORM HERE BEING BE FOR
EXAMPLE FOR YOUR VIDEO WITHIN
REMIT THE TAX. STATION CD TFA
WITHIN DISTRIBUTE THE REVENUE
TO THE CITY OR COUNTY WHO- A IN
THIS A- THIS ISWILL PROVIDE
CITIES AND COUNTIES WISH TO
FOR. AT TO A ON REVENUE PER
WHICH WILL BE IN TURN BE RAIN.
INTO THOSE VITAL SO. AND IT'S
ALSO GOING TO SURE THAT ALL
HOSTING FOR. DO THEIR PART IN
LEVEL THE PLAYING FIELD FOR
HOST CONSUMERS AND LOCAL
COMMUNITIES. MR CHAIR WE'VE
JEAN HURST ON THE LINE FOR OUR
RULE COUNTY WHERE AS A
CALIFORNIA AS WELL AS THE
PRESIDENT AND CEO OF THE
CALIFORNIA'S CHAMBER OF. WE'RE
GRATEFUL THAT THERE- WE WOULD
US AS WELL I WOULD RESPECT ASK
FOR IN A VOTE AT APPROPRIATE
TIME. AND MISTER CHAIRMAN OF
THE ARE. AGAIN YOUR OF THOSE
ALL AND THEN AND- YES THEY ARE
THESE ARE- COMMITTEE. OKAY
THERE ARE NOT. A. PROCEED DO WE
HAVE A SHOW WITNESS MR PADRONE
OF THE N. F. AND I'LL GET THE
CROWD HERE TO IN THE ROOMS BUT
COLLECTED WITH THE. FIRST GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU SO MUCH AGAIN-
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS I JEAN
HURST HERE TODAY I REPRESENTING
THE RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
AND ITS DIVISION OF THIRTY FIVE
AND THE WORLD COUNTIES HERE IN
THE COURT AND INTERMENT AT THE
FIVE BY. I YOU WILL KEEP MY A
RUMOR BRIEF AS MANY OF ARE-
AWARE IN MANY WORLDS I BIRDS
THE ONE THAT ARE AT DEPENDING I
TRANSIT ARGUE TAX THERE ARE HE
COME OF THAT COUNTY DRUG STREAM-
END UP COURSE I THOSE COUNTY
HAVE THE STRUGGLING MIGHTILY
I'M DURING THE PENNED THEM AND
LIMIT YOU- I ACT THAT TO THEIR
TO. BY AM BUSY. SO IT COULD BE
READ THE CLIENT IN OUR- BEGIN
AT OPEN AN WELL VISITORS.
ENTITIES I THAT EXIST IN OUR
COMMUNITY EQUITABLY AND
EFFECTIVELY- WE THINK THAT
PROPOSAL OFFERED BY SB FIVE
FIVE FIVE- PUTS US ON AT ALL. A
PATH TOWARDS ACHIEVING THAT
EQUITY- IN AN EFFICIENT MANNER
AND WOULD RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR VOTE TODAY THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK YOU THE FIRST DO WE
HAVE THE JULIAN CONNECT CEO OF
HISPANIC. CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
CALIFORNIA. IN SUPPORT YES
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK
YOU- NAME AGAIN IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE. CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
PLEASE GREAT RISK YOUR NAME FOR
THE RECORD. BOB THANK YOU
MISTER DOING PRESIDENT CEO
CALIFORNIA HISPANIC CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE THE CHEC- THROUGH OUR
ADVOCACY EDUCATION PROGRAMS ON
OUR MEMBERSHIP OF OVER HUNDREDS
BY CHAMBERS AND BUSINESS
ASSOCIATIONS. CHEC REPRESENTS
INTERESTS THAT OVER EIGHT
HUNDRED FIFTEEN THOUSAND
ISLAMIC BUSINESSES IN
CALIFORNIA. AND WE WOULD
DIRECTLY WORK IN A COMMUNICATE
WITH OVER FIFTY THOUSAND SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS- THE CHEC HAS
ALWAYS FOCUSED ITS PROACTIVE
EDUCATION ADVOCATES EFFORTS ON
PROGRAMS AND POLICIES. THAT
ANSWER AND MEET THE PRIORITY TO
NEED TO CALIFORNIA. SMALL
BUSINESS AND HISPANIC COMMUNITY.
WE ARE WE ARE TO RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF CHAIRMAN WHY S. FIVE
FIVE FIVE. SB FIVE FIVE FIVE
OFFERS OUR STATE AND LOCAL
COMMUNITIES A QUICK AND
EFFECTIVE SOLUTION FOR
COLLECTING AND DISPENSING
TRANSIENT OCCUPANCY OCCUPANCY
TAX DOT REVENUE FROM SHORT TERM
RENTAL HOSTING PLATFORMS. AS A
RESULT OF THE COPA NINETEEN
CITIES AND COUNTIES ARE
PROJECTED TO FACE SEVERE BUDGET
SHORTFALLS ASTERISM RETURNS THE
CALIFORNIA T. O. T. WILL SEE
HER SERVE. AS AN IMPORTANT AND
NOBLE TOOL THAT WILL ALLOW
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS TO MENTALLY
TAP INTO VISITOR DOLLARS AND
REINVEST TAX REVENUES BACK INTO
THEIR COMMUNITIES. OUR
TWENTIETH OCCUPANCY TAXES PAID
PLAYS AN IMPORTANT ROLE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES AND HAS THE
POTENTIAL TO BE REINVESTED IN
FIRE AND POLICE SERVICES LOCAL
SCHOOLS LIBRARIES AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT PROJECTS THAT WILL
PROPEL THE ECONOMY. AND SAFE
NEIGHBORHOODS. AND WHAT IS GOOD
FOR COMMITTEES IS GOOD FOR
SMALL BUSINESS WE URGE SWIFT
PASSAGE OF SB FIVE FIVE FIVE.
EIGHT OUR CALIFORNIA'S COAST
ENDEMIC ECONOMIC RECOVERY TO
SUPPORT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS SMALL
BUSINESSES AND VITAL PUBLIC
SERVICES THAT RELY ON P. O. T.
RABBANI. I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION- BOB THIS
AFTERNOON- AND FOR TAKING OUR
COMMENTS. THANK YOU HAVE TAKEN
ANY. THAT WOULD BE OUR TO
PROPOSE WITNESSES THE OFFICIAL
NOW DO WE HAVE MODERATE ANY
OTHERS IN Q. IN SUPPORT. OF THE
BILL. THANK YOU IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. FIVE FIVE FIVE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
OUR FIRST FINAL COME FROM LINE
OF NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON. SHOT ON BEHALF
OF THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS OF
BUT NOW MY COUNTY IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND AS A
REMINDER YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT
OF AB. FIVE FIVE FIVE. AND WE
DO HAVE THE NEXT LINE OF. ONE
MOMENT. FIND ONE SEVENTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN AND
COMMITTEE MEETING MEMBERS
CHAPTER ELEVEN THANK YOU BEACH
SHORT TERM LINE IN SUPPORT OF
SB FIVE FIVE FIVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. AND AGAIN AT ONE AND
THEN ZERO FOR ANY SUPPORT. AND
SB FIVE FIVE FIVE AND WE WILL
GO TO THE NEXT LINE. AND
THAT'LL BE ONE FIFTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ON BEHALF OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO CHAMBER OF COMMERCE I
OFFER OUR STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
FIVE FIVE FIVE WE SUPPORT
EFFORTS PROPOSED PANDEMIC
ECONOMIC RECOVERY AND THIS BILL
OFFERS NEW INNOVATIVE
INSTRUMENT AVENUES FOR MUCH
NEEDED REINVESTMENT IN OUR
COMMUNITY. THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION. THANK
YOU THIS THEIR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION IF YOU'RE
ANNOUNCING SUPPORT PLEASE ANY
OTHERS. THANK YOU OUR NEXT ONE
OUR NEXT FINAL COME FROM- LINE
ONE TWELVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI THIS IS ANISHA RUDO CALLING
ON BEHALF OF THE BAY AREA
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE
FIVE FIVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE NOT FINAL COME
FROM ONE TEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS JEAN YOUNG
WITH THE LONG BEACH AIRBNB
HOSTING COSTS. THERE ARE A
GROUP OF TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
HOME CHALLENGE THEM HOES. NEED
TO SHOUT BACK ACTIVE PLAYERS
AND- HOW LONG BEACH IN ORDER TO
ACQUIRE- AT FIVE FIVE. I
BELIEVE TO A PATIENT. HELLO
IMPORTANT SOURCE TALK REVENUE
FOR THE STATE. THANK YOU THANK
YOU. NEXT INCLUDE SELECT A BILL.
ALTHOUGH LINE OF ONE SIX YOUR
LINE OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN STEVE REISER I'M A
RESIDENT AND SHORT TERM RENTAL
OPERATOR AND WALNUT CREEK- I'M
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE
FIVE FIVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AT THE ANNEX OF A LOT OF ONE OH
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES BY
HEATHER CARSON ON BEHALF OF
HOLLOW THE HOME SHARE LYONS LOS
ANGELES AND WE SUPPORT SB FIVE
FIVE FIVE. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEXT TO THE LINE OF ONE
SEVENTEEN. THEY DROPPED ONE
EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR- TOM'S BUT
ON BEHALF OF AIRBNB IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU AND WE HAVE NO
FURTHER SUPPORT IN Q. ALL RIGHT
DELUDED YOU ANNOUNCE ONE MORE
TIME FOR SUPPORT. YES IF YOU
ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB FIVE ARE
AT THAT'S THE B. FIVE FIVE FIVE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
IN SUPPORT OF S. B. FIVE FIVE
FIVE ONE AND THEN ZERO. AND WE
HAVE. NO SUPPORTING QUEUE AT
THIS TIME DO WE HAVE ANY
OPPOSITION THANK YOU MODERATOR.
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO SHOW
OPPOSITION OF S. B. FIVE FIVE
FIVE. YOU MAY PRESS THE ONE AND
THEN ZERO FOR ANY OPPOSITION.
ONE MOMENT WE HAVE ONE IN CUBA
WE GET THEIR LINE NUMBER. IT IS
A REMINDER IT IS ONE AND THEN
ZERO FOR ANY OPPOSITION OF SB.
FIVE FIVE FIVE. AND THAT'LL
COME FROM THE LINE OF NINETY
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HM
MEMORIES NEGRONI AND WITH THE
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES ARE
NOT AN OPTION TODAY- IN
BETWEEN. THE SENATE WORK ON
THAT MEASURE. I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE OCT AN OPT OUT
PROVISION SO THAT OUR BABIES
CAN DECIDE LOCALLY WHEN THEY
WANT TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THIS
PROGRAM. HELLO I WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR GOING FORWARD TO ENSURE
THAT LOCAL IS ACTUALLY ABLE TO
NEGOTIATE LOCALLY WITH WITH
PLATFORMS. ON THAT DAY CONTINUE-
BUT WANTED TO- THAT MODEL. WE
ALSO WANT. WHAT DID HE OF THE
BILL CAN HELP ADDRESS- THE
CASES IN WHICH A- SHORT TERM
RENTAL. THE CLUB OWNER OP- THAT
DID NOT THROUGH A- A PLATFORM-
THEMSELVES. THE COURT TO THE
WORKING TOGETHER THANK YOU HAVE
ANY FURTHER OPPOSITION. WE HAVE
NO FURTHER OPPOSITION IN KILL.
THANK YOU AND THEN WE WILL
PROCEED THERE ARE NO- BODIES
PRESENT HERE AND THEN THE AND
TWENTY FORTY. PHENOM THAT
SHOULD CONCLUDE THE TESTIMONY
MISTER CHAIRMAN WOULD USE LUNCH
FOR THE BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
DO WE HAE ANY QUESTIONS. OR
MOTION FROM MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. SENATOR OROVILLE
THANK YOU- I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR CLARIFYING FOR ME I
THINK A COUPLE OF THEWITNESSES
MADE REFERENCE TO. THE ABILITY
OF LOCAL AGENCIES AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT- TO DECIDE WHAT THEY
WANT TO DO AW ON OTHER ISSUES
RELATED TO AIRBNB IT IN LOS
ANGELES IT'S A- A HUGE ISSUE.
ON THE AIRBNB- ACTUALLY TAKES
OUT OF THE HOUSING STOCK OUT OF
THE HOUSING MARKET PERMANENT-
HOUSING THAT WE ARE IN SO
DESPERATE NEED OF- AND ALSO HAS
AN IMPACT ON OUR HOTELS TO
INVEST. AN ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF
MONEY INTO BRICK AND MORTAR
HOTELS AND WE'VE BEEN PAYING
THE T. O. T. FOR MANY DECADES
WE'VE COUNTED ON THEM WHEN WE
NEED THEM SO. WE DON'T WANT
THEM TO BE NEGATIVELY IMPACTS
SO- THANK YOU- CENTER MCGUIRE
THE AUTHOR FOR. CLARIFYING THAT
AND MAKING SURE THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS CONTINUE TO HAVE
THAT AUTHORITY AND I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL. SENATOR
ROGER WOULD THAT BE YEAR. OF
MOTION TO SUPPORT. SURE SO WILL
WERE TO GET VOTING ELOQUENT TO
MOTION TO SUPPORT. THE MISTER
CHAIRMAN WOULD YOU LIKE TO GIVE
A SUPPOSED. THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER CHAIR JUST WANNA SAY
THANK YOU FOLKS ON ALL SIDES-
FOR- WILLING TO COME TOGETHER
ONE AND STATE OF THE CITY
THROUGH THE QUARTER CONTINUE TO
WORK TOGETHER IN WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I WILL.
WHAT WHAT DO WE HAVE A MOTION.
LET'S GO GRANITE CALL THEROLL
ON SB FIVE FIVE FIVE REQUIRE.
SHIN IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY SENATOR MCGUIRE BY
REQUIRED BY SENATOR NIELSEN HI
NIELSEN- A SENATOR ALSO. DRAWS
SO HI SENATOR HERTZBERG HI
HERTZBERG AYE SENATOR WIENER.
WIENER HI FIVE ZERO WE WILL
OPEN UP PLACE ON CALL. AND THEN
WE WILL GO. RED SHOULD CONCLUDE.
MR MANY ONE. THE END OF THE
CALL THANK YOU SO MUCH LAYS IN
GERMAN NINE WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU THE VICE CHAIR IS ALWAYS UP
FOR THE CONTINUE PARTNERSHIP
THANK YOU SO MUCH WORK IN THOSE
BILLS AS WELL AS THE GERMAN
WHAT WE'RE GOING TO ASK IS CAN
YOU GIVE US TWO MINUTES SO THAT
WE CAN GET OUR ACT TOGETHER AS
FAR AS COMPOUNDING WHICH FEELS
WE NEED TO GET FOLKS ON. THE
VAST MAJORITY OF YOU ARE GOING
TO BE ABLE TO SCOOT OUT HERE IN
WILL GET US IN HERTZBERG
ROLLING QUICKLY SO I GIVE US
TWO MINUTES TWO MINUTES TO BE
TO GET OUR- BILLS COORDINATED
ANIMAL ARE START DOING ALL. ON
CALL VOTE.
YOU'RE GOOD TO GO.
HELLO EVERYONE. PARTISAN GERMAN
OF THE TO DO THIS- WE ARE
THROUGH SENATOR THE VICE CHAIR
NIELSEN HAS VOTED ON ALL BILLS
AND WE WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO
THE VICE CHAIR. THREE WINNERS
MISSING ONE IN THAT IS. ITEM
NUMBER NINE S. B. ONE OH FOUR.
LET'S GO TO MISTER NOW WITH THE
MOTION PLEASE AND PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS SENATOR
HERTZBERG. HERTZBERG BY SENATOR
WIENER WIENER HI BY ZERO. YES
SIR FIVE ZERO THE BILL IS THAT
WE'RE NOW CLOSING THE ROLE
THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER WIENER
SAFE TRAVELS HOME. THE GERMAN
NEVER GONNA START- LET'S START
WITH THE CONSENT CALENDAR
DENVER GOING TO GO IN THE GYM
TO FILE ORDER SO WE'LL GO FROM
CONSENT CALENDAR IT DIDN'T WERE
GONNA GO TO FOURTEEN THAN TO
ONE AND THEN SO ON AND SO FORTH
SO LET'S GO TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. WE HAVE THREE ITEMS
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR. FIFTY
THREE SEVEN SB. FOUR FOUR. IN
MY HANDS WERE SO CALLED. FIFTY
FOUR THREE ONE FIVE THE SERVER
NOW PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS BURGER HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG BY FIVE ZERO FIVE
ZERO THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS
OUT OF THE SCHOOLS ROLE IS IN
GENERAL ON TO ITEM NINE
FOURTEEN THAT'S SB TWO SEVENTY
FOUR WE TOOK THAT OUT FIRST
FIVE SONORA CASKEY CURRENT.
VOTE IS THREE ZERO. THE SENATOR
DORADO. DRAWS A HI SENATOR.
HIGH HERTZBERG HI BY ZERO FIVE
ZERO IS THE BILL AS HAVE
RECALLS THE ROLE NOW ARE MOVING
ON TO. ITEM NUMBER ONE IS P. TO
SIXTY EIGHT MR ARCHULETA
CURRENT VOTE IS THREE ZERO
MISSING MEMBERS ARE DRAWS OF
HERTZBERG THAT MR GRAHAM.
SENATOR ALSO. DRAWS SO HI
SENATOR HERTZBERG AS AMENDED
INSTRUMENTS AS AMENDED YES SIR
HI BIRDS BURKE HI FIVE TWO ZERO
THANK YOU SO MUCH THAT BILL IS
THAT WERE CLOSE THE ROLE WE'RE
NOW MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER
TWO IS TWO THREE TWO THREE
COVER YOUR- CURRENT VOTE IS
THREE ONE. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MISTER MEMBERS MISTER
FOR NOW SENATOR HERTZBERG
HERTZBERG HI FORTY ONE FOUR ONE
NINE BILL IS THAT WE'RE CLOSING
THE ROLE MOVING ONTO NOW ITEM
NUMBER FOUR IS P. TWO FORTY
EGGMAN CURRENT VOTE IS FOUR
ZERO PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS MISTER GRINNELL.
SENATOR HERTZBERG HERTZBERG HI.
FIVE ZERO. THE BILL IS OUT WITH
A FIVE ZERO RECALL THE ROLE.
BERNAMA ON TO ITEM NUMBER FOR
RIGHT IN THE FIVE SB SEVEN TWO
GLAZER. KERN VOTE. THREE ONE.
THE SERRANO. SENATOR HERTZBERG
HERTZBERG BY FORTY ONE FOR ONE
FINAL VOTE BILL IS OUT IN THE
ROLE WE'RE NOW MOVING ON TO
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN SP FOUR THREE
EIGHT. THIS ENJOYS A FOUR ZERO
VOTE PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS SENATOR HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG HIGH BY TWO ZERO FIVE
ZERO ZERO SEVEN ZERO IS THAT
WE'RE CLOSING THE ROLE WE'RE
NOW MOVING ON TO ITEM. THIRTEEN
S. B. EIGHT. SKINNER CURRENT
VOTE IS. THREE ZERO THIS ORDER
NOW. WE HAD. FIVE ITEMS S. I'M
SO. THERE ARE THE HERE I PAULA-
I WANNA I LET ME BACK UP I'M
GOING TO GO TO. FIFTY EIGHT
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THE TWILIGHT
AND FACT- YES THANK YOU LET'S
GO TO ITEM EIGHT SB TWELVE
THANK YOU TO THE MAJORITY
LEADER AND CHAIR EMERITUS.
SORRY BOUT THAT HURTS THE ITEM
EIGHT SB TWELVE THAT'S WHAT
HAPPENS YOU'LL GET A SLEEP
SENSOR FOR A SAY THAT IT IS THE-
CURRENT VOTE IS FOUR EIGHT
ZERO. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS SENATOR NIELSEN.
NIELSEN AYE SENATOR HERTZBERG
HIGH HERTZBERG HIGH FIVE ZERO
FIVE ZERO VOTE IS THAT BILL IS
THAT WE'RE CLOSER WE'RE NOW
MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER. TEN
FIFTY FIVE FIVE FIVE. RESERVE
NOW CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THAT BUT WE DECIDED THAT
ONE NEVER TURNS OUT IF YOU SEE
THAT ONE THAT'S GOOD BECAUSE I
GO TO ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN THAT
SOUNDS GOOD SB FOUR NINETY ONE
VICE CHAIR NIELSEN CURRENT
LOTUS FOUR ZERO. SERRANO
SENATOR. HERTZBERG HIGH FIVES.
LARA THE PAIN ALMOST OVER I
DON'T THIRD S. EIGHT KERR VOTE
IS THREE MISTER NOW CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS-
VIRTUALLY. HERTZBERG FIVE BY.
FIVE ZERO I THINK IT THAT MAY.
YEAH YEAH. SENATE BILL EIGHT
OKAY BORDER. ZERO YOUR- NIELSEN
HI FIVE ZERO INTEREST ALL RIGHT
THERE WE GO WE HAVE A FIVE
EIGHT ZERO VOTE THAT BILL IS
OUT WE'RE CLOSING THE RULES
THANK YOU SO MUCH ALL RIGHT
PLEASE IN GERMAN WE APPRECIATE
EVERYONE COMING TOGETHER OUR
NEXT THREE HEARINGS WILL BE FOR
FIVE HOURS SO WE HAVE THREE
HEARINGS HERE COMING UP- WEEK
AFTER NEXT THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR THE GERMAN AND ONE OF THE
THINKING MISTER GRINNELL
MENTIRA GOVERNED BY TEAM FOR
ALL THEIR WORK IN THE SERGEANTS
IN THE BACKSEAT. OF FOR ALL. OF
THE WORK THIS MEETING IS
ADJOURNED. HAVE A GREAT.